Good morning. Seeing that board members are now present, Brooks, will you please call
the roll to establish a quorum? Member Sun. Here. Vice President Strauss. Here. Member
Rucker. Present. Member Rodriguez. Here. Member Petillo-Brownson. Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Glover-Woods. Here. Member Fatah. Here. President Darling-Hammond. Here. We have a
quorum. Very good. I hereby call the July 2021 meeting of the State Board of Education to order
at 8.32 a.m. and I'd like to commence by saluting the flag. Member Fatah, will you please lead us
in the Pledge of Allegiance? Definitely. Okay. Everyone stand. Awesome. Ready, begin. I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands,
one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all. Please be seated.
Thank you very much. We'll now be adjourning into closed session and board members please
disconnect from this link and go to the closed session Zoom link and during closed session,
board will discuss and or take action on the following case, MFC. See you in closed session.
Thank you very much. Seeing that the board members are all present,
Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish a quorum? Member Sun. Present.
Vice President Strauss. Here. Member Rucker.
Member Rucker, you're on mute.
I'm sorry, present. Thank you. Member Rodriguez. Here. Member Petillo-Brownson.
Here. Member McQuillin. Here. Member Glover-Woods. Here. Member Fatah. Here.
President Darlin-Hammond. Here. All right. We will now reconvene in open session and during the
closed session, the board discussed and took action on the following case, MSC. Agenda one
is our state board priorities item and I want to turn it over to State Superintendent Thurmond
to provide his report. Thank you, President Darlin-Hammond. Good morning, board members.
Good morning, everyone who is following our meeting. It is so exciting to say that this is
our last meeting before the opening of school and that welcoming everyone back to school.
Hard to imagine, but next week I'll have the opportunity to visit with students and staff
in the Chula Vista Unified School District where they are going to be opening next Wednesday.
And so if you didn't know, now you know the opening of school is upon us. We all know how
difficult the last year and plus has been. I'm so grateful that we can now pivot to looking forward.
And while there were many challenges behind us, we're more than our circumstances. While we still
have questions about what we need to do going forward, it is clear there is a pathway for every
one of our schools to be open for in-person instruction, to do so safely, to provide the
rigor that our students need to support them going forward. We know that our students can
recover from trauma. They can recover from learning gaps that have been exacerbated
by the pandemic. And we are grateful that our state has provided the resources to really help
accelerate those efforts. Our state budget has been robust in its focus on education
in every way that you can imagine. Deep investments in early education, universal
TK, universal meals, universal after school programs. You think about it, this budget
envisions a way for us to reimagine education. To say that while this has been a difficult moment
that we've all experienced together, that we can build it back better. That we can create an
education system that recognizes that what we had before wasn't always good enough for all. And that
we have an opportunity to do more and to do better for all of our students. I'm so excited about all
these things. And I know that our President Darling-Hammond will talk about many of them.
She's helped to really steward many of the investments that have landed in the budget.
We've been excited to work closely with her, with the members of the legislature, the governor and
the governor's staff. And I want to acknowledge everyone at the California Department of Education,
State Board of Education, the Department of Public Health and Health and Human Services.
All these things coming together to really help create the pathway for getting back to
in-person instruction. And of course, our school leaders, our superintendents and administrators,
our great teachers, many of whom have been teaching through the summer. And of course,
our classified staff who've helped to deliver 500 million meals to our students during the pandemic.
Our schools have been everything. And the budget that we're going to have to support our schools,
both from the state level and from the federal level, really does envision all of the things
that our schools need to recover and to dream big for how we go forward, including how we close
the digital divide, investments that will help us to make the upgrades necessary to our infrastructure
to have broadband all across our state. We know that internet connectivity needs to flow like
electricity so that everyone has access, not just for distance learning when that is the case,
but just to prepare for the jobs of tomorrow and so that our students are prepared.
So many great things to tell you about. Do want to let you know that as we look to the future for
CDE, we have some events coming up that we want to share. One being that we have been focused,
like everyone, on how to increase the number of vaccines taken up by our young people,
especially those who are ages 12 and older. We've been a part of many efforts. Dr. Darlingham and I
are part of a number of media outreach efforts. Next week, we will be hosting a, on the 21st,
we'll be hosting a teen outreach vaccine effort where young people will be talking to other young
people to say why it's so important to get a vaccine. On that same day, I'm excited to let
you know that we will be holding a meeting of the American Indian Education Oversight Committee,
a committee that has been revived and will have probably two dozen participants talking about ways
that California can support the experience of Native American students and what we teach as it
relates to Native American studies and history. Finally, at the end of the month, on the 26th,
the week of the 26th of July, we anticipate holding a webinar for many districts that still
have questions about how to use their resources, how to get school open, and we'll be leading and
centering the conversation with some best practices that aren't really new, but we know when we double
down on them, they have the kind of investments that will help our students build skill, right?
We can't replace lost time that someone, you know, missed out on in terms of having time in a seat,
but we can build skill like literacy, focusing on the things that we've always talked about,
building literacy by third grade, doing interventions for our older students. We know
that when our students build skill around reading, around learning another language,
around learning computer science, you know, we know that these are things that will help our students
to not only recover but to excel as we move forward, and so these are the places that we
intend to go. You know, I am unfortunately going to have to leave you in just a few minutes because
today I have the honor of presenting a bill in the Senate, AB 520, a bill that is a bill focused on
diversifying the teacher workforce. It's a bill that we're sponsoring at the Department of Education.
It builds on the work of Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond. I've been borrowing her work for years,
and this bill focuses on diversifying the teacher workforce and continues to emphasize a very
specific way that we should also be looking to expand our efforts on expanding the number of
male educators of color in our state. Research has shown us that diversifying the teacher workforce
has a benefit for students of color and for all students, and we believe that this is one more
component that will be a benefit to our students, but I'd be remiss if I didn't before I, you know,
get ready to go say that I wanted to say thank you to some of the board members for their service.
Matt Navo, thank you, and congratulations. Thank you for your service. We look forward to working
with you in your new capacity as the chief leader at CCEE. We look forward to working with you there,
and Zaid Fattah, I want to thank you for your incredible service. While we'll miss your direct
input, we couldn't be more proud of what you've accomplished so far and all the great things that
we know lie ahead of you, and Yale, I mean, no small feat, and congratulations to you. We hope
that you'll stay in touch and just, you know, send the word every now and then so that we can hear
from you, that we know that you're doing well, and if you want to just give input on any of the
things that we're doing, like the new statewide youth advisory council that we will be formally
launching in days and weeks, we won't put you to work, but you can just helicopter in sometime and
just give us a thought that might be on your mind, and so again, thank you for your incredible
service board members. Thank you all board members for what you do, and I'm happy to turn it back to
you, President Darling-Hammond. Thank you so much, Superintendent Thurmond, and we're excited that
you're going to introduce that bill. That's a really important part of the picture that creates
the new normal in California, so thanks for all of the leadership that you've exhibited over these
last months and on this next front. Good luck with that. Thank you. We'll see you soon. See you soon.
And I will make additional remarks to augment what our superintendent has
laid out. As you know, this month marks a major set of milestones in California public education
with the passage of an incredible state budget. The offering of more summer school programs than
ever before, nine out of ten districts in California have been offering some summer school,
summer learning, summer enrichment programs, many of them to all students who are
able to and interested in attending, and then of course the planning for the full return to school.
On Friday, I was honored to join Governor Newsom at Shearer Elementary School in Napa
for the signing of AB 130, which was the key component of the state's historic 123.9 billion
dollar pre-K and K-12 education package. This is 20 billion dollars more, almost 30 percent more
than we have spent on education in the past. Now, many of the investments are made over a
five-year period, so the goal is not to sort of throw money at the wall, but to create infrastructure
and to create new systems for education. It is the largest budget for education in the state's
history. It's historic not only because of its size, because it focuses very intensely on equity
and it has the potential to transform the education system in the state. It brings to life a whole
child vision for California education, one that attends to the needs of children and families
with a whole school, whole community approach that wraps around them with education supports.
Elsewhere in the budget, which is again one of the largest budgets generally in California history,
this is supplemented by support to eliminate homelessness, improve health care, close the
digital divide, and support children's employment. All of us, of course, are critical to improving
the lives and the learning of children. So we are really looking at this as not a return to the old
normal, but the creation of a new normal. In addition to providing the highest level of per
student funding in history, and I think we will be above the national average having been close to
the bottom just a few years ago, we will have a greater concentration of funds on students in
poverty, English learners, students in foster care, students experiencing homelessness.
The budget also includes the first down payment on a four-year commitment to establish universal
pre-kindergarten by gradually expanding TK to four-year-olds in the state. Kim, your smile is as
big as a smile can be. And for all of us, it is a happy day. It will begin to close the opportunity
and equity gap before children reach K-12 school. It will ultimately invest $2.7 billion.
Adult-child ratios will be cut significantly to no more than one to 12.
There's an increase of $1.1 billion to improve staff-to-student ratios at all schools,
serving high concentrations of vulnerable students, including up to five additional
counselors, nurses, teachers, or paraeducators at each school. Many of you know that California has
by a long shot the highest ratio of students to staff of any state in the country by a very
large margin. So this is the beginning of a process of really bringing those ratios much
more in line. There's over $1.5 billion in ongoing and one-time increases to special education funding,
including $260 million for early intervention for preschool-age children. Very important,
because we know when we invest early on, the rates at which students can succeed in mainstream
classrooms and actually often not need to be continued in a special education diagnosis
are much higher. We've got almost $3 billion to eliminate our widespread teacher shortages,
including building the early childhood workforce. This includes $850 million in grants to prepare
teachers who commit to teaching in shortage areas through service scholarships and residencies,
and $250 million to attract expert national board-certified teachers
to teach and mentor in high-poverty schools. So we build a stable expert teaching force in the
schools that now can experience often a continual churn of teachers. There's more than a billion
dollars for professional development around learning acceleration in the content areas,
social-emotional learning, restorative practices, multi-tiered systems of support, and more that
will enrich our schools and the knowledge base of our staff and ultimately the lives of the
children. $3 billion to convert more than 3,000 school sites serving students with the greatest
needs. One-third of the state schools will be eligible to become full-service community schools
with expanded learning time, family engagement, wraparound health, mental health, social services,
focus on strong relationships, social-emotional learning, restorative practices, and this is
intended to become a way of doing education in more and more schools throughout our state
over time. This is something that Superintendent Thurmond campaigned on when he came into office,
among many other things, as well as the governor, and really will provide, you know, kids in the
situations where they have the greatest needs and who've been most impacted by the pandemic.
The range of supports focused directly on them and their families and their needs rather than
having to, you know, deal with bureaucracies and barriers to getting the supports that they need.
$1.8 billion in ongoing funds for summer and after-school programs at all schools that serve
concentrations of vulnerable students, and that'll grow to $5 million by 2025,
and then funding for universal free nutrition as Superintendent Thurmond said, access to two free
and healthy meals for children for all students. This really is the beginning of a renaissance in
California education, which was once the leader in the nation during the 1970s before Proposition
13 began the disinvestments that led to the repeated budget cuts that many of us
experienced that left us near the bottom of the nation in funding and pupil-staff ratios
and achievement. We were 48th and 49th in 8th grade reading and math by 2010. Governor Brown's
investments in a more adequate and equitable finance system through LCFF began to turn things
around in 2013. This board's actions to create a more child-centered and community-connected
accountability system continued that course, and we have seen improvements on every dimension.
We are moving up both in graduation rates and achievement, closing many achievement gaps,
although not all of them fast enough, and we really see this budget as making a big difference
there. And these next moves, if we hold the course, will catapult California, I believe,
to its historic leadership role in the nation once again. Closer to today, we're about a month away
from the start of the new school year, and as Superintendent Thurmond said, some people are
already beginning, so children are coming back to school. As you know, to ensure that students have
access to safe and full in-person instruction and as much instructional time as possible,
the California Department of Public Health on Monday issued updated K-12 guidance in line with
the new guidance from the Centers for Disease Control. And we really see the surest path to
safe, full in-person instruction at the outset of the school year, as well as minimizing missed
school days for quarantine or illness is a strong emphasis on reliable prevention. And this includes
continued work to achieve vaccination for all eligible individuals, universal masking in schools,
at least at the start of the school year, which will allow all students access to full in-person
learning without hybrid strategies and to get and keep them safely in school, and access to a robust
testing program as an available safety layer. Now, you probably are aware that there have been
questions about the decision to maintain masking in schools, and I think it's worth a moment to
explain why it's so important that we do what is needed to ensure that every child can be in
school every day and stay in school. You know that masking is the most fundamental and the
most effective tool to prevent the spread of the virus, which is airborne and spreads between
people in that way. The countries who have kept their schools and societies open throughout the
pandemic have used masking as a core strategy. Recent evidence indicates that in-person instruction
can occur safely without physical distancing requirements when other mitigation strategies
like masking are fully implemented. And the most important thing, of course, is that we want to
keep our children safe. Although we are making strong strides on vaccinations and we will continue
to do so, only 52 percent of Californians are fully vaccinated. And more important for schools,
only 37 percent of those aged 12 to 17 have completed their shots. And, of course, vaccines
are not even available for younger children. So what we're seeing across the country is that while
adult rates are going down of the virus cases, child rates have been going up. And we need to
be sure that we're protecting all of our children. As you know also, the highly contagious Delta
variant is taking hold in the country as more people move about with fewer precautions.
In fact, there are many variants that are going through the alphabet to name the variants. So
Delta is widely known about, Epsilon is increasing, but they're already up to Lambda in the alphabet
in naming the variants that are coming through and expect to use the whole alphabet. In the last two
weeks, daily case rates in the country have nearly doubled. So we're beginning to see that
exponential curve that we have seen before. And you know that if it doubles in those two weeks,
then it will double in the next several weeks unless there are things that change that pattern.
In Missouri, they ran out of ventilators last week. So they're back to where they were
at the start of a pandemic. We can anticipate some surge this summer. And while vaccinated
people have strong protection, there are breakthrough cases and they can be transmitters
to other non-vaccinated people, including children. So it's not surprising that many
students, parents, and teachers have concerns about returning to classrooms. We need children
back in classrooms and we need them to be safe. And that starts with masking, which is the most
surefire way to be sure that everyone is safe in schools, at least until we get to the point where
we have most people vaccinated and we have really put this pandemic to bed. We need this
sensible approach. It also removes the danger of stigmatizing some students who, depending on the
community they're in, might be stigmatized for wearing a mask or stigmatized for not wearing a
mask. It relieves teachers and staff of the burden of trying to figure out who should be masked and
who shouldn't and chase after them and enforce some differential masking rules, which would be a
logistical nightmare. So the California Department of Public Health will continue to assess conditions
on an ongoing basis. We'll determine no later than November 1st whether to update the mask
requirements or recommendations. And it may be sooner than then. Indicators, conditions,
and science review will include vaccination coverage status. And so to that point, if you
or anyone you know is eligible for the vaccine and has not been vaccinated yet, please don't wait any
longer. Do it. Encourage them to do it. Now is the time for us to make as much progress as possible
for a safe school year as well as a safe California society. With all the great progress we've made in
California, with the investments that are coming, with the vaccinations that are taking place,
I think we can look forward to a joyful and well-supported school year. And finally,
I'd like to close on another joyful note that made news last week. And I'm thrilled that the
Education Commission of the States announced its 2021 recipient of the prestigious James B. Conant
Award. And the winner is none other than our former board chair, Mike Kirst, which is why we
see him with us on the screen. We're very excited. I am privileged and honored to call Mike a friend,
a Stanford colleague, someone I've admired for years. A lot of my policy training was in
long walks with Mike all over the campus as we talked about every area of policy there is to
talk about. He has the distinction of being the state board's longest-serving president.
I've had enormous shoes to fill following Mike's tenure on the board. But fortunately,
he's been a valued advisor and counselor along the way. I know I can always turn to him. He is
a caring leader who, along with many of the board's veteran members, helped shepherd in the big
structural changes I mentioned earlier with respect to school finance, assessment, accountability,
the improvements to public education made under Mike's leadership are the foundation
from which we work to make further improvements today. Mike's work on the board, in addition to
the thousands of Stanford students who personally benefited from Mike's mentorship in the area
education policy, have really affected the state and the nation in many, many positive ways.
And I would like to give Mike a virtual round of applause and turn it over to him.
Well, thank you very much for having me and having me able to address the board. I was
sort of looking forward to standing down below and looking up at you and the dais that
will have to do it this way. I'm really enthusiastic about the progress you've made
since 2019 January when I left. Linda's announcements were just overwhelming in
terms of the scope of it. And we couldn't have done it with whatever I've done in California
without the support of many people over the years. When I was asked to make some remarks,
I thought, well, this is my 58th year in education policy. I'm just leaving my Stanford office
because we're remodeling it. I've been in their same office for 50 years. And I thought I'd make
a few observations because this award from the Education Commission of the States is really a
lifetime award in terms of what people have done. So here are my observations after 58 years. And
this is just a slice that I want to focus on of what I've learned in all these, in the evolution
of this long career. I like this award from the standpoint that it really recognizes the transfer
of education research and analysis in the public policy. And what I always wanted to do with my
career was to be in and out of government. So I was in 20 years in government, but accounting the
five years at the federal level and 16, I'm sorry, and then the other years in the state.
I began really focusing on finance and governance. And that, of course, is exemplified by the local
control funding law. I worked in Florida, and I would say that's one of the best things I've
ever done in 1973-74. We did a total overhaul of the finance education program there. It still
lasts in Florida. Oregon on finance. I worked in Texas where I was the chief finance consultant
at Ross Perot and his overhaul. I have a lot of Ross Perot stories. And then worked in other
states as well. I also did a lot of work on the politics of education, who controls our schools,
building political coalitions. And at the end of that, and it was continued, of course, through
to California and LCFF. And towards the middle of it, though, I began to realize the limits of
finance and governance to include and to improve schools and to really improve the outcomes for
children. So what I really learned is the importance, of course, of what we all know,
of improving classroom instruction. A lot of what we do, including finance and governance,
is a way to improve classroom instruction. But if nothing new is happening and better in classrooms,
we're really not getting that far in terms of what we hope to do.
A paper that was put out by the former head of the Garden Grove School District, Laura Schwamm,
has the right title. We are never better than our teachers. So I began to focus in the beginning in
my first years on the state board on curriculum and instruction. And all the important work you do
and the curriculum frameworks, of course, the standards, the assessments, that has a powerful
impact. Our accountability system, like the dashboard, has a powerful impact. But all of
this may not change much when that classroom door closes. What's happening behind those classroom
doors? How do you connect the capital in Sacramento to the classroom? And you can do that in your
doing that in many ways now. For example, community schools is an excellent example.
But that still will have to get at some point down to improving our math instruction.
We're not going to see much progress in the way we are in math. So LCFF brought a number of
things together in a coordinated and aligned and coherent way that began to change the
classroom. But when you look at the studies, it's still, and you look, say, at mathematics,
it still isn't profoundly changed. Most of what I'm seeing and reading about, Rand has done these
studies as well, is that teachers add a few things, like me adding a few things to my syllabus
from, and now I'm speaking about the Common Core and the implementation of Common Core math,
for example. They add a few things to that. They think, well, I'm already teaching most of this.
They do some changes in how they're delivering their teaching. But I think it's very hard to
make a transformation of teaching. We have 350 to 375,000 teachers. How do you affect what they're
doing without command and control? We can't do that. So I really think that one of the areas I
want to salute that Linda mentioned in this list is the big money we're putting into teacher
preparation, teacher professional development, recognizing outstanding teachers through the
National Board, and generally supporting deeper work on our frameworks. I think those are really
vital, and I continue to puzzle on how to do this in a massive way. I'm currently studying
the details of how Ontario Canada did so much in terms of improving teaching through Ontario
provincial activities. The state there, called the province, was just vital. And so I encourage you
to continue what you're doing, think about the progress you're making, and that it's the last
mile of implementation often. That's key. The very last mile, of course, that's teachers, classroom,
instruction, the interaction with instructional materials, and how you can see whether you're
making a difference there and how you're improving. So that's my brief history of 58 years, and I'll
stop there and let you get on with your important meeting, and I'll go back to my pondering these
problems I've been discussing.
I was muted. Thank you so much. We are so pleased and proud that you're being recognized in this
way, and you talked about the last mile. It's that foundation that was laid in this last
administration that you led during Governor Brown's term of the funding system, the governance,
the accountability system on which you can then build the teaching and learning that is needed.
So I think we're tackling these things in the right order, as you know. One of the reasons I was
pleased to accept this job was because it was building on such a wonderful legacy that the
board had already created. I think we have a few people who may want to say things, and I'm going
to call on member Strauss.
Mike, it's so great to see you here with us at the board meeting. I agree, I think all of us would
much rather have been in person to meet with you and to meet as a team, but I have to say and reflect
on the wonderful eight years we shared together and how lucky I feel as a leader that we were able to
be guided by your ponderings and your experiences and help to implement significant changes
that are going to impact going forward for our kids, for our grandkids. And I just have to tell
you how much I personally appreciated getting the opportunity to work with you, the friendship that
we developed, and your thoughts. And I would say as I teach graduate classes, your writings and
theories have continued to influence how I guide that work. So I hope that we will continue to stay
in touch, and I'm so glad that you're here with us, and I can't think of anyone more deserving of
the honor than this award by the Education Commission of the States. So thanks for being
with us, and I just have to tell you again what an honor and a pleasure it's been to work with you.
Thanks. Member Rodriguez, do you want to say a word?
Yes. Good morning, everyone. Congratulations, Dr. Kurtz. It made me really happy. My heart
skipped a beat when I saw your name pop up in the Zoom, and this is a very well-deserved honor.
And I want to thank you as well for all of your support and the influence you've had on me through
your work. Congratulations again. Terrific. All right. Well, thank you so much. This is a
wonderful way to start our meeting today, and I'm going to move along now to announcements.
You know, we are sad, too. I see Ting leaning forward. Did you have a hand up or anything that
I missed? No. Okay. No, that's my hand up. You did. Okay. All right. Member Rucker,
it's not showing up on my thing. I think I need to move my medallion to the other side as
Dr. Strauss had done. Dr. Kurtz, I wanted to also chime in and give my congratulations to you.
I have known you for a long time, but I've gotten to know you personally in the work that we did
and have done together on the state board under your leadership. I recall when I was first appointed
that you had called me and talked to me personally about the work that I was hoping to accomplish
and what my goals were. You have been a great but also humble leader, and your humility continues
to show here. I cannot tell you how much the teachers and other people that I work with in
the stakeholder community not only admire and respect your work, but also admire the way that
you change the culture and climate for engagement for the state board with the education stakeholder
community. And that work and that modeling for engagement continues. There's a messiness about
education policy and the development of education policy and implementation that takes time, that
takes patience, and that takes humility. And so I appreciate that not only have we done a lot of
things, but it's been anchored in this ideal that you've come to define as the California way. If
we don't do anything else, if we don't leave anything else behind in our mark on the world,
I think probably the most important thing we've done as a state board under your leadership and
continuing with Dr. Darling-Hammond's leadership is we have defined a policy, a practice,
and a mode for engagement called the California way that everyone across the country looks at,
wanders at, and tries to understand how to do it as well as you've been able to help us do it.
So thank you so much not only for your leadership and humility, but thank you for the things that
you have mentored me with and have taught me how to do and have helped me to understand and
participate in. And congratulations on this very important award. And thank you. And Superintendent
Thurmond would like to say a word. And we're glad you're still with us.
They're going to call my name any moment in the Senate, but I'm grateful that I had a chance to
hear those remarks. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. You know, to see the convergence
of really we have two great minds who have led and are leading our state board and our educational
work in the state, and Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond and Dr. Kirst. And to have the convergence of both
of your styles, your messages, has been a special treat. It struck me that if you want to become
State Board of Education president, be a Stanford professor and researcher. And I imagined what
those conversations and those long walks must have been like and what they must have entailed.
And so it's just a treat to hear really from our two great state board education leaders
and to hear about your ponderings that you shared. Thank you for the highlight and the snapshot
of your ponderings over 58 years. And we appreciate that you're still pondering
and that you're willing to share. And so again, glad to just see the convergence
of two incredible leaders at the same time. It was a treat. And I think it's just really a helpful
way to frame the work that you started and that Dr. Darling-Hammond and many of us are continuing
to lead. So thank you. Thank you so much. And you know, one of the things we find in the policy
world is that continuity really matters. And so I think it's a benefit to the state that we are
able to get on a path the California way, as Patricia said, and follow that path.
So it's a wonderful, wonderful way to start our deliberations today. Mike, thank you so much for
being with us. We know you're with us, even when you're not on the screen. And I will just tell
you, if you ever want to take a really fast walk and have about a million ideas a minute,
that's the walk you take. So we'll see you soon, I hope. I'll see you on the campus.
And I'll move on now to announcements. We're now going to both be happy and sad about the departure
of board member Navo from the stick board because he is going to become the executive director of
CCE. And so that's a wonderful asset for us and as a partner and for the state.
His contributions while on the state board included serving as the liaison to the CCE.
So he just decided he'd slide on in when Tom announced his
retirement. And he will be a wonderful leader in that context. He's been developing the state
system of support, as well as facilities and territory transfer related board items.
Matt has joined us in this morning to allow us the opportunity to wish him well,
to share our excitement. And I want to open the floor to board members who would like to say
their farewells and their welcomes to his new role, Member Strauss.
So, Matt, I have to say it has been such an honor and a privilege to serve with you on the board.
I always so appreciate your thoughtful considerations of the challenging situations
we've had to address as a board and your experience as a practitioner and a leader
really show and how you carry yourself. And I think CCE is so lucky that you wanted to help
lead in this important work going forward. Because you have experience firsthand
as a teacher, as a leader, as a superintendent, and as a support at West Ed. I just think they
couldn't have gotten anyone stronger to help follow the work that's been laid. And I look
forward to continuing to see you. I'll miss having our dinners and our chance to just talk about life
beyond the board. And I just wish you only the best. And I still appreciate you taking time from
your family vacation to join us this morning. Matt is three hours earlier in Hawaii right now,
beaming in. So we appreciate that commitment and willingness to be with us. Member Rucker.
Let me begin by saying you're in Hawaii. I have no sympathy for you on being three hours early
enough on this call at 630 in the morning your time. Matt, I so appreciate the time that we had
the opportunity to work together on the board. I really respect and admire not only the credentials
and expertise and background that you brought to the board, but also I'm very excited about
what your leadership with the collaborative will mean. And I'm going to be very careful saying that
because often when we take time to praise the new guy coming in, you know, you're throwing shade at
the guy going out. I also want to take time to thank Tom Anelino for his service because
he started this. This is not that he picked a fight, but that he took up the fight to take a
look at not only what the state's role can be in leading change and leading school improvement,
but he also set the table for what the work of engagement with districts from the state level
can look like. So I truly appreciate the work that he did to set up this model and to create
the types of engagements and projects that have been started by the collaborative. You come at a
time when we are transitioning from that from a phase of getting a ramping up and rolling out
to a phase of really evaluating where we are and what the logical next steps and priorities need
to be. And as Dr. Darling-Hammond has already talked about, we've looked at school leadership,
we've looked at the work of reporting and making transparent to the public what's going on with
schools, and now comes the hard work and those very hard conversations about not only just what
does accountability look like, but what it means to actually hold ourselves accountable for the
types of decisions that are being made. So you're stepping into a conversation that the collaborative
is beginning to turn to and that the board is beginning to ask those very hard questions about,
and I'm very excited to see you there. I've already asked to be on your to-do list to make
an appointment with, so I'm looking forward to those conversations and the work you'll be doing.
Terrific. Members Patat and then member Glover Woods.
Matt, thank you so much first of all for your service on the board,
but also thank you so much for always being willing and open to take a meeting with me
and some other student leaders this past year, whether it be Casque or Jenup or Zach from San
Diego. You're always so willing to lend an ear and so willing to give just such valuable and good
advice when it came to a proposal that, you know, whether it be the proposals that we presented back
in November or something that we were going to go present to a legislator or literally just anything,
you were always just so willing to lend a hand, give an ear, and I'll always appreciate that. So
we're going to miss you. I know that I'll miss you, but I'll definitely always keep your email
and my contact and message you if I have anything. So thank you so much. Great. Member Glover Woods
and then member Patio Brownson. Thank you, Matt. I just wanted to say again to you congratulations.
It has been my honor to serve with you on the board over this past year. I will miss your very
important and very pointful questions that you always ask and just really I'm excited for you
in your new role. I'm extremely excited for the CCEE that will be working under your leadership.
Great things to come and as member Strahl said, they couldn't have gotten a better person for
the job. So congratulations to you. Terrific. Member Patio Brownson.
I just want to say congratulations on your new role. We were sworn in together back when and I
I will miss our conversations and also just the incredible perspective that you've always
brought to the board of both always having a focus on how to constructively resolve
the challenges that we're faced with, how to engage with the folks who come before the board
with respect, with grades, and with the desire to figure out a way to help kids and the adults who
actually are all in the ecosystem working together. So I'm delighted that you will be
a partner in an agency not far off and hope that we'll still have occasion to see you here.
That's great and I'll just say as I turn the mic over to Matt to make his comments that I first
encountered Matt when I was doing some research on Sanger Unified School District where they had
undertaken extraordinary over a series of superintendents, extraordinary improvements
and gains, really reaching out to kids, putting in place literacy programs, terrific training for
teachers around the needs of students with disabilities but also the needs of every student.
So it became very much a sort of child-centered, teacher-supported and supporting strategy and so
Matt has lived through the kind of system of support construction that CCEE is all about
and so it's going to be terrific to have you there. I also just want to note as Member Rucker did that
this is also part of a legacy beginning with Carl Combs tenure which really began the process
Tom Romulino has done a wonderful job of expanding the system of support and really helping us
conceptualize it. Matt I'm sure you will take it that next level in the way that Mike first talked
about to really focus in on what do we need to do to support the kind of teaching and learning
that is needed for every child in every district. So we're thrilled that you're going to be there
and if you'd like to say a few words this is your time. Oh thank you so much and yes I am in Hawaii
and internet is spotty and if I lose you I've let Brooks know to speak for me in terms of
thanking everyone so much and Board Member Rucker you have such a way of
capsulating what is ahead of us. I just appreciate so much your perspective and
simply want to thank the Governor for the opportunity and all the Board Members and
Board Chair, President Linda Darlingham for giving me the opportunity to serve. It's been an absolute
joy and it seems like just yesterday Kim we were going through confirmation with it so it just seems
so quick but I've learned an incredible amount of being here and understanding the perspective,
the large perspective of such a complex system in California having been looking up at the
system for quite some time and having an opportunity to serve at a place where I can see from the much
larger view. It's such a complex but one of the most innovative educational systems in the country
and it's just a joy to be not only a student of California educated by great educators in the state
but also have the opportunity to serve. So I greatly appreciate it. I will miss
being a part of this amazing group and I just want to thank the State Board staff and
Karen staff, Walters and Brooks and the CDE and their staff and again the Governor
giving me the opportunity. It was Governor Brown who had given me the opportunity to serve
as a Governor appointee to ACSI back in 2013. That was my first opportunity to serve
the Advisory Commission for Special Education and started to learn about the system
statewide system of support and how it was designed and I hope to bring to CCE
a perspective. I certainly will have no aspirations of being able to fill
Carl or Tom's shoes in any way but hope to bring just a new perspective of ways to think about
how to do this very complex work. So appreciate it very much. I know you have a very long day ahead
of you but again thank you so much and I'm going to miss this group and thank you Board President
Darlin Hammond for giving me the opportunity to say a few words. I appreciate it very much.
It's wonderful to hear from you. You're now free to go to the beach
and enjoy your time in Hawaii. We are so proud and so pleased that we'll have the opportunity
to continue to work with you in this new role. Thank you. And now I'm going to announce that
this is our last meeting with student board members, Dave Patah. He is the only student
board member whose term endured through the COVID pandemic and participated through the remote state
board meetings. So that was one more on the many challenges that you faced. You educated us in some
very important ways about what student life during the pandemic was like. I can call to mind several
very important conversations that informed us in ways that were very important in our decision
making. He served as liaison to the annual SABE conference and all of his insights and commitments
to the board's work have been deeply appreciated. Yale is lucky to have you. I will say that is both
my alma mater and Brooks Allen who is our executive director. So we'll be glad to share
insights from many years ago. And board members, please join me in saying a few words to Zade and
then we'll ask Zade if he wants to respond. So board member Strauss, I saw your hand go up.
So Zade, I have to say you've been an amazing board member for so many reasons. Really articulate
about student perspectives. Very engaged in all of our issues that we work with at the board.
But you've also done such an amazing job to increase student engagement at our state level.
And I think that's resulted in instead of having 30 or 40 applications for a student board member,
we get 75. And I think you've really helped students around the state see how important it
is to have a voice. So your statewide activism has been so helpful. And I just would say it was
a pleasure. Zade and I got to serve on a student panel for youth and government. And I got to see
Zade engage beyond our board work with students and talk about our issues. I can't think of a better
exemplary student representative of the voice of educational policy at the state. And I'm excited
to follow your pathway. We know you have a great road ahead. You will come back to make amazing
impact in the work you do. And it's been my honor to serve. I'm just sorry it's only been remote.
But I feel like we all got to know you in this model as well. And I'm really excited about you.
Thank you so much for your commitment to the students of California and the work we do.
Thank you. Thank you, Member Strauss. Member Patil-Bronson and then Member Rucker.
I just wanted to congratulate you as well and wish you well as you head off to a land of
incredible cold and excitement that will expand your horizons in all sorts of ways. And thank you
for your service. I also just want to echo Eileen's comments that the level of both
increased welcome to students to come to actually raise the issues that are relevant and
top of mind for students across the state I think has absolutely increased as a result of your
outreach and work. And you've also just I think even in this all virtual format been able to
actually lift up the student perspective in ways that have enriched our conversations time and
time again. I also just have a memory of you very eloquently but very pointedly raising up some of
the mental health concerns that students are experiencing through the COVID year and making
sure that we were all attuned to what it's need in terms of all the full child wraparound services
that our board chair was describing earlier in the budget as part of the preconditions for learning
and for children and young adults to feel welcomed accepted and challenged in all the ways that
school system should. So thank you so much and all the best of luck.
Thank you. Member Rodriguez. Oh I'm sorry member Rucker and then member Rodriguez.
Well Zade of course congratulations and all of the other compliments that have been heaped on
your shoulders already by my colleagues on the board. I feel I have a different and unique
relationship with you mostly because several of your teachers at your school are some of my
closest friends and they talk about you not with just great pride but also with great respect
because of the student that you are at your school. People in the public see you here at the board
meeting and it's easy to forget with the level of sophistication and engagement that you have been
as a leader on this board. It's easy to forget sometimes that you are a young man
heading off to college in the fall and so at your school and around with your peers
when you return from the board meetings and you go back to school you're just Zade and you are
this young man and this good friend and this good colleague and mentor and peer with your friends
that's not only exemplary as a student leader that we see here on the board but also in your
school community you have been a very vital and important part. So I want to say thank you and
congratulations and you will be missed by your board colleagues but you're also leaving a void
and a vacuum in your high school and in your high school community for the friends and the peers and
the support that you have offered and given at your school as well. So I'm very proud of you. I'm
glad I get to know you and as you continue with your work you know don't lose that very special
touch and that very special part of who you are that makes people very glad not only to be your
friend but be in your circle and be able to rely on you for the advice and the leadership you have
offered. Thank you and member Rodriguez. Thank you President Darlene Hammond. Zade both you and I have
been through zoom meeting we started in zoom and it's you know I really wish that I could have had
the opportunity to chat with you face to face. I have tremendous admiration for you and you've been
an inspiration to my students even though they don't know you because you know like I have the
the Zade chart and I tell them I inspire them to set the goals that that you communicated with us
at your first meeting about you know how you wanted to serve on the state board and to engage
you know to be civic minded and so I really want I'm grateful for this time that we spent together
because I've learned a lot from you and you know I wish I would have had you as a student but
when I'm looking at my students I'm thinking you know I'm preparing the next Zade hopefully
so thank you. Awesome Zade do you want to say a few words? Yeah definitely I have so many thank
yous to to give out firstly to all the board members but I've just had the opportunity to
sit alongside three things specifically. First thank you for always setting a good example of
what it means to be kind and cordial even when disagreeing with someone and working to fiercely
articulate kind of an opposing point. I think that's something that's so important in this day
and age and it was you guys just set such a perfect example of that when speaking. Second
thank you for always kind of valuing diversity of thought and opinions and for always kind of
throwing down the brakes whenever you heard a thoughtful comment that you hadn't considered
by a caller during public comment. That was also something that I really picked up on and really
grew to value as well. And third and finally thank you for always being so kind friendly
and inclusive to me be it at board meetings or when we found ourselves together on a panel
outside of the board meetings. And also just a quick thank you to all the state board CDE staff
and Brooks for always being there to lend a hand or open ear to me or to listen to an idea and
for agreeing to speak at events that I kind of come to you with haphazardly.
And thank you to all the student organizations that I've just had the opportunity to work with
this year for being so hardworking, so relentless and so thoughtful when it came to changemaking
and for welcoming me into your inner circles. I've learned so much about myself and about
California education policy and about just other people just from being amongst you guys and so
that's something that'll definitely be taken with me to college all the things that I've learned.
I'm definitely looking forward to training my successor Rana. You guys will love her,
she's awesome just from the conversations that we've had so far and I know that she'll definitely
be filling in my spot and be doing a great job next year. I joined this position kind of a little
bit more quieter and I feel like I've kind of come into my own. Tomorrow I turn 18 so I came in as
a young man and I'll leave as a legal man I guess tomorrow so that's super nice.
And overall I'm just going to miss everything about this position, everything about the people
that I've met, but I know that you'll always be there waiting for me and I'm excited for what's
in store in New Haven so I'll definitely keep in touch. Take your boots. Definitely.
We're delighted that you're going to have such a wonderful opportunity and we will be ready to
welcome Rana. I'm glad you're already in touch with her. The new board member, student board
member who will be replacing Zade is Rana Bananka who is starting, she was appointed on May 28th,
she'll start on August 1st, her new term and I know we'll all look forward to welcoming her
at our September board meeting and Zade we hope you'll send us news of your first weeks at Yale
when you get there. And so I'm going to queue us up for our next agenda item but given that
we got an early start after I do that I'm going to give us a little 10-minute break to get a cup of
coffee before the next board item because it's a very long one. So but I'm going to sort of give
us a framework for the rest of the day. The following item has an addendum, item two,
California's draft state plan for the American Rescue Plan Elementary and Secondary Emergency
Relief Fund has an addendum. In terms of changes in the agenda we're going to reopen item one later
this afternoon before item 11 to reapprove the revised March 2020 minutes, take action on the
May 2021 minutes and receive liaison reports. The proposed waiver consent items are W1 through 12,
the proposed regular consent items are items 7 through 10. In terms of public input members
with public wishing to call in for public comment should view the live stream of the meeting to know
at what time public comment will occur for each item. Public comment may be provided by dialing
the phone number, entering a participant access code, and then following the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in callers will be added to a caller queue. The operator will notify callers when it is
their turn to provide public comment. We'll also ask callers to please turn down the volume
of their computers, the speaker volume, if they're following the live webcast to avoid an echoing
effect. Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker per item. Item 11 is the
general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on matters that
are not specifically listed on the board's agenda. Board members please mute your microphones when
not speaking and keep your cameras on as much as possible to ensure that we maintain a forum
throughout today's virtual meeting. For each item on the agenda there will be an opportunity for you
to raise your hand using the zoom participant window if you'd like to ask the question or make
a comment. Then you've been doing a great job at that already. With that it is now 9 54. We have a
long item coming up. I'm going to suggest that we take a break until 10 0 5, a cup of coffee so you
can be ready to dive in and then we'll carry that item through with us until lunch. Even 10 minutes
10 0 5 actually 11 minutes you get. So keep your
stay on. Don't leave the meeting but you can stop your video and mute yourself.
Do we need to call the roll again? I believe we do.
Seeing all board members present, Brooks can you call the roll?
Call the roll.
Member Sun. Present. Vice President Strauss.
Present. Member Rucker. Present. Member Rodriguez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Present. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Glover-Woods.
Here. Member Fatah.
Here. President Darling-Hammond.
Here. We have a quorum.
Thank you very much. We're going to dive into item two which is California's state
draft state plan for the American Rescue Plan Elementary and Secondary School Emergency Relief Fund.
This plan requires states to provide more detailed information than previous applications
and under very tight timelines. CDE and state board staff have worked diligently
plan that looks both at what the state and schools did to address COVID-19 during the
past 16 months as well as how the state will support LEAs in the coming school year
as we move to safely opening schools and addressing student needs exacerbated by the pandemic.
This includes two plans that LEAs must adopt related to the safe return to in-person instruction
and how they intend to spend their ESSER funds. The draft plan relies heavily on actions from
the governor and legislature related to the 2020 and 21 and 2021-22 state budgets.
Stakeholder engagement is a critical element for the state and local plans.
Following six months of negotiations, multiple budget hearings with testimony and public comment
as well as additional stakeholder engagement, the 2021-22 state budget was recently approved
and the draft APR ESSER state plan reflects the final state budget allocations and the
state's educational properties. In order for California to access the remaining 30 plus percent
of ESSER III funds, which is approximately five billion dollars, we must submit an approved plan
to the U.S. Department of Education. The CDE and state board staff recommend that we approve the
draft California state plan pending the state board executive director approval of final revisions
requested by the state board and correction of any type of graphical errors. This item does have
an addendum and it will be presented by Rachel Maves and Stephanie Pappas of the CDE. Rachel,
please begin. Thank you President Darlene Hammond. Good morning Vice President Strauss,
Superintendent Thurmond and members of the state board. I am Rachel Maves, deputy superintendent
of the instruction and measurement branch at CDE and today I have the pleasure of presenting
California state plan for elementary and secondary school emergency relief funds
as required under the American Rescue Plan Act. The effort was led by deputy superintendent Lisa
Constancio and her fierce team Stephanie Pappas and Ellie Gardner, Amy Tang Paterno and Dan Merwin.
Deputy Superintendent Constancio was called to support the superintendent on another matter,
so you're left with me today. Thankfully her team as well as many other program staff are here and
available to support any questions you might have after the presentation. I would like to
offer a special thanks to education administrator Stephanie Pappas as you have truly led this charge
pushing this plan forward and have been key in its development as well as our state board staff
colleagues Deb Brown and Sarah Petrowski for your collaboration and support into the evenings
and over the weekends. I know we have a lot to discuss today but as we delve into our state's
plan I would be remiss not to spend a couple of minutes to also acknowledge and thank the
greater CDE team for their tremendous amount of work they have done over the course of this year
in addition to their regular duties their regular day-to-day duties under the leadership and vision
of state superintendent Thurman. When I started at CDE I had a tremendous amount of respect for
our organization and the past year has only served to deepen that feeling. Team over the
course of the last year and a half you have not only continued to do the overwhelming amount of
daily work but you have layered on additional and often new initiatives to ensure the field
receive timely information and in the midst you produce some groundbreaking work that serves as a
bright beacon during an unbelievably complex time in education which is perhaps the cause of what
my teenager pointed out at the other day as the further grain of my eyebrows my hair now being
beyond repute. Team you have pushed out over 19 billion dollars of additional funds in the
course of a year. You have helped support groundbreaking initiatives including the
transformative social emotional learning competencies through the mental health 2.0 group
and the digital learning integration and standards guidance led by SCOE. You shifted our entire
assessment system to offer flexibilities that required innovative ways to ensure access for
students and families. You have provided over 40 webinars specific to meeting the needs of our
current context in addition to the multiple webinars delivered for the everyday requirements.
You develop multiple guidance documents and resources in over 20 different areas including
CDE stronger together a guidebook for the safe reopening of California's public schools,
grading guidance for progress and distance learning, guidance on diagnostic informative
assessments, teaching multilingual learners online in the California context, guidance on
embracing and supporting multilingual learners during distance learning and so much more.
Many of you have consistently worked extraordinarily long days jumped on zoom calls or responded to
email during your vacations and tackled one task after another with impossible deadlines. This
plan included. Thank you. Thank you for your perseverance, for your grace and for your
commitment to our students in California. In order for California to access the remaining 30 plus
percent of ESSER III funds approximately five billion dollars we must submit an approved
plan to the U.S. Department of Education. The state plan before you today briefly describes
not only what we have done to address COVID-19 during the past 16 months but also address how
we will support LEAs in the upcoming school years as we move to safely reopen all schools
and addressing student needs exacerbated by the pandemic. To begin with I think it is important
to quickly review our background and context. As I mentioned above this year there was an influx of
an unprecedented amount of state and federal funding. The coronavirus aid relief and economic
security act allocated almost six billion dollars. The learning loss mitigation funds allocated almost
5.3 billion dollars and also required LEAs to develop a plan in coordination with stakeholder
feedback for the allocation of those funds. The coronavirus response and relief supplemental
appropriations act allocated over six billion dollars. AB 86 allocated 4.6 billion dollars for
in-person learning and expanded learning opportunities. The IPI allowed LEAs to either utilize an existing
plan or develop a new plan with union support and the expanded learning grant required a separate
plan that also included stakeholder feedback. And finally the elementary and secondary school relief
S or 3 funds allocates over 13 billion dollars and requires again another plan for that includes
stakeholder feedback. Finally the increased concentration grant funding that we see in this
new bill allocates 1.1 billion dollars that will be included in a mid-year update in the 21-22 LCAP.
The ARP act is the third federal relief package that contains significant funding for education.
As I mentioned the previous two federal relief packages were the CARES act and CRRSA act and
combined they provide approximately 8.3 billion in relief funding specifically for K-12 schools.
However the ARP act is the first to require a state plan for these relief funds and really is
the focus for our discussion today. As we delve deeper into the content of the plan it is important
to note that this was developed on a very tight timeline. On March 11th 2021 the American Rescue
Plan was signed into law. On April 21st the U.S. Department of Education released the ARP Esser
State Plan with the expectations that SEA submitted a plan approved by June 7th. On May 14th
Board President Darlene Hammond and State Superintendent Thurnman sent a letter to ED in
order to request an extension to the ARP Esser State Plan to August 2nd due to the California
State Board of Education approval requirements and the California budget process.
The way in which California receives funds and then distributes federal funds is unique compared
to other states. In other states funds go directly to the SEA to then prioritize and redistribute to
LEAs. In California the funds go to the Department of Finance and are included in the overall budget
planning process to ensure alignment with state priorities. Because the ARP funds are incorporated
into the budget process the timeline for developing and presenting a plan to the State Board of
Education had to also follow the budget timeline. Following six months of negotiations, multiple
budget hearings with testimony and public comment, as well as additional stakeholder engagement,
the 21-22 state budget was enacted on Monday, July 12th, 2021. The posted ARP Esser State Plan
reflects the final state budget allocations and the subsequent state educational priorities.
California was allocated over 15 billion dollars in a third round of elementary and secondary school
emergency relief funding or ESSER III for short. Pursuant to the provisions of the ARP over 13.5
billion dollars of this allocation is sub-granted to LEAs based on each LEA share of funds received
under Title I, Part A. A new requirement of the ARP Act and subsequent U.S. Department of Education
guidance is a requirement for both LEAs and states to complete plans for ESSER III funding.
LEAs must complete a safe return to in-person instruction and continuity of services plan
as well as an expenditure plan for their use of ESSER III funding.
The focus of today's presentation is the ARP Esser State Plan which included
includes an overview of the two LEA plans. Over the course of the last seven years
California has embarked on a process of intentionally integrating and streamlining
state and federal requirements where possible our California way. This includes identifying
overlaps between the LCAP and LCAP federal addendum and incorporating CSI requirements
into the LCAP. As we begin to review the plan requirements for ESSER III funds the same
intentionality was used to reduce redundancy. You will notice that where applicable we work
to integrate state and federal processes. In this next section we will quickly review the ARP
ESSER III State Plan template. The template includes prompts that highlight comprehensive
planning by SEAs and LEAs for the effective use of ARP ESSER funds to reopen schools safely this
fall, support for sustained access to in-person instruction throughout the school year, and
addressing the academic social and emotional mental health needs of students. The plan includes
information gathered across multiple divisions throughout CDE and the California Department of
Health all in collaboration with SBE staff. It is representative of the priorities outlined in the
budget. The template requires an SEA to review the past year to describe actions and events that have
already taken place and reflect on what was learned. It also requires an SEA reflect on what
was learned and describe how the SEA will support LEAs and utilize federal and state funds to improve
services and supports for students in the upcoming year. Very similar to the process California
developed with its LCAP. The development of this plan has been quite a task. The Department of
Finance and Legislature have contributed through the development of the budget. Multiple branches
and divisions across CDE have been involved in this process. The California Department of Health
has helped inform this plan. State Board of Education staff as well as LEAs, member organizations,
advocates, families, and other partners. Because the plan reflects the priorities of the state
budget, it required CDE to review the stakeholder engagement that informed the budget process,
which is the foundation for the state plan. The Region 15 Comprehensive Center reviewed hundreds
of letters sent to the governor's office, state assembly, and state senate that identified the
budget priorities and policy positions of approximately a thousand organizations that work
with students and schools in California. This input and the letters received through various
means were both timely and relevant as they provided insight into local priorities and
recommendations on how the state should allocate resources available for schools. In addition to
the feedback provided through the budget process, CDE also hosted a Tuesdays at Two webinar to gather
input on the LEA expenditure plan template and a draft was additionally reviewed by the California
Practitioners Advisory Group. Over 200 letters were submitted from stakeholders regarding
California's 2021 budget were analyzed. These letters were submitted between January 2021
through June 2021 either by individual organizations or groups of organizations
collectively ranging from just a few to nearly over 200 per letter. Although these letters
represent all together these letters represented the voices of over a thousand organizations.
From this analysis over 100 stakeholders including 20 school districts and other LEAs,
over 75 nonprofits and others, and nearly 15 unions in 40 letters expressed support for
addressing mental health, trauma of students, families, and staff. Over 250 stakeholders
including 125 school districts and other LEAs, over 100 nonprofits and others, and over 10 unions
in more than 25 letters expressed support addressing the accelerated learning of students.
Nearly 90 stakeholders including over 10 school districts and other LEAs, nearly 70 nonprofits
and others, and nearly 10 unions in 15 letters supported the safe return of all students for
the 21-22 school year. CPAC also provided very helpful feedback during our meeting.
They recommended adding clarifying language to the plan that stakeholder engagement is not a one-time
event. We tried to work diligently to call this out in the plan that as funding and context changes
California leaders will continue to engage with stakeholders on an ongoing basis. They requested
that we consider allowing LEAs to use existing plans for the safe return plan which is also a
flexibility that was included in the SAA plan as you will see later in this presentation.
They also recommended providing more clarity around how the state budget process influences
the state plan to spend federal dollars. This is something that we've incorporated into the plan as
well as the presentation. Collaboration with COEs was also noted as a strength throughout the
pandemic. I cannot say enough how much we have appreciated and strongly value the support of
our county office of education partners and work to incorporate those successes into the plan as
well. They also with a very keen eye noted the places we use language like learning loss
and remediation and requested we change that language to reflect more strengths-based assets.
Regarding the expenditure plan our Tuesdays at 2 which included specific feedback as well from the
equity coalition helped us to inform some changes to the plan. These include a revised revision of
the title template, the request to provide flexibility for LEAs to reference or include
input provided by community members during the development of existing plans to the extent that
the input is applicable to the requirements of the SR3 expenditure plan. They asked that we provide
flexibility for LEAs to include actions described in existing plans including the LCAP or the ELO
grant plan to the extent again that those actions address the requirements of SR3.
They clarified within the template and instructions that the plan only addresses SR3 funds. They
requested a list of community members be included with whom LEAs were required to consult.
They requested a summary of expenditure tables be removed to the beginning of the plan.
We also included a requirement in fields in the template for LEAs to choose to utilize community
input and or action from other planning documents to provide the name of the plan referenced in the
LEA and a description of where that plan may be accessed by the public. We also clarified the
instructions that an LEA may reference or include input provided by community members during the
development of the existing plans including the LCAP or the ELO grant plan to the extent that the
input is applicable to the requirements of the SR3 expenditure plan. We clarified within the
instructions that when including actions from other places the LEA must describe how the actions
included in the SR3 expenditure plan supplement the work described in the plan being referenced
and the SR3 funds included in the SR3 expenditure plan must be in addition to any funding for those
actions already included in the plan's reference by the LEA. Finally, we clarified within the
instructions that an LEA must include all of the LEA's apportionment of SR3 funds. This feedback
has been extraordinarily valuable and has served to make necessary changes to what we're bringing
before you today. The rest of the presentation includes an overview of the revised plan as
informed by stakeholder engagement to then gather your feedback. The ED provided state template
contains seven sections referred to as critical areas that must be addressed. These sections
include describing the state's current status and needs, safely reopening schools and sustaining
their safe operations, planning for the use and coordination of ARPS or funds, maximizing state
level funds to support students, supporting LEAs and planning for meeting students needs,
supporting the educator workforce, and monitoring and measuring progress.
Each section of the template begins with framing from ED followed by an overview of the purpose
and focus. In section A, ED recognizes the extraordinary efforts made by states, LEAs,
and educators to support students during the COVID-19 pandemic. In this section, SEAs will
describe the progress they have made, the priorities and student needs guiding their ARPS or funding
decisions, and their current and projected operating status. Each section also includes
areas of focus. There are five areas of focus as specified within the section A plan.
First, the state must include the top two or three strategies that have been most effective
in supporting the needs of students. The CDE and the SBE work closely with the governor's office
and the California Department of Health, CDPH, through the state schools for all team, along
with input from stakeholders to identify the most impactful practices from this year.
Those practices include guidance, resources, and flexibility to support effective distance learning.
A few highlights include significant funding to LEAs from the governor's office and legislature
to develop and implement initiatives that directly support academic achievement and mitigate learning
gaps. Investments and guidance including digital learning integration and standards guidance,
as well as flexibilities in the administration of assessments. Two, expanded access to devices,
broadband, and connectivity. An example of this includes California's efforts to address the
digital divide through the bridging the digital divide fund created by Governor Gavin Newsom,
first partner Jennifer Sibyl Newsom, and SBE president and the state superintendent of public
instruction, Tony Thurman, that raised tens of millions of dollars in direct aid to communities
and school districts to address this issue. Three, support for the safe return to in-person
instruction. This was accomplished through various efforts including the state superintendent and CDE
in partnership with the SBE, CDPH, and others to put out guidance and develop resources for LEAs
on how to safely return to in-person instruction. The governor's office supported school staff by
giving them first access to personal protective equipment, COVID-19 testing, and COVID-19 vaccines.
For section A2, the state plan requires SEAs identify the overall priorities for the state.
These are the top three issues currently facing students and schools across California as a result
of COVID-19. Mental health trauma needs of students, families, and staff. Over 100
stakeholders expressed support for budget priorities focused on the mental health and
trauma needs of students, families, and staff. This priority was broadly supported by school
districts and LEAs, non-profits, community groups, and labor partners. Over 250 stakeholders
expressed support for accelerated learning priorities such as expanded learning time,
high-dose tutoring, and summer enrichment. This priority had widespread support from LEAs,
non-profits, community groups, and labor partners. And finally, over 90 stakeholders from a variety
of groups representing school districts, LEAs, non-profits, and community members and labor
partners expressed support for the safe return to full-time in-person instruction.
Underserved students are identified in the plan as students from low-income families,
students of color, English learners, children with disabilities, students experiencing homelessness,
children and youth in foster care, migratory students, youth involved in the criminal justice
system, LGBTQIA students, and another group disproportionately impacted by the pandemic.
As the state reviewed needs for each student group based on stakeholder feedback, there are a number
of areas that overlapped across student groups including mental health supports, social emotional
supports and programs, targeted interventions to support accelerated learning, and access to
reliable technology including devices and broadband. Another prompt asked the state to describe how it
will support LEAs in identifying the extent of the impact of the COVID-19 pandemic on student
learning and student well-being. The draft describes how stakeholder engagement is foundational to
how the state understands the impact of changes such as the pandemic. It then covers the local
control and accountability plan as a critical data collection tool as school districts engage their
communities to assess student needs, opportunity gaps, and areas for improvement. The plan also
notes that the CDE has continued to use the California school dashboard to understand the
needs of schools, of districts, schools, and student groups. Additionally, CDE produced resources
such as guidance on diagnostic informative assessments in August 2020 to guide districts
on collecting data to inform teaching and learning. This prompt required CDE to describe schools
operational status and mode of instruction. The data collection included whether schools were
open for in-person, hybrid, or distance learning only every second and fourth Monday of each month.
At the end of January about 240 of approximately 1,100 school districts were offering some
in-person instruction and at least some of their schools. Over the course of the next few months
that number increased to nearly 930 districts reporting they were offering some in-person
instruction by mid-May. This prompt requires a description of the planned operational status
and mode of instruction of the state and its LEAs for summer 2021 and for the 21-22 school year.
LEAs are being asked through the CDPH bi-weekly survey to provide information on summer offerings
including if they are offering summer programs to all students or just a subset. Based on
information collected to date, LEAs representing 90 percent of all districts report that they
overwhelmingly plan to offer a summer program. Section B of the template asks the state education
agency to describe how LEAs will be supported in safely returning to in-person instruction
and sustaining the safe operation of schools. This section includes two areas of focus,
supports for LEAs and safe return to in-person instruction and continuity of services plan.
As part of this section the state is required to describe how it will support LEAs in implementing
the most current guidance from the Centers the Center for Disease Control and Prevention.
California has been very forward-thinking in its response to the pandemic
and as such the state has already taken a number of actions to address CDC guidance.
A few notable highlights include the CDSBE and various state partners work together to allocate
and coordinate the distribution of PPE hand sanitizer and touchless thermometers to all
California schools including private schools. We provided support for LEAs through technical
assistance, guidance, testing and resources and Governor Newsom in the California legislature
provided $6.6 billion in the state budget including $2 billion for in-person instruction
or IPI grants on March 5th, 2021 before the ARP Act was signed. As a condition of receiving
IPI grants, LEAs were required to offer in-person destruction as defined in AB 86
and funding can be used for things like COVID-19 testing, cleaning and disinfecting, PPE and more.
As noted in the background and context, SR 3 requires LEAs to complete two plans,
the safe return to in-person instruction and continuity of services plan and the SR 3
expenditure plan. The safe return to in-person instruction and continuity of services plan
includes four specific components, how the LEA will maintain the health and safety of students,
educators and other staff, how the LEA will ensure continuity of services, a description of the LEA's
policy or practice that provided the public with an opportunity to provide comment and feedback
and how such feedback was incorporated into the development of the plan and various assurances
and contact information. LEAs are required to submit the safe return to in-person instruction
continuity of services plan to CDE within 30 days of accepting funds. I would just note that
the ARP Act allows an LEA who had a plan in place as of March 11th, 2021 and that is compliant with
the ARP statute to be grandfathered in for a period of up to six months. As such, the state
allows those LEAs to use the abbreviated template to verify they are currently in compliance.
LEAs are required to review and if appropriate, revise their plans at least once every six months.
The CDE will track the required revisions through LEA quarterly and annual reporting on use of funds.
Similarly valued by California and evidenced in the various state plans including the learning
continuity plan, the expanded learning plan and safety plan and the local control and accountability
plan, ED also recognizes that seeking input from diverse stakeholders is essential to developing
plans for the use of ARP assur funds that are responsive to the needs of students, families
and educators. This section includes two focus areas including the ways in which the SEA gathered
stakeholder feedback as well as how the SEA has supported the coordination of federal funds.
Over the course of this year, state agencies have engaged in regular meetings with various
organizations including districts, charter schools, county offices of education, advocacy groups,
community members and more to elicit feedback, build understanding of the needs of California
students and explore areas for partnership and collaboration. This slide represents the ways in
which feedback has been formally submitted but the more informal conversations and collaboration
over the course of this year have also been an invaluable foundation for the development of
California state priorities to meet student needs. As noted previously, California utilizes
a unique approach in the way it receives and disperses federal funds. Because funds go directly
to the Department of Finance and are then subject to the rigorous budget process, the letters sent
to the governor's office, state assembly and state senate were an essential stakeholder feedback
mechanism. The legislature and governor's office received feedback again from approximately a
thousand organizations that work with students and schools in California. Additionally, CDE
hosted other opportunities for feedback including webinars. The first webinar solicited input from
LEAs and the public at large and had 572 attendees, while the second webinar solicited input from
advocates representing the interests of students who are English learners and their families,
homeless students, foster youth, migratory students, students who are incarcerated and
other underserved students. A draft of the state plan was also presented to the CPAC
on June 29th. It is important to note that all public comment received today will be considered
and where possible incorporated into the plan. Over the last, over the course of the last seven
years, California has acknowledged its vast diversity in LEAs and the student populations
they serve throughout the state. With the adoption of the local control funding formula,
our LEAs ranging in size from six students to 575,000 students had the freedom to, in consultation
with their local community, strategically allocate resources to best meet their unique needs.
While the federal funds provided guardrails for funding, each LEA is allowed the ability
to address the most pressing needs for their local student body. There is a statewide webinar
and module that provides information to LEAs related to the blending and authorized use
of ARP S or three funds. In conversations with a district superintendent of colleague of mine,
and I think I mentioned this before, he noted that there have always been cracks within our
education system. Well, with the onset of a global pandemic, in some areas those cracks have now
become chasms. To this end, and in line with California's commitment to continuing to ensure
we are providing equitable opportunities for all students, ED also recognizes that states have an
extraordinary opportunity to address the disproportionate impact of the COVID-19 pandemic
on underserved students through the ARP Act's required state set-asides to address the academic
impact of lost instruction time, provide summer learning and enrichment programs,
and provide comprehensive after-school programs. This section is comprised of four areas of focus,
including academic impact of lost instructional time, evidence-based learning and enrichment
programs, evidence-based comprehensive after-school programs, and emergency needs. CDE and other
state agencies, including SBE and the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, or CCEE,
continue to provide guidance to LEAs as they consider evidence-based interventions
that meet their local context to address students' needs. This includes webinars to
address high-quality distance learning and after-school programs, research-based best
practices in distance learning, development of various guidance documents, including equitable
grading practices, utilizing interim informative assessments, and the development of transformative
social-emotional learning competencies. Additionally, the state budget also focuses
on increasing the number of adults providing direct services to students and additional funds
for the California Community Schools Partnership Act, which will serve LEAs that demonstrate a
need to expand access to integrated services, especially for students disproportionately
impacted by the COVID-19 pandemic. Over the course of the last several years, again,
California has worked diligently to build and establish guidance and support high-quality
expanded learning programs. In 2014, CDE adopted quality standards for expanded learning programs.
These standards focused on fostering positive relationships between program participants and
staff, building positive relationships among program participants, offering a blend of academic
and developmental skill-building activities, ensuring high levels of student engagement,
maintaining an orientation toward mastery of knowledge and skills,
and providing appropriate levels of structure as well as opportunities for autonomy and choice.
With over 2,000 LEAs and 4.6 million students, the 6.2 million students, the budget and the CDE
continue to promote the necessity of engaging with community-based organizations or municipal
agencies to operate high-quality programs. States were given the opportunity to reserve funds for
emergency needs if applicable. The California state legislature and governor chose to utilize
funds to prioritize the most urgent immediate needs rather than reserve funds for future
emergency needs. In this section, ED recognizes that the safe return to in-person instruction
must be accompanied by a focus on meeting students' academic, social, emotional, and
mental health needs and by addressing opportunity gaps that existed before and were exacerbated by
the pandemic. It includes two focus areas, which are the LEA plans for use of ARPS funds and LEA
consultation. I think it is important to note that LEAs recently completed two additional plans,
the expanded learning plan required by AB 86 and the local control and accountability plan.
There is significant overlap in plan requirements as well as the process for completing these plans.
Over the course of the last few months, LEAs have been engaged in a collaborative process
with stakeholders to better understand student needs and to collect feedback for strategic
resource allocation. The federal funds received through ESSER III do not comprise the core funding
for LEAs but rather offer a way to provide additional support to needs that may have
already been identified. To reduce duplication of effort and promote coherent planning,
LEAs will be provided with the flexibility to reference or include actions described
in existing plans to the extent that those actions address ARPS requirements which have
already been discussed with stakeholders. When referencing or including actions in other plans,
the LEA must specify the amount of ARPS funds that it intends to use to implement the actions
and these ARPS funds must be in addition to any funding for those actions already included in the
plans referenced by the LEAs. Any existing plans referenced by the LEA will be required to be
accessible and available to the public. While LEAs may connect the expenditure plan with other
existing plans, they must still include a description of the action in the expenditure plan.
We just had a Tuesday at two yesterday with many of our LEAs and communicated this directly to them
as well. The interim final requirements for SER III state that the SEA establishes
the deadline by which LEAs must submit SER III expenditure plans and that the deadline must be
reasonable and should be within no later than 90 days of LEAs receiving their SER III allocation.
The September 30th deadline complies with this as it is approximately 90 days from the cutoff
for LEAs to submit assurances indicating they will comply with all program requirements.
However, following discussion with the U.S. Department of Education, ED clarified that it
is guidance that the deadline should be 90 days after LEAs receive funds. Since the ED has now
clarified the 90-day deadline is part of guidance rather than a requirement, CDE proposes the
deadline for the expenditure plan be pushed back until October 29th. The state views this as a
reasonable timeline given California's later budget process relative to when it received funds
and all the work LEAs have to do around COVID-19 thus far. While this additional time allows LEAs
the ability to further develop their plan for using SER III funds including consultation with
stakeholders, the extended deadline should not be viewed as a prohibition against spending funds
until the expenditure plan has been submitted. The purpose of SER III is to prevent, prepare for,
and respond to the COVID-19 pandemic and these funds enable LEAs to do so accordingly.
LEAs are also required to describe their efforts to meaningfully consult with stakeholders within
their SER III expenditure plans. This includes community engagement, how the LEA promoted
community engagement, how the development of the plan was influenced by that input,
and efforts for meaningful consultation. This may sound very familiar. As mentioned above,
the expanded learning plan completed by LEAs by June 1st, 2021 and the local control and
accountability plan that was due to county offices of education by July 1st have similar
requirements. I will say as a former superintendent I appreciated when there was an intentional
effort to align state and federal requirements which is why LEAs may reference or include
input provided by stakeholders and community members during the development of existing plans
as long as it is applicable to the use of ARPS or funds. The second to last section,
we're almost done, two more, requires that the state describe how educator workforce will be
supported. This section includes two areas of focus, supporting and stabilizing the educator
workforce and staffing to support student needs. The first portion of this section is focused on
the extent to which there is an educator shortage, how the state will assist LEAs in identifying the
most urgent areas for shortages or potential shortages, and steps to fill anticipated gaps
for certified teachers. The draft plan clearly lays out that California has shortages in a wide
range of teaching and support staff positions, and in recognition of that shortage, California
has used both state and federal funding to retain educators. The state stabilized funding
levels for LEAs throughout the pandemic to ensure that changes in enrollment did not impact existing
programs and staffing levels. AB 86 provided funding for a learning recovery program for
vulnerable student groups. It required LEAs use at least 10 percent of their LCFF entitlement to
hire paraprofessionals to provide supplemental instruction and support throughout the duration
of the ELO program, with a priority for full-time paraprofessionals. Additionally, the state budget
for 2021 also allocates significant funds for workforce preparation, as well as staff retention
and training. A few, and just a few examples, include 350 million one-time Proposition 98
general fund over five years to support teacher preparation residencies in designated shortage
areas and other grow-your-own teacher credentialing programs. 125 million one-time proposition 98
general funds over five years for the classified school employee credentialing program to support
more than 5,000 classified school staff in becoming credentialed teachers, particularly
in designated shortage areas, and 1.5 billion one-time Proposition 98 general fund over five
years for the educator effectiveness block grant to provide local education agencies with training
resources for classified, certificated, and administrative school staff in specified high
need topics, including accelerated learning, re-engaging students, restorative practices,
and implicit bias training. Three billion was allocated to expand and strengthen community
schools so they can become stable hubs that support a wide spectrum of student needs to
ensure students have the supports they need for learning, including integrated health,
mental health, and social services, alongside high-quality supportive instruction through
expanded learning time, including tutoring. These funds are targeted at communities with
high levels of poverty. 1.1 billion of ongoing funding was established to increase the numbers
of adults providing direct services to students. The funding will increase the grants that are part
of the local control funding formula that provide additional funding to LEAs that have high
concentration, over 55% of low-income students, English learners, and foster youth. The LEAs
that receive the funds will be required to demonstrate how they increase the number of
school staff on their campuses, including teachers, counselors, nurses, paraprofessionals, and other
staff. The final section of the plan requires states to detail how it is building capacity
at the SEA and LEA levels to ensure high-quality data collection and reporting. It also requires
the SEA to safeguard funds for their intended purpose. It is part of an effort to promote
and maintain transparency on how S or 3 funds are used. This section includes two focus areas,
capacity for data collecting and reporting, and monitoring and internal controls.
The state will continue its capacity and building the capacity of its LEAs to collect data on
reporting in the following ways. California publishes the California School Dashboard and a
variety of additional reports annually to provide information to parents, schools, and the public
regarding the progress of California's districts and schools across a variety of indicators
disaggregated by student group. Schools and LEA accountability report cards also play a role
in collecting and data reporting. This data includes the following disaggregated by student
groups where applicable. Assessment results, including assessments other than the California
Assessment of Student Performance and Progress, chronic absenteeism, suspension and expulsion,
student access to properly credentialed and assigned teachers, school staffing reports,
results of school climate surveys, and per pupil expenditure data. Data Quest, which is something
we don't talk about enough, is a fantastic resource which also serves as an invaluable tool to
provide information to parents, schools, and the public. In addition to CDE's reporting,
California developed an aggregate level data collection known as the school reopening and
summer instruction status dashboard to inform parents and the public about the current
instructional status of each LEA and the school plus data on summer instruction. The additional
data collection and reporting structure will be in place through the 21-22 school year.
Like the CDE process, LEAs have access to technical assistance related to collecting
and reporting this data via a helpline. The CDE provides both monitoring and internal
controls through a variety of measures, including extensive guidance related to the coronavirus
responses on numerous webpages that are continuously updated as a resource for both LEAs
and the public. CDE has and will continue to provide technical assistance by offering
extensive virtual ESSER and GEER training and presentations on various platforms to a wide
variety of audiences. Additionally, LEAs make contact the education stimulus box for additional
information, questions, and support. To ensure transparency at the state level, the CDE created
a reporting portal for LEAs to report quarterly on federal stimulus fund expenditures, including
ESSER and GEER, and percentages spent on each of the allowable activities. The CDE staff
check for accuracy and completeness of information. The reported information will assess CDE during
monitoring reviews of the LEAs and the use of CARES, CRRSA, and ARP funds. In addition,
the California School Accounting Manual provides accounting policies and procedures
and implementation guidance for LEAs. The CDE audit team also selects LEAs each year
for a federal program monitoring review using a risk-based approach. The CDE will conduct
monitoring reviews of federal aid using CDE's monitoring tool, and staff will follow up on any
findings and additional corrective action that is required of the LEA. In conclusion, the California
Department of Education and the State Board of Education staff recommend that the SBE approve
the draft of California State Plan for the American Rescue Plan Elementary and Secondary School
Relief Fund submission to the ED pending the SBE Executive Director approval of final revisions
requested by the SBE in correction of any typographical errors. This concludes my presentation,
and I will turn it back over to you, President Darlene Hammond.
Thank you very much for that thorough and clear presentation. We appreciate it. At this point,
we'll open the phone line for the public comment queue. Members of the public wishing to provide
comment on this item may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access
code provided on the slide that is shown now. While we are waiting for members of the public
to call in, I want to ask Member Sun if she has any initial comments before me, then I will ask
board members if they have any clarifying questions before we go to public comment,
and then we'll save our substantive questions for board discussion. So with that, Member Sun.
Thank you. Very well organized and detailed presentation indeed. Thank you so much,
Deputy Superintendent Maves. So you mentioned at the very beginning of your presentation about the
fierce team that put this plan together and absolutely agree that in such a short time,
the requirement that this took this plan took multiple divisions within CDE and coordination
of that and the coordination of even multiple agencies within the state.
And also getting the stakeholder feedback, including a special meeting with the CPAC
so that you had their input into this plan as well. So a couple of things additionally to note
and highlight from your presentation. I really appreciated that you provided the context for this
plan and the uses of the funds will be embedded within the California way,
within our LCFF framework, the dashboard and the LCAP. And so this provides that template or the
framework from which the LEAs will be able to utilize these funds and be part of their strategic
plan moving forward after the pandemic. I also want to that the plan also balances that local
control and the flexibility for LEAs to utilize those funds with the transparency of how those
funds will be utilized. So all of those are highlighted and were questions that were raised
by stakeholders and by the CPAC. And I really appreciate that you and your team have
done such a great job in addressing those. Thanks.
It's really helpful in California that we are really trying to integrate our planning for this
substantial amount of money with the state budget, with the other initiatives that I
described earlier so that we really have a way to take advantage of building a system with these
funds. So I appreciate the way in which the department, the board and others have worked
together on this. And as you say, it was a lot of work. Appreciate all of the clarity in the
processes as well as the substance of the work. We are, as noted, we asked for an extension
for California so that we could integrate this with the state budget process,
allow the state board to act on it in a timely way. And of course, it's reasonable then for the locals
to have at least a 90-day period after this to do the work so that they have funds, they can
continue to use them, but to really be sure that they're thinking about the integration of those.
So I'm pleased with where California has been in this process and how we've gotten to this place.
And I think the department is leading us in a very productive, systematic and systemic direction,
which I think is so important so that we're not just creating a Jackson Pollock,
throw the paint at the wall kind of approach to the funding and the spending, but really
developing a tapestry of programs and supports that will be effective and efficient also in
the use of the funds. So Eileen, do you have a clarifying question?
I do. And again, building on Member Sung and President Darling-Hammond's comments,
Deputy Superintendent Magues, what a thorough and clearly presented item. I do want to ask you to
clarify the number of plans that a local district has to complete. So I appreciated what you said
that we're trying as a state policy to not overlap, but to make the system fit together.
And you're building on the plans the districts have already prepared. So is there a way for you
to summarize as a result of all these different funds, what are plans that the local districts
have to complete? Sure. I would be happy to, Vice President Strauss. The first plan that an LEA had
to complete was through the learning loss mitigation funds, which was the learning continuity plan.
The second plan was the in-person through AB 86 for the IPI grant, which was the safe return
to schools plan. That one, they could either use an existing plan that they had in place
by March 11th, or they had to use an updated template. The expanded learning grant
also required a plan. And then we just completed the state local control and accountability plan.
So now they're ideally, I think what we would see as they've done a number of
stakeholder engagement around these plans that as we head into the expenditure plan,
we're not siloing that we really are leveraging what we have as the California way and integrating
these pieces and looking at how they can build upon. Terrific. Thank you. And I know that
effort is appreciated even while the situation continues to be complex
for both our state agencies and our districts. Seeing no more clarifying questions, I'm going
to move to public comment and then we'll do discussion after the comment. Are there any
public comments? Yes, currently we have 18 people in the queue. Callers, just a quick reminder that
this is only for item two. If you're calling for another item, please wait until that item is called.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning. I'm Ruth Barajas from Californians Together, and I'd like to talk about the negative
impact of the timing for the LEA's planning processes. The draft state plan references
the LCAP is due July 1st, 2021, and the adoption of the 2021-22 state budget in June. And 4.6
billion more for schools will be provided to provide targeted interventions with students
who've been disproportionately impacted by the COVID-19 pandemic. Extra funding is great,
but as a former elementary school principal and district EL specialist, I'd like to state the
obvious. Plans are developed based on resources available. In all likelihood, these additional
billions of dollars were not reflected in the LCAP spending plans passed by the local governing
boards on July 1st. There have been very limited input with the state ESSER plan on these funds,
especially considering that there was revision posted just 36 hours ago. So we urge the state
board to please provide for written feedback on this new version of the plan prior to submission.
Thank you. Thank you, caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now. Caller, you're live. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Good morning. My name is Dr. Barbara Flores,
and I am the current COVID president and school board member of the San Bernardino City Unified
School District since 2008. I would like to bring attention to the following. In the draft state
plan, identified needs are listed by required subgroups. However, the descriptions of how the
needs will be met with ESSER funds are not included in the plan. The federal template requires a
description of programs and interventions by subgroups, which is currently not contained in
the draft. We urge the SBE to request the department as specific examples. For example,
for English language learners, we need to purchase by literacy digital platforms that are multi-sensory
and multi-faceted, such as Footsteps to Brilliance or Mayan that provide a variety of digital books
and foundational skills that students can have access to. Our focus needs to be on equity,
access, and innovation programs to enrich and expand our ELs and teachers' pedagogical repertoire.
San Bernardino City Unified is doing just that, and we will use the money to expand the depth and
breadth of their use. Thank you, caller. Your time is up. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Yes, good morning. This is Liz Guillen with
Public Advocates of the LCFF Equity Coalition. We recognize and really appreciate the challenge of
producing documents and revisions and a certified timeline that Deputy Superintendent Mays and her
colleagues at the department are responsible. First of all, we thank the department for allowing
more time for LEAs and their communities and stakeholders to engage and plan intentionally
and in a way that integrates and adds to existing plans. We're still in the process of reviewing the
very latest revisions. However, I do want to point out that on the educator workforce, the
definition around teachers, we still urge that the definition be changed so that it is technically
correct as opposed to calling for properly credentialed teachers, but to really look at
the definitions that we use here in California. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Good morning, President Darlene
Hammond and members of the board. I'm Jennifer Hicks, Assistant Superintendent of Educational
Services at the Placer County Office of Education and the 2021 CISC Care. I'm sharing these comments
on behalf of CISC and CSF. We support and appreciate the effort to promote coherent planning
for LEAs by allowing LEAs to leverage the work that they've done over the past several months
with stakeholder engagement, with the identification of their local needs, and then the development of
their actions and services. This approach really allows LEAs to strategically plan for how to best
use their SR funds while also supporting and building on their existing funding and initiatives.
As revisions are being considered, we would also encourage highlighting the strong partnerships
in collaboration with county offices of education and specific examples of how this strategic
partnership will support the implementation of the plan and the critical work to safely reopen
schools as well as ensuring their continuing safe operation. Thank you. Your time's up. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning. This is Robert Manoring with Children Now. I just wanted to comment most focused on
the local, the LEA template, and wanted to first acknowledge that this budget is the most significant
investment in the state of Iowa. It's the largest investment in the state of Iowa. It's the largest
LEA template, and wanted to first acknowledge that this budget is the most significant investment
that I've seen in my entire 20-plus year career. There's almost $50 billion of new resources,
and this $13 billion pot needs to be put in that context. The template for the LEA
misses really an opportunity to integrate in a way. There are no outcomes that are required to be set
for how these funds will be used and what they will achieve. There isn't an explanation of how
this $13 billion fits into the broader picture. There isn't an emphasis of how these efforts will
be sustained when these one-time funds go away. And finally, there isn't the focus on programs
and interventions for targeted subgroups and how that differs from LCAP funding, which is a lot
for school and district-wide purposes. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and
affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Jamie Mauhai with Head Start California.
Head Start California represents the nearly 150 Head Start grantees in California, and annually
we serve over 100,000 kids and families. Our programs are based on the whole child, whole
school, and whole community approaches, so we are pleased that Dr. Darling-Hammond is committed
to ensuring this model continues through the universal pre-K expansion. We also wanted to
thank Superintendent Thurman and his team at CDE for their support and funding for Head Start in
response to pre-K and TK expansion. Unfortunately, we did not get the $50 million appropriation we
asked for, but we were still called out in the budget with the pre-K planning grant, so we're
grateful for your help in securing that. We are hoping that California can ensure equitable support
for all Head Start programs by investing $50 million of the ARP and ESSER funds each year for
the next two years to support Head Start and Early Head Start programs with flexibility at the program
level to use this funding to address staffing shortages, increase outreach to serve more families,
and help Head Start programs transition to Early Head Start as the transition to TK and pre-K moves
forward in the state. Thank you. Thank you caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools. For the last
16 months, our school districts have worked hard to develop several state and federal plans and
reports and establish local priorities, identified student needs, and detailed how they are going to
spend their state and federal dollars, all of this with stakeholder input. In Riverside County,
our districts developed their plans and reports in alignment with their LCAP, which also had
stakeholder engagement. We saw our districts leverage partnerships to enhance their stakeholder
engagement process and use technology platforms to offer virtual forums, increasing both
opportunities for input as well as number of participants. We believe the draft plan continues
to offer school districts with the opportunity to further align and complement the extensive work
that has been done so far with stakeholder input and respectfully ask for the board's approval of
the draft plan. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record. Your time starts now. Hello, my name is Eric Bonickson. I'm the Superintendent of Placerville
School District, a small school district in El Dorado County serving about 1,300 students.
I fully support the plan that CDE has put forth. If we must do another plan, that plan needs to be
concise, succinct, and to the point. That type of plan will be understood and implemented. A long,
drawn-out plan will not. As a small district administrator, you want me to spend my time
working with students and teachers, not spending my time sitting in my office writing plans and
reports. A long plan does not mean a good plan. It is just a long plan. I strongly urge a yes vote
on CDE's proposal and welcome the state board and CED to work with small districts of California
to reduce unnecessary work so that we can spend our time with our children. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning. This is Dr. Katherine Reimer from the San Ardo Union Elementary School District.
I'm a very small school district of about 120 students in South Monterey County. We do appreciate
and support the work that CDE and the State Board of Education has put forth into the plan.
I will say as a very small school superintendent principal, that is also completely modernizing my
facilities at this time that the stress of writing the plans and the time that it takes for us to
write the plans has become overwhelming in the past year. I have brought students back to campus
and it's very imperative for me to be with my staff and students during this time and I would
appreciate that you take that into consideration. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello? Yes. Caller, you're live. Good morning. My name is Lorraine Richards and I am a classroom
teacher representing the California Teachers Association. CTA appreciates the CDEs and
State Board's efforts to develop the draft state plan and CTA is fully supportive of the three
priorities laid out in the draft state plan and have been advocating for them tirelessly since
the start of the pandemic. We believe there is a need for intensive high quality tutoring and
robust academic support for students and we urge the CDE and State Board to provide guidance to
the LEAs to ensure these resources are being used most effectively. With the extension to October 29th
stated today, we recommend that the CDE provide strong guidance to ensure that authentic stakeholder
engagement occurs and impacts the expenditure plans prior to their submission. Lastly, we believe
that this is truly unique opportunity to leverage state and federal funds at a magnitude that has
never been seen before. Thank you for your time. Thank you, caller. Next caller, please state your
name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. I am Martha Hernandez, Executive
Director of Californians Together. I want to thank Rachel Maves for her excellent presentation
and her team for their tremendous efforts on this item. We wish to highlight the issue of supplement
versus supplant for the use of these additional funds. We urge that the directions to the LEA
expenditure plans be amended to request districts to describe how they are supplementing programs
and services in their LCAP. Identified needs are listed by required subgroups, however,
descriptions of how these needs will be met with the additional funds is not included in the plan.
In the section maximizing state-level funds, there should be a link between the needs and the plan,
services, and expenditures. We urge the board to request the department to update this section
to meet the requirements of the federal template for these funds to require a description of
programs and interventions by subgroups which is currently not included in the state draft.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now. My name is Tim Taylor, executive director of the Small School District
Association representing 62 percent of the schools in California, and we fully support CDE's draft
plan and commend staff and others that focus on doing their best to condense multiple plans and
reduce the redundancy of work schools are being required to do. We are still in the middle of a
pandemic and we have dozens of small schools that had to close because of the raging wildfires
and we need to make sure we focus on our students and their well-being. We welcome working with
other associations, CCE, CDE, and equity groups, and the state board to immediately address
efficiency of all plans. I also recommend we work with Secretary Cardone in Washington
to change the redundant processes at USDE so he's fully aware of the stress they are putting on
districts and state agencies. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and
affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Cecil Edwards. I'm the superintendent principal of Baker Valley Unified School District.
We're a small K-12 district situated on I-15 between Barstow and Las Vegas and have about
125 students. As a small district superintendent, I fully support the plan as it focuses on plans
that we've already written this past year. That's a good start, but we still spend way too much time
on plans and it's hurting our ability to run districts and support our students and families.
Even the IRS provides less requirements to submit their taxes for people who make less money.
Why am I submitting the same documents for 125 students as Los Angeles Unified School District
with 700,000 students and a staff to support those requirements? As the only administrator on site,
adding additional reporting requirements takes me away from the students. As we come back this fall,
I want to spend time with students and staff not making or writing more reports. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darley-Hammond and the state board. My name is Dr. Marlene Batiste and
I'm the director of state and legislative affairs for CABE and a director for the Oxford School
District. I think it's important that the state board understand that districts wrote their LCAPs
prior to ESSA funds and that the plan in place takes into account the way the districts will use
their regular state funds to support their unduplicated student counts. We are now to use
ESSA funds to do those things in our LCAPs. Those would be supplanting not supplementing.
Our district has taken ESSA funds into consideration and made additional plans
such as hiring literacy intervention teachers for all K-5s to support our unduplicated student
counts for learning loss. This is above and beyond our current LCAP plan. If we are to use
ESSA funds appropriately and ensure that those students with the most need receive support,
we need to require districts within the state plan to briefly explain how they will use these funds
above and beyond our current LCAP plan with stakeholder input in order to hold ourselves
and all LEAs accountable. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Yes, board president and members,
I'm Shelly Siegel Coleman from Californians Together and the LCFF Equity Coalition. Pages 38
through 45 address the federal template for maximizing state level funds to support students
and to address the academic impact of loss instructional time, evidence-based summer
learning and enrichment programs, and evidence-based comprehensive after school programs.
For each of these areas, the plan must describe the programs and interventions and how they
specifically address the disproportionate impact on student subgroups which are on pages 11 through
13. English learners are targeted with identified state funds, but there's no indication of what
these additional ESSER funds will do to supplement the state funds as is now required in the LEA
Expenditure Plan. The federal template requests specificity for addressing the subgroups. We
urge the state board to direct the CDE and we thank them for all their work, but to revisit this
section, identify specific... Thank you, caller. ...interventions for individual subgroups. Thank
you, caller. Your time's up. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now. Hello, Madam President. This is Brian Revis calling on behalf of the
Education Trust West. We agree with many of our partners in the Equity Coalition in that we think
the state plan could use some refinement. Specifically, we'd like to see greater opportunities
for engagement in a more specific direction around the use of data. We're concerned that in
parts of the plan it reads as sort of a record of things that were already going to happen
had we not received the federal money. We'd like to see more done to make sure that new things are
done to meet students' greatest needs and you can do that through things like making sure LEAs use
assessment data from state or local assessments to identify students for assistance, or one of
the recommendations from the LCFF Equity Coalition was for the CDE to update its findings on the
status of the digital divide so that we know the size of that gap going forward. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
My name is Stuart Packard. I've been the superintendent for 10 years in Buttonwillow Union
School District, a district that serves state preschool through eighth grade. We're located
35 miles west of Bakersfield. I'm currently serving as president of the Small School District
Association as well. We applaud the steps taken by CDE and its efforts to combine the current
plans with the USR funding. I have been working with folks at PACE out of Stanford University
to discuss the excessive paperwork and plan requirements that already exist for all schools
but are truly burdensome on small school districts. I encourage these efforts to go
further and would like to suggest the use of infographics which we use and attach to our
already 100-page LCAP. Our school community members, which is comprised of 95 percent
SED and 67 percent EL and who we know by name want our school to provide a safe environment,
a strong learning environment, and a quality school facility. We signed up to work with
our communities, teach students, and coach teachers. I shared with the folks at PACE that
we have nearly 20 different plans that must be written. The work required on these documents
takes us away from working with students and staff to improve our schools. Thank you again
on trying to combine plans on behalf of the small school throughout the state.
This concludes public comment for item number two.
Thank you very much.
At this point, we can begin board discussion. Board members, please remember to raise your hand in
the participant panel of Zoom if you have a question or comment. Are there questions or comments?
Looks like Member Rucker and Member Glover-Woods. Member Rucker.
First of all, I want to say thank you to the CDE staff for all of the work that they did
to put this plan together. A comprehensive state plan is an interesting piece of work.
There's a desire to be comprehensive, to cover all the bases, to cover all contingencies,
and think about all the different permutations of ways that this work can be done. At the same
time, there's a desire to make it concise and easy to read and consumable for all of the various
types of stakeholders who are going to read this document and then figure out what to do.
I want to thank you for the effort that you made to do that. I also want to thank all of the
stakeholders who called in because you read the document and attempted to consume it and break
it down into its component parts. In doing that breaking down in its component parts,
you figured out the places where it was broken or you could break it. I appreciate the comments
that you made about what more needs to be considered. That's where I want to start with.
Dr. Mays, in speaking about this plan, she spoke to the idea about the goal of alignment
among all of the multiple plans that LEAs are called upon to write. In response to
Board Member Strauss' question, she identified at least five plans. Those are just five plans
related to school planning. There are some other plans related to other activities
that districts have to do like significant disproportionality or making plans for
textbook adoption. All of those are different plans. One of the things I think that was done well
by the document was an attempt to get districts and others involved in doing this planning
to take a look at what you are already doing so that the expression of work and intent
as it relates to the funds that are articulated in this plan are things that you add on.
But that's where the stakeholders pointed out something that's very important.
There is this need to articulate what is being added on and I'll give a very explicit example
without naming the LEA. As you all know, I do follow and try to read as many
LCAP plans and now learning, comprehensive learning continuity plans as I can to understand
what districts are doing and one of the trends that's become very clear is that while districts
are very clear and very articulate about explaining their intent and what they're doing and how they're
doing it, what we still have not really given districts good models for is how to actually
create descriptions of how they're using program funding to meet specific identified needs
aligned to student subgroups. And this gets to an accountability requirement that we probably
don't pay as much attention to as we should. All federal education funds have three types
of funding accountability, maintenance of effort, supplement not supplant and comparability.
And so I heard in the conversation from almost all of the stakeholders in relation to what the
plan should say to look at and prioritize the needs of student subgroups that the plan,
the guiding plan here does not model how the funds can be used to supplement not to supplement not
supplant the funding that schools are already receiving and to supplement not supplant the plans
that districts already have in place. And so that is a gap in the plan. If the stakeholders from
multiple groups have read it and can't see it, then it's not, while it may be there, it's not as
clear as it can be or as it should be. So I think that's important to take a look at and to pay
attention to. But this plan is a good start. And that's what makes this important. It's not,
it's a living document, something that can grow and improve. And one of the most important
anchors of our school planning process is continuous improvement. So with the board's
action to approve this plan today, it doesn't mean that we're not charging the department staff
to hear the input from stakeholders and to learn from the concerns that were raised and continue
to improve the plan. I also heard site administrators talk about sitting in their office
writing the plan. One of the most important and comprehensive anchoring elements of the state's
plan is the focus on stakeholder engagement. So for site administrators who feel taxed by the
burden of continuing to write plans, I'm concerned that I'm not hearing from them in expressing those
concerns, the larger responsibility of engaging stakeholders in meaningful ways as this work
continues and goes forward. Because this is an iterative process, something that's not a one-off,
something that doesn't happen just to meet the deadline, as was pointed out about the July 1
LCAP deadline, but something that we should be continuously looking at, continuously revising,
and continuously asking, are the statements we wrote in this document really reflecting the
priorities that we are aware of and have our priorities changed over time? Those are two
continuous questions that we have to continuously live with, and so I'm concerned that there seems
to be expressed from what we heard among the stakeholders, this widening gap about what the
work of school planning actually means. And so I wish Matt Novel wasn't in Hawaii right now,
because this would be an instructive activity for him to listen in on, because these are the
types of bridging work that the collaborative is really going to have to take over and take charge
of to help reinvigorate the model of not only collaborative engagement, but to make sure that
all stakeholders have some consonance in the conversation they're having about doing this
planning. So I think we need to pay attention to how these funds are being used to meet identified
needs. I think you may have frozen.
African American students are the lowest performing subgroup in this school on all three of the
statewide tests in every single grade level tested, and not once is that subgroup ever called out as
a priority or ever identified for a specific type of support that the school district is receiving,
even concentration grant funding to provide support for. We need to figure out how to have
that conversation and make sure that change is going forward. Thank you so very much.
Thank you, Member Rucker. I have Member Glover-Woods, Member Strauss, and Member Patil-Brownson
coming up, so Member Glover-Woods. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond, and I first just would
like to say to the CDE staff as well as the SB staff just much gratitude for trying to coordinate
and develop this plan in such a very short time frame. As Member Rucker says, this is a we're about
continuous improvement. That is one of the foundational pillars of the California way,
I would say, and very appreciative of the comments that were shared today during public
comment on areas that we might be able to look at and continue to shore up. We're at a time where
we're receiving an unprecedented amount of dollars to focus on student needs during what has been a
very unprecedented time, and I think it's definitely a blessing to have those funds in place,
and there's also the recognition that there have been a plethora of plans that have had to be
developed at the local level over this last year. So the effort that has been made to try to
coordinate content from those plans as well as the extension to the end of October to get more
stakeholder engagement and more stakeholder input I think will be very helpful at the local level.
The reality is, and I might even just be saying something that is quite the obvious,
our students are coming back for in-person instruction. Some have already started and
over the next few weeks will be there, and we do want with that happening for there to be enough
time for the stakeholder engagement, the feedback, and for LEA staff to be able to welcome our
students back, ensure that the students and staff have the environment that they need,
as well as meet the requirements that we've received from ED as well in their planning. So
again, hopefully that extension until the end of October will allow for those things to coexist.
One last point that I'd like to just make and perhaps even get feedback on if there's feedback
to give is around what happens after plan submission. Again, there have been a plethora
of plans that have had to be submitted, and that's a good first step, but after October 29th,
once plans are submitted, I just strongly encourage for CDE staff and for all of us who
are here to support the LEAs and the students in our state to really look at how do we best
support the actual implementation from what is decided in these various plans, how we ensure
that the implementation is actually going to make differences for all of the students in our state,
as well as some very specific student groups that have been called out in public comment
and by previous board members. So I just encourage us to think beyond plan submission
and to really start to look at the impact of all of these dollars and how we will best sustain
many of the things that will be started over this time period. Thank you very much.
Such an important point for us to be thinking about, so thank you. Member Strauss and then
member Paccio-Brownson. So I want to build on our board member comments,
particularly member Rucker and member Glover-Woods, and appreciate all the planning and
implementation challenges going forward as schools reopen. So a couple of comments. First,
I appreciate the priorities that are identified in the plan, particularly mental health and
accelerated learning needs as students have a safe return to school, and I appreciate the
identifying of promising practices. I am concerned that there's, first of all, this is more money
than most of us have ever seen. We probably remember many more years of budget cutting
rather than budget enhancement. But because this is money over the next three to five years,
my fear is that people will just, as previous comment made, do lots of programs to try to see
what sticks rather than be thoughtful in a coherent, organized, strategic approach.
So, I mean, there's only so much capacity. People are exhausted from a really tough year.
They've taken a week or two off, and now they're getting ready to come back. I want to be really,
I'm hoping that the guidance from CDE will encourage people to be very thoughtful on what they
look at funding that they have several years to do this with some increased overall funding,
but some one-time funding to try to make the biggest difference and to collect data
to show evidence of progress. I think that's really important. And there's lots of data,
not just our state assessments, but local assessments, interviews with students,
all kinds of ways we can find out how we're doing. But I guess my caution would be that
we give LEAs permission to take their time to do it right, getting students back in a very safe
way, supporting teachers. They need mental support and collaborative support as well,
and to be very thoughtful about what strategic interventions they do to enhance and accelerate
learning so that students can catch up and continue to progress and that there'll be a
coherent approach. And I always remember Ted Sasser used to say, less is more. And I think we
need to give people permission to be thoughtful so that when the money, one-time money is gone,
and it's a huge amount of money, we have changed practice long-term for students and for leaders.
As Mike Kerr said, the first impact that will change achievement is students. The second impact
is actually leaders' support. And so I think we need to be thoughtful and give districts
the permission to take their time to continue to have coherent plans. That's my concern around
trying to make sure there's accountability for what they spend the money on. They collect data
and evaluate it so that they have a thoughtful plan going forward that really does impact
and change our system long-term. Thank you.
That's an important point. And I just want to reiterate that the state money that we
talked about earlier, money of those are ongoing proposals or they're one-time for five years so
that we can get a long trajectory. The federal money is at least a three-plus year trajectory
until 2024 and into the beginning of 2025. There's even a note that extensions can be
requested. So we should be thinking about, as you said, how this plays out over a period of time,
not rushing to spend it quickly if it's not coherent. Member Patil Branson.
Thank you. I also just wanted to offer appreciation for the department's presentation,
as well as all the stakeholders who have been, I think, bird dogging the website
and eagerly awaiting all of the recent updates and keeping abreast of all of the changes.
There's three points I just want to make. One is to concur with board member Rucker's
comments about needing to sharpen the focus and sort of the commentary around how underserved
students' needs will actually be addressed. I think the presentation we just heard was really,
I think, clear on the identification of needs for underserved students, but then less clear on how
the particular additional services would be aligned to those needs. Also, the description for
targeted services to address African-American students, I think, is also something that needs
to be lifted up as both what works for African-American students, but the analogy that
comes to mind is PolicyLink, a nonprofit organization that's talked a lot about the
analogy of curb cuts, curb cuts being for the disabled community, but then being something
that offers incredible supports for a variety of different types of pedestrians, of people with
strollers, of people who just need additional assistance, people on bikes, and thinking about
all the creative ways that services that are targeted for African-American students also
will have lots of spillover benefits for other students as well. On the stakeholder
efficiencies, I think, that were described of reusing feedback that has been collected
through the state budget process, I certainly am hearing LEA leadership talk about the sort of
pull it takes, the amount of sheer power it takes to undertake multiple bites at the Apple
stakeholder convenings, listening sessions, and I am sympathetic, and I also think at the same time
that there has to be a balancing, because purely using background from state budget processes that
ran from January to June has the potential to miss, I think, what are important feedback loops
from stakeholder groups that may have envisioned state budget process as a limitation of the art
of the possible. They may have different priorities that the state budget process has been adopted,
and some things have been baked in, and some have not, and assuming that what they listed
as the highest priority in January or February to be the same highest priority based on what
we know of the state budget that was adopted in June, I think is almost a point in time snapshot
that doesn't really represent that people are going to have change in priorities, and even
that priorities are going to change given the COVID year that we're having, and the Delta variant
changes in terms of how people are thinking about what is highest priority as we approach
the next school year. The last thing I wanted to lift up is the importance also of saying,
having clear instructions to say what is an investment that is funded through the
traditional state budget process and the LCAP process that was adopted previously versus what
is additional to the idea that it's supplemental to not supplant, but having greater clarity so that
LEAs can tell us what the difference is for the federal funding versus what is ongoing funding.
At this point, I'm seeing Member Rodriguez and Member Sun in the list.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. So I'd like to echo everything that my
fellow board members have said, and also, you know, President Darling-Hammond, when you were
giving your report this morning, I thought, you know, we're like on the edge of this spontaneous
unfolding of human potential in California, and, you know, thinking about what Member Strauss said
about, you know, having the necessary time to think this through, I would also concur that,
you know, there's the time that's necessary to make sure that
even if it's one-time money that it's spent in a way that adds to the system that we're creating,
and so that the directions are clear, you know, clarifying the supplementing versus supplanting.
I'm right there with everyone, and I also want to thank Member Rucker for her comments
regarding the stakeholder engagement, how necessary that is to be out there talking to students,
to families, to community members, to teachers, and my fear is that when something is rushed,
all of those voices do get left out, and then we're told what to do. I have been teaching,
I've been in the classroom for 21 years, and, you know, when there's something that is in a
hurry, you know, then teachers are told what to do, it creates a lot of stress, and it's passed
down to the students, right, you know, and like, oh, we have to get through this because of funding.
So thank you for all of your comments, and thank you, CD staff, for this tremendous presentation
this morning. Very clear. President Darlene Hammond, if I may just add one point of clarification
because it's come up a few times, and I think that this might help ease some of the questions
around supplementing versus supplant. I know typically with some of our title funding,
we have really strict rules around that, and the ESSER III funds are a little bit different.
ED states that the ESSER funds do not contain a supplanting prohibition, and as a result,
ESSER funds may take the place of state or local funds for allowable activities. However,
the program does contain a maintenance of effort requirement, which is designed to keep states from
substantially reducing their support for K-12 education. So I just wanted to provide that
quick caveat so that we could get some clarity around the supplementing versus supplanting.
Thank you. Thank you. That's very helpful. Member Sun? Yeah, thank you. I appreciate that
clarification, Dr. Maves. So I just wanted to say I really appreciate the comments and the points
that my fellow board members have raised with this. I know that the timeline for this particular plan,
our California submission application for these funds, has been on a short timeline.
But ultimately, as President Leonard Darden-Hammond pointed out, the LEAs have until 2024
to spend these funds. So just because we are submitting the plan and the LEAs shouldn't respond
by the end of September does not mean that all the money needs to be expended.
And so there could be a plan for a plan and then to have a more thoughtful process over the next
couple of years to fully maximize the LEAs plans in a thoughtful way. So when we are ready, I will
be ready to make the motion to support CDE's recommendation that we approve the draft California
state plan for the American Rescue Plan Elementary and Secondary School Emergency Relief on submission
to ED. I think we are ready for that motion. I see two hands up, but I think they're just
left up by accident. Remember Patio Brownson and remember Rucker? No, I didn't leave my hand up by
accident. I put my hand up again. You wanted to talk again. Okay, so hold on to that motion.
And we'll come right back to you because I know we want to make this motion and
have this passed before lunchtime. So we stand between ourselves and lunch. Member Rucker.
Okay, so no pressure. You just told me I'm the one standing between everybody and lunch. So
let me apologize now. I want to respond to or at least do a check down on what I just heard
Dr. May say. The comment I made, and I probably was the one that may have created the confusion,
so let me begin by apologizing for that. But I want to make sure I heard her correctly.
And I'm going to pare it back what I think I heard her say and I wrote it down quickly.
I believe I heard her say that as it relates to these ESSER funds,
that the maintenance of effort requirement, a provision that requires states to maintain spending
at a certain level in order to assure that locals don't dramatically reduce funding for their schools
or their school district within the school district from year to year, that is maintained
in the ESSER requirement. But there is no supplement, not supplant language or
accountability requirement as it relates to the ESSER funds. So districts can use this money
for other programs or to create programs. I want to remind this board at the beginning of my tenure
on the State Board of Education, the board was implementing the Quality Education Improvement
Act program and there was no supplement, not supplant language in the enacting statute
and in the regular. So as a result, in districts and LEAs that receive these QEIA funds,
what began happening is that districts often remove other funds from those school sites
and then gave them the comparable amount of QEIA funds. So they met the maintenance of effort
requirement, but those sites that should have been receiving additional support to provide
targeted assistance for those students did not gain, did not actually gain additional funding
to do that incremental support. So while I understand that there is a maintenance of
effort requirement, what the problem that is missing, and this is how we look at the gap
in what's not being addressed in the plan, there is no articulated, clear, and specific requirement
that identifies or matches the challenge of the students who are identified as the priority
with the funding to address those challenges. So we're still not matching supports and challenges
without a supplement, not supplant requirement. So I understand the technical thing about supplement,
not supplant, not being a fiscal accountability requirement, but I don't really see how we're
going to do this work to match supports and challenges and prioritize the student subgroups
that these funds are intended to benefit without a supplement, not supplant requirement
in our state plan. That's all. I think I did that. We can still get to vote on the vote on this and
get to that. So thank you, Dr. Darling-Hammond, for that. Thank you for making that point.
At this point, I do believe, oh, Member Patia Bronson, did you put your hand back up?
Okay. Yes. Sorry, I just, I'm, procedurally, I'm just trying to understand because the motion,
I think, that's in our board book says that we're voting on approval of the plan as written,
but incorporating feedback from today's discussion as part of a stakeholder engagement
session. Is that correct? Or am I misunderstanding it? And it's just-
Maybe we should ask Dr. Mayes to put up the actual recommended motion at this point.
All right. Maybe the shortcut to what I'm asking is, is there still, within the context of approving
this motion, room to ask the department to sharpen some of the language around focusing on
student subgroups and how the funding will be targeted to the needs identified for student
subgroups. And Rachel, do you want to speak to that question as well?
Sure. We can ask for certain things. I just want to be sure that that's-
I think, I think that there are a couple of things to keep in mind in the way in which
California approaches our budget and identifying some of these needs. There's a
nexus between what we offer as a statewide approach and then what we require and ask
and give latitude for LEAs to identify their unique needs and meet those at the local level.
So the budget defines a lot of ways in which we plan on supporting our students,
including community schools, support for mental health, diversifying the teacher workforce,
getting more teachers into the classroom, paraprofessionals. Those are the ways in which
we as a state are taking action to ensure that we're supporting these students.
And then at the local LEA level, there's the ability to get more granular to define what those
student needs are specific to that local context. And that's where you're going to see some of,
I would say, those more, again, granular or high quality practices that are going to be captured
and enacted and implemented at that local level. So I think, again, part of our California way,
as we've talked about it, is trying to give that balance to both of those pieces.
So I'm sorry, Dr. Mayes, does that mean, because I concur and absolutely agree that this is
local discretionary decision-making, but I think the request that a few of us have raised
is to ask that the LEAs describe what the nexus between their locally identified subgroup needs
are and the services that will address those locally identified needs.
And you're proposing that be an addition to the plan?
To just sharpen the language asking for greater specificity, but not prescribing in any way
what those report would be that the LEA would be deciding upon. But if they're identifying
X need, how they're identifying it with Y support. Linking needs and supports clearly in the plan.
If I may, I think you were just about to reply, did I? Oh, okay, sorry. Yes, absolutely.
But I think she's, are you there, Rachel? I apologize, yes. So I think we can look at that
a little bit further and take into account the ways in which we are doing some of that in the
LCAP and in the Expenditure Plan, because I do think that that is the intention. When we look at
the LCAP template, it clearly asks what the needs are underneath the goals and then the
are underneath the goals and then the subsequent actions. And that's included also in the
Demonstration for Increased and Improved Services section. But we will also take a look at the
Expenditure Plan and take that into consideration. So I think that we could include as part of the
Executive Director Approval of Final Revisions requested just a
clarification in the plan that that's important, that we are looking for that process of linking,
identify needs and supports to be. And I, you know, in the many, many pages of the plan,
I am sure that that is stated, but I think we're asking for a fine point on it.
Yeah, and if I may, I think that was the whole, it was very important to me that we framed all of
this within the California way in our context of our current funding and accountability system,
because that is embedded in equity and the identification of subgroups. So it is the
absolute expectation that these funds would support that process of identification at the local
level utilizing data. And I think those areas have been addressed. If there are specific areas
that need to be where the language might be sharpened, if you will, either in the LEA template
or in the application itself, I do think that we could, that would be part of that.
I hear us giving that piece of advice. And I think I'm sure it's being heard by our Executive
Director and by the CDE staff. So I think with that on the table, we could go ahead and make the
motion, the recommendation. All right. So I will then go ahead and make the recommendation
that is on the screen there that the State Board recommend that SBE approve the California State
Plan for the American Rescue Plan Elementary Secondary School Emergency Relief Fund submission
to ED pending the SBE Executive Director tool of final revisions requested by the SBE
and correction of any typographical errors. And do I have a second?
I'll second. Thank you very much. Any further discussion?
I just have a question. So with the, it does say in the language of the motion,
approval of final revisions requested by the SBE. So Board Member Patil Bronson did ask for
the sharpening of language and, you know, the unit of, the theory of action places the unit of change
in our LEA plan at the LEA level, but the theory of action in the federal template places the unit
of change at the student level. So that's the kind of sharpening of language that Member Patil
Bronson is particularly asking for to make sure the matching supports we're talking about
is not at the LEA level, but at the student level. So as long as we understand
those are the kinds of revisions being requested, I'm fine with the motion.
I think we've reiterated that. And I think our Executive Director and our
Deputy Superintendent have that understanding. So with that, I think we need a roll call for the vote.
Brooks, can you call the roll?
Member Son. Aye.
Vice President Strauss. Yes.
Member Rucker. Yes.
Member Rodriguez. Yes.
Member Patil Bronson. Yes.
Member McQuillan. Yes.
Member Glover Woods. Yes.
Member Patil. Yes.
President Darlene Hammond. Yes.
Passes unanimously.
All right. Thank you very much. Thank you, Rachel and others who contributed to the item.
It is 12 o'clock. We are adjourned for 30 minutes for lunch. Please stay in the meeting,
turn off your camera and your microphone, and we will see you at 1230.
All right. Welcome back. Have everyone had a good lunch?
And at this point, we need to reestablish a quorum. So Brooks, please call the roll.
Linda Brooks is not available at the moment. Please hold. We'll call the roll.
Please call the roll, then. I'd be happy for you to do it.
Thank you. You know what? I can do it. Do you have the list, Pam?
I do have the list, and Brooks has just arrived from his mission.
All right. I apologize. I had to step out first of all.
All right. Member Sun. Here.
Vice President Strauss. Here.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez. Here.
Member Patil O'Rounson. Here.
Member McQuillan. Here.
Member Glover Woods. Here.
Member Fatah. Here.
President Darling-Hammond. Here.
We have a quorum. Wonderful.
We are moving on to item three, and it is the California Assessment of Student Performance
and Progress, the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California, and the California
High School Proficiency Examination. We're going to update on program activities.
The CDE does not recommend any action as this information, this is an information only item,
and it will be presented by Mel Vang of the CDE. Mel, please begin.
Thank you. I will share my screen.
Thank you.
Thank you, President Thurmond, President Strauss, and for the Assessment, Development,
and Administration Division at the California Department of Education.
So agenda item three, again, is an informational item on assessment updates.
The item provides a summary of the developments and updates related to the California Assessment
of Student Performance and Progress with an emphasis on the California Science Test,
the California Alternate Assessment or CAA for Science, the English Language Proficiency
Assessments for California or LPAC with a focus on the initial administration,
the California High School Proficiency Examination or CHESB,
and an overview of the outreach and professional development activities.
Just reiterating that there is no recommendation, the CDE does not recommend
any actions for this item, and it is being presented for information only.
I will begin with the CASP updates.
As a reminder, the California Science Test is an assessment under CASP,
and it is aligned with the California Next Generation Science Standards or our California
NGSS. It is administered to all students in grades five, eight, and once in high school.
I would like to just highlight a couple key events that support the development of the California
Science Test. As of today, there is a virtual item writer workshop being held with California
science educators from July 12th through July 14th, and this is our last day for that event.
So during this workshop, ETS, who is our contractor, trained the educators in writing
a variety of new items using the three science domains, life sciences, physical sciences,
and earth and space sciences. And the CDE also continued to consult and meet with our
national science experts. Just want to highlight that in April of this year, a science summit
meeting was held with our science experts, and the focus of that was to provide some updates and
impacts on the CASP or the California Science Test over the past year due to the COVID pandemic.
And during that meeting, our national experts also provided updates to California on projects
that they are involved in that could potentially be helpful and provide assistance to our science
team. Next, I will cover a couple activities with the California Alternate Assessment
for Science, which is an online assessment administered to students with the most significant
cognitive disabilities whose individualized education plan or a program or IEP indicates
the use of an alternate assessment. So test examiners administer this assessment to students
one-on-one, and eligible students take the California Alternate Assessment for Science
in grades five, eight, and high school, just like the regular one. And this assessment consists of
four embedded performance tasks administered to students as close to instruction as possible
throughout the year. So with that, for the 2020-21 California Alternate Assessment for Science
results, California will again report preliminary indicators. We will provide a percent correct and
an indicator category. So these eligible students in grades five, eight, and high school
who submitted all four performance or embedded performance tasks will receive preliminary
indicators. And high school students who met the participation rule for the CAA for science in the
2020-21 school year have satisfied the federal and state science testing requirement for high school.
So local educational agencies will receive a downloadable student score extract file
in the test operations management system, or what we call TOMS, containing these preliminary
indicators for students who took all four of the CAA for science performance tasks.
The LEAs are encouraged to communicate the individual student preliminary indicator results
to parents and guardians in a manner suited to their local context. And then the CDE provides
tools on the preliminary indicator toolkit webpage to assist our local educational agencies
in reporting preliminary indicator results to educators, parents, and guardians, or other
stakeholders. Just to highlight a little bit that the California Department of Education will provide
aggregate preliminary indicator data in the form of that research file in the fall on the
CAA for science administration research files webpage. And for the CAA for science data,
this year the preliminary indicators, they will not be sent to the California educator reporting
system or on the public reporting website, as they are preliminary indicators. And there is no
official CAA for science student score report generated. So as a reminder, the preliminary
indicators are not precise enough to stand on their own, and that is why these results should
not be used to compare students, schools, or districts. With that, another opportunity or
activity that's happening with the California Alternate Assessment for Science is that there's
a, our virtual standard study meeting will take place with California science educators as well
as special education educators in August, from August 3rd through the 5th. And the CDE had planned
to ask for approval of these recommended threshold scores in November 2021, but however you all know
what happened that due to the pandemic and that the testing volumes for the 2020-21 administration
are fairly low, it is not enough to collect sufficient impact data. So the CDE will postpone
seeking approval of the state's Superintendent of Public Instruction's recommended threshold scores
from the SBE by one year. And for the standard setting, ETS, our contractor, is implementing both
the modified ANGOF and the extended ANGOF methods. The ANGOF method is really similar to the method
that was used for the regular California science test or CAST, and it is widely used, it's a widely
used approach for standard setting that relies on educator judgments and can be conducted using
smaller volumes of test data. So included in the standard setting process are the educators taking
part in making recommendations for the threshold scores that are to be presented to the SBE for
approval in the future. With that, I'm going to jump to the California English Language Proficiency
Assessments for California or ALPAC update.
Just want to highlight the initial ALPAC administration window just opened on July 6th.
We are continuously moving along in all these different assessments. As a reminder, the purpose
of the initial ALPAC is to determine a student's English language proficiency if a language other
than English was indicated on the home language survey. So this assessment transitioned, remember,
from a paper pencil test to a computer-based assessment last August, and it will continue
to be administered online except for the writing portion and for kindergarten through grade two.
So the paper pencil test option that was provided throughout last year due to the pandemic will be
available in this coming year, but only for students who have a need or express, or there
is an accommodation written in their Individualized Education Program or Section 504 plan. So training
has been available since April 12th through our training site called the Moodle Training Site,
and educators who are testing students have been trained in through that process. So the
CDE continues to provide options to administer the initial ALPAC remotely to assist LEAs. As you all
know, we're not totally safe out of the pandemic yet, so that those who are testing now have an
option as they transition back to in-person instruction for the 2021-22 school year.
Then moving along, I'd like to apprise you of our most recent administrations of the California
High School Proficiency Examination, or CHESB. Sorry, there's many acronyms, but I'll try to
explain. CHESB is a test for students who are 16 or older who need to verify their high school
level skills in reading, writing, and math. And in some cases, students take the test and leave high
school early to work or to attend college. And those who pass the test receive a Certificate
of Proficiency, which is equivalent to a California high school diploma in California.
So with that background, currently the California High School Proficiency Examination is a paper
pencil test that needs to be administered in person. So it was not administered in October
or May due to health and safety concerns related to the COVID-19 pandemic.
As you may recall, there were a number of students or test takers who came and expressed
their concern about not having this test available as an option for them. So due to improving
conditions, since that time, such as increased vaccinations and the return to LEAs, or many of
the LEAs are returning to in-person instruction, it allowed for the administration of the CHESB
in April and May. And students who had, for that group, we started with students who had previously
taken the CHESB in 2019 or in the summer of 2020 and had one or more subtests that they still have
to test. And we contacted them first, or Sacramento County Office of Education is the contractor for
this assessment. Students were contacted in the month of February and these students were offered
the opportunity to test either at the Sacramento County Office of Education site or the LA County
Office of Education for a two-week period in April. So registrations was then open for all students
during the month of April and then for the May administration as well. And the administration
was also available in May at those same two locations. Remember, we couldn't offer many
across the state. And for those two periods in both months, we were able to assess over
1,000, but it was more like closer to 1,800 students who had the opportunity to test before
the summer break. I just wanted to highlight here that it took a lot of effort to do this assessment.
I want to thank the LA County Office of Education for opening their facilities for us to be able
to offer an opportunity in Southern California. I want to thank SCOE, the Sacramento County Office
of Education, our contractor for administering these tests. And also CDE sent a group of staff
from our assessment office, mainly the CHESB office in our division, to go to Southern California and
help administer these tests because it was very difficult to get test administrators as well. But
we wanted to provide the opportunity as much as possible. So led by Don Kilmer, who is the
administrator of the office, they went to Southern California and support the testing effort.
With that, I want to share some outreach and professional development activities that we've
been doing recently or in the upcoming time regarding all these assessments or regarding
summative, interim, or formative components of our state assessment system. A complete
list of those opportunities is available in the outreach and professional development
activities section of the July SBE item. I will just highlight some of them here.
So starting in January, when there was a lot of need for communication with the LEAs, the CDE,
along with our contractor, ETS, we provided weekly office hours and coffee sessions that provided
virtual opportunities for LEA staff to ask questions and get answers about the spring
administration and the options that we were offering. So these office hours centered around
different topics such as LPAC or the California Educator Reporting System. And they really allowed
LEA staff to share their local practices and experiences. And then the coffee sessions were
an open forum for questions and answers. And we did this weekly until the end of May,
which we changed to monthly in June and July. So the CDE has offered another set of training
as the new LPAC coordinator training in June 2021. And this full day training was provided by County
Office of Education partners in 11 locations across the state. And it was the LPAC coordinators who
are new to their role and for coordinators who want a refresher. So the training included an
explanation of the responsibilities and time responsibilities for coordinators and also
timeframes along with procedures and practices to support managing test administration.
And then in June 16th, ETS on behalf of CDE presented the CASP and LPAC post-tests webinar.
And that included information about how assessments are scored, where the reports are located in the
test operations management system, and how local educational agencies can access their reports.
And then again in June, the Sacramento County Office of Education
convened a, on behalf of the CDE, hosted three virtual site administrator convenings, which
featured facilitated discussions with them to collect feedback on their recent experience with
the state assessments. And in addition, CDE staff provided presentations on the various formative
and interim assessment resources available from the state, as well as in other states.
And then in addition, during May and June, the Sacramento County Office of Education on behalf
of CDE conducted online interim assessment handscoring train-the-trainer workshops
to support County Office of Education trainers across the state. And then in June,
the Sacramento County Office of Education convened a, on behalf of the CDE,
assessment handscoring train-the-trainer workshops to support County Office of Education
trainers across the state to deliver handscoring training within their regions of the, their region
of the state. So these, there were four workshops were offered and two focused on English language
arts literacy and two focused on math. So the County Offices of Education were encouraged to
participate as a team of either English language arts, mathematics, or assessment staff to attend
this training to increase their capacity to conduct subsequent handscoring trainings for their
teachers. Excuse me. And the workshops were really designed to build the capacity of County Office
of Education trainers to engage educators with their region in understanding how
calibrating during handscoring can pretty much help deepen understanding of content
standards for ELA and math, strengthen the evaluation of student work, and promote the
use of student results to inform teaching and learning. And then starting this month,
the CDE is kicking off another professional development opportunity called the Interim Informative
Assessment Training Series. This training is designed to assist LEA staff in understanding
and using the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments as well as formative assessment process to support
teaching and learning. This is a live online training series which consists of three modules
and module one focuses on the purposes of different types of assessment including formative
assessment and such resources as the tools for teachers and how they work together to support
learning. And then there is a module two that focuses on how the Smarter Balanced Interim
Assessments can be used for classroom application. And then module three focuses on using hand
scoring to analyze interim assessment, written responses, and understanding expectations,
and determine next steps to support learning. So each module in this live online training
series will be offered multiple times between July and November of this year. And in addition,
each module is designated to be independent of the other modules so that educators can customize
their participation on the basis of the area or areas in which they want to further professional
development. So any LEA staff interested in this training may find the opportunities listed in the
training tab on the CASP.org website and also reach out to their county offices of education.
So with that, I will sum it up. I am towards the end of the presentation. I want to remind you all
that most of our updated tweets we are on Twitter and much of our outreach activities and resources
and PD opportunities are also tweeted on Twitter using our assessment handle here at CDE Assessments.
And then I will stop here to see if there are any questions. President Dolly Hammond.
Okay, great. Well, I want to start by opening up the phone line for public comment,
and then we'll come back to clarifying questions and then discussion. So thank you very much.
We're going to open up the phone line. Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item
may do so by calling the phone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is
shown now. While we're waiting for members of the public to call in, Member Sun and I will offer our
initial comments as liaisons and then we will see if there are any clarifying questions and then
we'll go to public comment. So Member Sun. Yes, I didn't have anything too much to add just to
thank Mao and her team for these updates. They're always very comprehensive and we always see that
progress continues to be made. And just wanted to recognize the CDE staff that went down and
actually helped with the administration of the CHVC. I think that's just wonderful that they did that.
Yes, I do too. And I just want to do the same thing, which is, you know, the amount of outreach
that this division does is really quite extraordinary in all kinds of ways around
just about every assessment that we have. So I just want to recognize and thank the staff for
the outreach for the very professional way that staff has handled assessment over this last year,
which was so trying and challenging in so many ways. And, you know, they offered weekly office
hours for districts and facilitated the variety of approaches that were plausible in different
districts for assessment. And then I just want to also recognize the ways in which the team and Mao
as the leader of that team is always looking ahead to find ways that we can improve and
innovate and develop our capacity to support students and teachers in the learning teaching
process with assessment. So there'll be more about that coming up in our meetings. But
just to flag now that it really is much appreciated. Any clarifying questions before
we go to public comment? All right. Let's see if there are any public comments.
Currently, we have no callers in the queue. All right. Is there any board discussion?
Again, this is just for information. Questions or discussion?
All right. We are just dazzled. Well, wait, wait. Member Strauss, there's a hand going up.
I just wanted to thank Mao and her team. And this is really helpful, even though there's no
action to give us an update on what the activities are and recognizing the challenges of the spring
I just want to reiterate what our former other board members said and thank the department for
all the extensive outreach and support to the field in these really unprecedented times. So I
just appreciated the update and the specifics. It's really helpful for all of us to know where
we are in the process in a variety of ways we have assessment. So thank you for the continued work
from the assessment division. And not seeing any other hands raised. I think we can move ahead
to item four, which is the California assessment of student performance and progress and the English
language proficiency assessments for California request for approval to proceed with the California
assessment system request for qualifications stage four, which is negotiations. And the CDE
recommends the state board approve the request to begin negotiations with the educational testing
service for the California assessment system contract to cover five administrations of the
CASP and the LPAC beginning July 1, 2022 through December 31, 2027. And the item will be presented
by Malvang. Take it away, Mal. Thank you. I will do that. Let me share my new presentation.
And go from there.
So thank you, President Darling-Hammond. I will just proceed with this item. Item number four
is the procurement update, which is an action item. So in this presentation, I will go over
the recommendation, the background of the request for qualifications for stage procurement process,
and share the results of stages one, two, and three with you, and highlight the stage four
negotiations, the next step in this process. So the action before you is the following. The
California Department of Education, or CDE, recommends that the California State Board of
Education, or SBE, approve the request to begin negotiations with ETS, or Educational Testing
Service, for the California assessment system contract to cover five administrations.
I'm sorry, there was.
I think Member Fiddle-Brown. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Okay. So let me start where I was. So the California Department of Education,
or CDE, recommends that the California State Board of Education, or SBE, approve the request
to begin negotiations with Educational Testing Service, ETS, for the California assessment
system contract to cover five administrations of the California Assessment of Student Performance
and Progress, CAST, and the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California, or ALPAC,
beginning July 1, 2022, through December 31, 2027.
The CDE issued the California Assessment System Request for Qualifications, or RFQ, as a four-stage
process to procure its next assessment contract for the CAST and the ALPAC. The four-stage
approach here allows CDE to identify an assessment contractor with the proven capacity
and expertise to successfully implement the California assessment system.
And in attachment one of this item, it includes the consensus scoring for stages one, two, and three,
and then an evaluation team comprised of local educational agency staff from different regions
of the state, and staff from different divisions across CDE met after the submissions from each
stage were received, and they evaluated those submissions. And the potential contractors who
passed a stage were provided the criteria for the next stage. So in stage one, the qualifications
round was released in April of 2020. I can't believe it's over a year now. The evaluation
team met in June to evaluate the submissions, which provided the CDE assurance that the potential
contractors have the capacity to support the California assessment system before we proceed.
And we identified 10 key areas of qualification for potential contractors to assure us that they
have the capacity and the expertise to implement our California assessment system. So two potential
contractors successfully met the required qualifications,
excuse me, including Educational Testing Service, or ETS, and the National Computer Systems, NCS,
Pearson, Inc. With this in, let's say, so in stage one, these are the qualifications results.
There were the 10 key areas of qualification were worth 100 points each. So for stage one,
there was a total of 1000 points possible as displayed in attachment one, as well as in this
table. The evaluation results of ETS and NCS Pearson, Inc. are in columns four and five.
The 10 key areas are as follow. One, computer-based and adaptive assessments.
Two, the system access through a single sign-on. Three, the test delivery.
Four, scoring and reporting. Five, a secure browser, being able to use a secure browser.
Six, reporting of test results. And then seven, item types and standards.
Eight, item bank and test forms. And then nine, item development and review process.
And then 10 is the universal tools, designated supports, and accommodations,
which are accessibility resources that they're able to do. So the evaluation results for stage
one were that ETS had 936 points out of 1000, and NCS Pearson, Inc. had 907 points out of 1000
possible. So moving on to stage two, both contractors or potential contractors earned
enough points to advance to stage two, which is the mandatory demonstrations stage.
So the stage two was released in August 2020 to the two potential contractors who passed stage one.
And for stage two, CDE identified five critical areas for the potential contractors to demonstrate
their ability to meet the California assessment system needs. And the evaluation team met in
November to evaluate the submissions received. And each mandatory demonstration was worth 200
points. And this stage, which is the mandatory demonstration stage, was worth 1000 possible
points as well. So the two potential contractors who successfully met the required qualifications
from this round included the, again, Educational Testing Service or ETS and the National
Computer Systems NCS Pearson, Inc. And here are the results of the mandatory demonstrations.
The five areas are capacity and performance. The second one was the item types, item functioning,
and rendering, and item banking. And then the third demonstration was accessibility resources.
The fourth one was being able to capture scoring and reporting. And then also
the fifth one was to demonstrate single sign-on capabilities.
Oh, sorry. And then, so I just wanted to highlight that the evaluation results for stage two were
that ETS had 953 consensus points out of 1000, and NCS Pearson, Inc. had 892 points out of 1000
possible. Again, both made it to move on to stage three, which is the formal written submission
stage. And in this stage, the criteria or requirements were released in February 2021
to each of the potential contractors who passed stage two, and they both had about a three-month
period to provide this submission. And in the formal written submission, potential contractors
were required to submit a draft scope of work and a proposed budget. So the CDE received the formal
written submissions from the two potential contractors, and the evaluation team met in
May to evaluate both the draft scope of work and the proposed budget. And the outcome of the
consensus scoring from stage three, along with the overall scores from stages one, two, and three
provided us with the recommendation before you today. And I will cover these results
in the following slides. And again, the results are also available in attachment one.
So for the technical scoring results, the evaluation team first reviewed and scored the draft scope of
work and staffing from each potential contractor. The scope of work is broken into nine separate
tasks, and each task had points based on the nature of their importance to the assessment system,
as well as staffing for a total of 3,000 points. Available in attachment one, this table also
displays the task name along with the possible points, and columns four and five are ETS and
NCS Pearson, Inc.'s results. So task one is the 3.1, it says 3.1, but three is the task section.
So task one is comprehensive plan and schedule of deliverables. For the task two, it's program
support and services where much of the training and professional learning occur. And then three is
technology services to support the system. For task four is about test security. And then the
task five is on accessibility and accommodations. And then task six is assessment development.
Task seven is on test administration. And task eight is on scoring and analysis.
And then task nine is on reporting results. And then staffing was also included in this
scoring round. So the technical scoring results for stage three were that ETS
had a total of 2,874 out of a possible 3,000, and NCS Pearson, Inc. had 2,512 points out of a
possible 3,000 points. Then the next step was that the evaluation team reviewed the budget
submission from each potential contractor. The number of points assigned for each task
of the budget submission was a percentage of the overall available points. And for each task,
the potential contractor with the lowest cost for the task received 100% of the points.
And then potential contractors with higher costs received fewer points on a per rated basis.
And I will go over this example so that we have a clear understanding of how this was done.
The example that I'm going over is also available in attachment one. So for example, let's say task
Y is worth 42 points. Potential contractor A submitted a bid of 1,000. And then potential
contractor B submitted a bid of 1,500. And potential contractor C submitted a bid of 2,000.
So in this scenario, potential contractor A received 100 points of the 42 points possible
for the task. Potential contractor B whose bid is 66% higher than the lowest bid will receive
28 points. And then potential contractor C whose bid is 100% higher than the lowest bid
will receive only 21 points. So the stage three budget scoring results are displayed
and applying that budget calculation evaluation process that I just described to each of the
same tasks provides a total of 1,250 points overall for the budget scoring. So again,
the tasks are the same as in the technical. And then the total here, which the budget scoring
evaluation results for stage three were that ETS had 880 out of 1,250 possible points and NCS
Pearson Inc. had 1,165 points out of a total of 1,250 points. So the next thing is to combine
the overall technical score from stage one, two, and three.
And this provides a possibility of 5,000 points total. So the overall technical score
for ETS is 4,763 out of 5,000 possible points and NCS Pearson Inc. with 4,311 out of possible 5,000
points. So the last step was ranking the potential contractor on the total of all points earned.
And with the technical score worth 5,000 and the budget score worth 1,250, there was a possible
6,250 points total. So ETS scored overall score is 5,651 out of 6,250 possible and NCS Pearson Inc.
scored 5,476 out of 6,250 possible. So this puts ETS first and NCS Pearson Inc. second in the final
ranking. And this is the process followed to bring this recommendation to you today.
So if the CDE receives SBE approval today, the CDE will work with the SBE staff and the
Department of Finance to begin negotiations for the next assessment contract and return to the
SBE in November with a recommendation for approval.
At this time, I've concluded my presentation and I will pause here to see if you have any questions.
So I'll turn it back over to President Darlin-Hammond for next steps.
Great. Thank you. We'll put up the slide for the public comments so we can get people in the queue.
There we go. Thanks so much. We're going to open up the phone line for the public comment queue and
members of the public who wish to provide a comment on this item can do so by calling the
phone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now. While we're waiting
for members of the public to call in, I want to ask Member Sun if she has any initial comments
before me and then we'll see if there are any clarifying questions before we go to public comment.
So, Member Sun. Yes, thank you. I don't have any initial comment other than to reiterate that this
was a year-long process and as you can see from the presentation, fairly technical, so there may
be some questions around that. I will have a comment before we take final vote on this item,
but at this point that's all I have. Thank you. Great. And I'll just add thanks for the care that
was taken in the process. It was a very careful, well-designed, carefully managed process that
got us to this point, so we appreciate that. And I understand that in the negotiations here is the
opportunity for us to be clear about what we really value and what we really need in our
assessment system, and I will add some comments about that when we get to the discussion part of
the item. In the meantime, then we'll go ahead and find out if there are any public comments.
Oh, is there a clarifying question? Yes. Okay, please go ahead, Member Ruck.
Could you go back to the slide explaining the rankings for the budget?
And Dr. Darling-Hammond, thank you for your comments because I actually had three questions,
but your comment answered two of them, so I just want to, I do have a question about the budget
question. Okay, great. Could you go back to that? Is it possible to go back to that slide?
Yes. Is that okay for me to go back? Yeah, I think so. People are queuing up. They hopefully
have written down the phone number. Okay, wonderful. Are you looking at this?
Yeah, this is what I'm looking at. So in your explanation, the lower the bid, the better it is
for each of the contractors. So the relative weight of this number, the 28 or the 21,
is a good thing. Is that correct? That's right because we want the best for our state and we
want the contractors to be mindful of how much. Okay, and then could you go to the second budget
slide where you showed us the scores that Pearson and ETS received? So on the budget description,
keep going. So on the budget description, as you go through these points and you did this rating
and evaluation for each of the elements in their budget proposal, they got these scores.
So on these scores, does this mean that on the formal written submission total for their budget,
that the budget proposal for Pearson was qualitatively higher or lower than the
proposal for ETS? I want to make sure I understand what that number means.
Yes, that number means that the higher you get, the lower your costs. So if you look at it,
so Pearson's budget scoring is lower, but this is, so really the budget scoring is all a calculation
based on the sample. So as you can see, let's say for example, this test administration one,
there was a total of 277 points and ETS, since they have the most, they were the low bid on
that task and then it was rated. But if you could see, let's say for example, the reporting,
Pearson had the low bid and they had all the points. Right, so yeah. Okay, so yeah,
I was tracking this. So overall, as it relates to this section of the evaluation,
overall in each of these areas that you evaluated, Pearson submitted a lower cost projection
than ETS did. Is that correct? That is correct. Okay, I just wanted to make sure I understood
that because as I was looking at the sum, the total when you got to the final slide and saw
what was added up, I wanted to make sure I understood the relative weight or value
of all three of the items that were added up to the total. Thank you very much for that.
You're welcome. Thank you for asking. And if we could put the caller phone number card back up
in case anyone else is trying, I believe there may be a caller in the queue. So
do we have public comment? Yes, currently we have one person to speak for item number four.
Callers, just a quick reminder, we don't want to miss anyone. So make sure that you call in promptly.
Caller, you are the next and the only person in line. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now.
Darlin Hamann and Vice President Strauss, esteemed members of the board and Superintendent Thurmond.
This is Walt McDonald, President and CEO of ETS, a not-for-profit organization whose mission is to
advance quality and equity in education for all. I am constantly moved by the passion ETS has for
supporting learners and educators. It's that passion that has brought me here today to say
that ETS and our subcontractors are thrilled about the possibility of continuing our serve
to serve California. ETS has had the privilege of working with California for several years.
Over that time, we've built strong partnerships with all stakeholders, creating a collaborative
approach that has allowed the board and the CDE to bring the best solutions for California.
ETS will fully support California from day one of the new contract, offering the stability and
quality that is critical. As the state recovers from the pandemic, ETS is committed to creating
innovations that will continue to improve the validity, reliability, and utility of the
California assessments. It is our mission. So thank you very, very much.
Thank you, caller. At this time, there are no more callers in the queue. This concludes public comment.
Terrific. Thank you. And we're going to launch into discussion questions, substantive questions,
or comments at this point. And I see member Rucker, your hand is up, I think, for perhaps
a substantive comment. Yeah, I'll wait on my, I do want to be in the queue, but I will take my,
I left my hand up so you, because I do want to be in the queue, but I don't want to be the first
person since I asked some questions. Okay, but we'll see if anybody else raises their hand.
Are there others who would like to engage in discussion at this point? Remember,
Son, you had some thoughts you wanted to share. Yeah, so before I move the recommendation,
I did want to just provide some comments around this next evolution, if you will,
of California assessment. And I, the public speaker mentioned that providing that continuity,
but I would also really like to emphasize the innovation portion of what we can do with our
assessments and how we will evolve these assessments to the next level. We, I think we've
done an excellent job thus far, and with this initial stage, getting new assessments up,
but I would like us to be more visionary, if you will, in looking at that, that next stage.
So in the stage four negotiations, if the board approves the recommendation,
I would like to emphasize that those conversations occur.
Thank you. And I'll just plus one to your comment, and then I'll come back to
member Rucker, and anyone who raises their hand. I think that this is a moment in the country,
and certainly in California, where there's a lot of interest in ensuring that assessments
really are supportive of teaching and learning, give information in a timely way, potentially
even during the school year, not waiting for everything at the end. We've heard a lot of
comments from our constituents during this last year, desires for increasingly authentic approaches
to assessments. So it's going to be an era of rethinking assessments that's beginning to be
part of the national conversation and the conversation in many states. So we do want a
partner network that is really ready to take on challenges of developing with us what the next
generation of assessments will be in California. So that will be an important part of our next
stage. Member Rucker. Thank you. As we were going through the evaluation metrics that were being
used to evaluate each of the contractors, I was stuck not only by the quality and the depth of
the metrics that were used in the multiple metrics, but also the types of questions
that the contractors were asked to address in their proposal. The three areas that really
came to my attention, and I will hold this, I would ask you to stick a pin in this.
Each year when we go through the reporting at the beginning of the assessment window,
I always ask the staff if they would share information about the use or access across the
state on the accessibility tools or the inquiries that are made. This past year,
because of the pandemic, obviously we didn't get that information. But the fact of the matter is,
given what our population of students who are identified who have some type of requirement
for accessibility or additional assessment support, what has been reported to this panel
about accessibility tools really shows that there is a far lower use and access of those tools
by students across the state than it should be. So one of the things I would really like to see
addressed as part of the contract would be, and it could be that it's under reported or that
districts don't monitor it well enough to make the report, or the data is just simply not collected
in a way that we can assure we're getting the timely and accurate report. So I would like some
attention paid to accessibility tools and how they are used, and I would really like to make sure that
we receive information about the use of those tools, not only because we have African American
students who are over identified to receive special education services, but then I want to know
if those students are receiving those accessibility supports in the assessment system as well.
The second thing I want to do that I think is important, and this was more as a result of what
California did in choosing the assessment instruments they've used, but I think it's
important to pose questions about what we want the assessment to tell us. Right now when we get the
assessment data back about students, for example, in English language arts, we are posing four
questions. How well do students understand stories and information that they read? How well do
students communicate in writing? How well do students understand spoken information? I think
it's important in looking at what we're at, what we are asking the assessment to do for us, that we
start with the question, what are we asking the assessments to tell us? So have we moved far enough
along in the assessment discussion and are we sophisticated enough to pose questions that will
tell us more? I'm not sure if the contractor is ready to do that work, but they have certainly
been doing a lot of work in California and they know we ask those questions. So I would like that
even if they can't deliver on that as part of this contract right now, I would like that conversation
to start. Thank you. Are there other comments, questions, further discussion before we make a
motion? All right, we may be ready for a motion. Okay, I'll go ahead and move CDE's request to
begin negotiations with ETS for the California assessment system contract to cover five
administrations of the CASP and the LPAC beginning July 1, 2022 through December 31, 2027. Terrific,
do I have a second? I will second. Thank you. Is there any further discussion?
We will hold a roll call vote. Brooks, please call the roll.
President Darling-Hammond. Yes.
Number Fatah. Yes.
Number Glover-Wood. Yes.
Number McQuillan. Yes.
Number Petillo-Brownson. Yes.
Number Rodriguez. Yes.
Number Rucker. Yes.
Vice President Strauss. Yes.
Number Sung. Aye.
Motion passes unanimously. All right, well, you've earned a 10-minute break, so
we're going to turn off our cameras and our microphones for 10 minutes and we'll see you
back at about 1.40. Okay, welcome back. We have a quorum, so Brooks, will you please call the roll?
Yes. President Darling-Hammond. Here.
Number Fatah. Here.
Number Glover-Wood. Here.
Number McQuillan. Here.
Number Petillo-Brownson. Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Rucker. Here.
Member Strauss. Vice President Strauss.
Thank you, and Member Sung. Here.
We have a quorum. All right.
Item five is next on the agenda. It is the School Accountability Report card.
Approval of the template for the 2020-2021 School Accountability Report card. The CDE
recommends that the State Board approve the SARC template for the 2020-21 school year,
and the item will be presented by Cindy Kazanis of the department. Hey, Cindy, where are you?
Good afternoon.
Wherever you are.
Yeah.
All right. Excellent. Cindy Kazanis, the director of the Analysis,
Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division. It's very nice to be with you.
This item for the template for the School Accountability Report card is typically on
consent, and so I'm very happy today to share some slides with you to talk about its purpose
and some things that are new for this year. Some will be only for this year, and others will be
for perpetuity. So as President Darling-Hammond just indicated, our recommendation is that you
approve the School Accountability Report card template for the 2021 school year.
This is a couple of things we'll be covering during the presentation.
Specifically, the School Accountability Report card is very unusual in that it is
a requirement that was under Proposition 98, which of course was passed over 30 years ago,
and because it's a requirement under Proposition 98, in order to make changes to it, there are
different vote thresholds in the legislature. So many of the things that you're going to see
today come from not only the state requirements, but also education code requirements, which are
mostly articulated in Education Code sections 33126 and 33126.1.
The SARC is also the way that the state complies with the report card requirements under the Every
Student Succeeds Act. I think that there sometimes is a misconception out there that the California
school dashboard meets this purpose, and it does not. There are very specific things you have to
put in your report card, which don't tend to be user-friendly, and so we still depend on the
School Accountability Report card to meet those requirements. I wanted to spend a minute or two
talking about our alignment with the Local Control Funding Formula. As I mentioned, because this is
a requirement under Proposition 98, there are things that we can change and make suggestions
to you all to change to the template, but there are others that would require an act of the
legislature. So in order to do what was under our control for the SARC, immediately following
the passage of the Local Control Funding Formula, taking you back to 2013-2014, the California
Department of Education reorganized the SARC. We put tables that were aligned with LCFF metrics
at the beginning and the non-LCFF tables at the end. These tables are also organized into sections
that align with the state priorities. So if you were to look for Priority 1, you would see,
you're going to see today that our teacher tables are up front as well as facilities and such
like that. We wanted to make sure that we could do whatever was under our power to align the template
and make it user-friendly for our local educational agencies to also leverage for the completion of
the Local Control and Accountability Plan. Now keep in mind that the Local Control and Accountability
Plan is a district plan and the SARC is a school plan, so they don't automatically align just by
virtue of what they're designed for. I wanted to mention that back in 2016, under President
Chris' leadership, he helped to get grant funding to the department to undertake what we called
the Underbrush Project. And really that was led by Marsha Bedwell, who used to be our
General Counsel, and she put together this amazing document literally five years ago that talked
about a cross-border between where LCFF and things like the SARC and other pieces could be aligned
moving forward. The department used that as a template to sponsor legislation in 2018,
AB 3096, which was unsuccessful, to again further align these two documents and reduce the burden
to the field. So we are enlightened to see letters that say that there is support for this moving
forward and just wanted to mention that the department has done what we can within the
constraints that are the SARC template. So first I'm going to go over just a couple of brief things
that are updates to existing tables. We know that the SARC is also used as a comparison
for our data reporting across states. And so two things that were some easy wins for us that we
thought would be very relevant is to start including student groups where it was appropriate
for tables. And so we've added for the graduation rate table and the expulsion and suspension table
student group information. And of course that's not just limited to our race and ethnic groups,
but also the expansive student groups that we collect, such as homeless, foster youth,
English learners, and so on. Additionally, as a condition of the waiver for accountability
from the U.S. Department of Education, the department is required to report out on
chronic absenteeism. So we are adding these as new tables and you're seeing this information by
student group as well. And then on to the meat of the presentation. We have spent the last year,
year and a half working on this new set of data. Of course, you as a board adopted new definitions
for our teacher requirements under the Every Student Succeeds Act. And up until this year,
we have not been able to report out on it because we didn't have the full set of data. And we are
currently still working on that data to produce it publicly this year for the first time. So for the
last several years, you've always seen teacher credentials and teacher misassignment and vacant
teacher positions. This coming year, we are suggesting the addition of four tables. And
the tables would include just a summary information for table six for teacher preparation and placement
for table seven, teachers without credentials and misassignments. So we're breaking down table six
and table seven and table eight. Of course, table eight is around our student, our teachers who are
assigned but are out of field. And again, that's the definition that you all adopted back in
November of 2019. And then finally, information around class assignments. We worked very closely
with state board staff, very appreciative of everybody that was involved, including program
staff. Of course, Barbara Murchison has since retired, but we do have somebody here to answer
programmatic questions if needed, as well as an entire team around supporting this work,
which again, we've spent quite a bit of time on. We're really excited to be able to release it for
the first time this coming year. I would also state that we've heard really clearly, we heard
at the last board meeting an interest in looking at the local assignment option, and we're working
internally and with state board staff to see if we can make some updates to our definitions,
potentially for the September board meeting. So in terms of the new tables around
assessments, and I know that you all spent a lot of time this year talking about assessments
and how to meet federal reporting requirements. Well, this is the mechanism in which you actually
report out on that work. So we are suggesting for this year only adding two tables, table 17
and table 18. And these tables are limited to districts and school sites where the California,
the CASP assessment was not able to be administered, and so local assessment was
administered in its place. And so under, again, the waiver that the department received and
the work that we've continued to do on your local assessments or rather around assessments,
we do have to report out on assessment data. And so the state is not able to collect this data, but
at the school level, you will see this information reported out by each school
that administered the local assessments. So these are the two tables that allow for that to occur.
So specifically for this year only, we've added a if-then statement, it goes back to my days of
being in logic class at university. So if the statewide summative assessment and the ELA
mathematics were not a viable option, then LEAs were allowed to use a different local assessment
under, again, the direction that the State Board of Education provided districts. They must meet
the criteria around these pieces that they are aligned with the Common Core State Standards for
English Language Arts and Mathematics. They had to be available to grades three through eight and
eleven, and they needed to be uniformly administered across the grade, grade span, or school. And so
what you see in the tables, and it's a little hard to tell because this is a Word document,
and districts will be reporting out on this potentially through an electronic system,
is these tables are expandable. So if you had a school that had one assessment in grade three
and a different assessment in grades four and five, they can complete those tables individually
for those grade spans. So for the science assessments, it was of course administered
by local educational agencies this year, and if it was not viable to make that assessment,
there were no other options available. And so for schools that did administer the CAST,
we will pre-populate that information for districts in schools that decide to use the pre-populated
templates. And then a piece that is not referenced in our write-up that we later found out after
the agenda item has posted was that there is a requirement that was put in place through
non-regulatory guidance from the U.S. Department of Education in September of 2019 that requires
the reporting of assessment data disaggregated by Militarily Connected Student Group. And this
actually came from Member Rucker, so I just wanted to acknowledge that she had reminded us that this
was a requirement that we weren't able to of course comply with last year because we didn't
have assessments to report out on. But for this year, for the SARC, we are suggesting that the
tables be amended to add this information. And just to make sure we're all on the same page,
what that means and how we're collecting it through CALPADS, which of course is our student
mobile data system, it means that a student has at least one parent who's an Armed Forces member
on active duty or serves on full-time National Guard duty.
So with that, I'm happy to turn it over to President Lyndon Arlene Hammond.
All right. Let me see if I'm on mute. So we want to get queued up for public comment on this item.
And the phone number is in front of us with the participant access code. Members of the public
wishing to provide comment on this item can do so by calling that phone number and using the code.
And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask Vice President Strauss
as Accountability Liaison if she has any initial comments. And then there are clarifying comments.
We will take those from the board before we turn to public comment.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. So first, Cindy, I just want to thank you for the explanation
and the history that you started the presentation with. I think people don't realize that we're
sometimes tied to existing legislation. It's amazing it's 30 years old, because many of us
remember when that all was implemented. So I just want to thank you for that explanation.
I appreciate the continued effort by the CDE team to align with LCFF so that the whole system
is aligned and appreciate the continued look at the underbrush project to try to deal with
try to deal with things that are not as focused on our priorities. And so I just appreciate and
reinforce the effort to continue that work. I appreciate, too, the extra the new tables that
are going to be included. I know districts are looking at how they use their local assessment
and how they report it back. I know I've had several questions from local districts on
those that did local assessments. I appreciate your explanation on that.
And adding the four-year adjusted cohort graduation rate by subgroup and the
chronic absenteeism by subgroup, I think, is quite helpful to the work that we are tracking
with our data. And I am looking forward to the continued work on the teacher credentialing
and misassignment issue. I know that's been very complicated when people have enough units
and get local approval and then are considered misassigned. So I appreciate the continued work
that the department's doing to try to clarify that. And I understand that will be coming back.
So initially, I just appreciate the continued work to get this aligned and the guidance that
the districts will need to complete this part of the SARC with their local reporting data
based on assessment from the spring. Thank you very much.
And I want to just record my enthusiasm for the teacher data joining the SARC in the ways
that it will. As a clarifying question, I know we're going to come back to this in September.
But Cindy, I wonder if you would like to just explain the ways in which you're trying to tease
out the local assignment option. Sure. So we, of course, with this data set,
I should start with this is a data set that we don't own ourselves. We have to, and we are
required to work with our sister agency, which is the Commission on Teacher Credentialing.
There was a data system planned over 10 years ago called Cal Tides that would have automated
this process. And the former governor returned the funding to the federal government for that
project. So we are in a state of manually transmitting data to the Commission on Teacher
Credentialing once it's been collected from our student level data system. And the Commission on
Teacher Credentialing this past year stood up a new tool to help with miss assignments called
CalSAS. And with that tool, they are now giving us back information that we've never seen before.
It's the detail in which for local assignment options, we are seeing courses that are also
provided with the appropriate education code section. And so I think we've gone through five
or six iterations of this data set. I think the six just came in last week. And so we are looking
at the data. And I think it's important to note that we are together jointly working on definitions
and business rules. And so some of these things you can work on ahead of time, but others you
can't really work with until you actually have the data in your hands. And so we are
going through an iterative process where we're trying to tease out credentials in which there
may not be, rather courses in which there may not be a credential available to staff to become
qualified for. And so that is an angle that we are looking at right now, again, with guidance
and leadership with the State Board of Education staff. Terrific. Thank you. Appreciate that.
Are there any other clarifying questions? I see Member Glover-Woods' hand up.
Thank you. First, just wanted to reiterate all of the appreciation. The SARC is one of, again,
continuous improvement. It just keeps getting better and better. And I'm quite excited about
the tables. I did have a clarifying question, so I want to be sure that I'm reading things correctly.
For tables 17 and 18, which are the tables for the local assessment test results,
the acronym that's in the box is DPC. And on page three of attachment one, it says DPC is
data provided by CDE. Is that accurate, or is that data that's going to be provided by the LEA
and would then not be DPC, but maybe DPL? I'm sorry to throw that at you, Cindy. I'm sorry.
I just wanted to be sure that I'm not assuming or misinterpreting where that data is going
to be provided. Member Glover-Woods, you are the only person that has recognized that,
or at least told us that you recognize also. Kudos to you. We missed that. That is a typo.
Those data will, of course, be provided by local educational agencies. The department
has no access to local assessment data. My apologies, and thank you for making us aware
of that typo. No apologies needed at all. I just wanted to be sure. That was my assumption,
but you know what they always say about assuming, so I just wanted to clarify,
so thank you very much. Very good. And seeing no other hands up,
I'm going to see if we have people waiting for a public comment.
Yes, currently we have seven speakers for item five. Just a quick reminder, callers,
if you would like to speak to this item, please go ahead and call and get in the queue.
We want to make sure that we don't miss your call. Caller, first caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond and State Board members. Diana Wu, representing
the Association of California School Administrators, acts to appreciate the
State Board's and CD's proactive approach to removing certain courses that do not include
associated teaching credentials, such as AVID, student government, and leadership from local
assignment options. Furthermore, under ESSA out-of-field educators who teach students
for four or more consecutive weeks to trigger a four-week letter notification to parents,
acts to request CDE work with LEAs to develop a robust communication plan to help LEAs communicate
this information clearly and effectively to parents. Thank you. Thank you, caller. Next
caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
SBE members, my name is Sheila Whitley and I am a classroom teacher representing the California
Teachers Association. CTA appreciates the CDE's effort to update the SARC template for the 2021
school year and understand the need for the updated SARC tables dealing with State Priority
1 and the degrees which teachers are appropriately assigned and fully credentialed in the subject
area for the pupils they are teaching. We also appreciate the stakeholder engagement conducted by
CDE and SBE staff. We believe that no teacher should be assigned to teach outside their
credential authorization and CTA should take any and all actions to protect misassigned teachers
from being accountable for such misassignment. In closing, CTA looks forward to being a continuing
partner with the CDE and SBE on any efforts to utilize data from the CDC to highlight Priority
1 and specifically around future misassignments. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Good afternoon, Jessica Sacco
on behalf of Children Now. I'd like to start off by thanking the department for their incredible
effort and hard work that went into this year's revisions as well as the redesign of the SARC
application and thank them for their work on stakeholder engagement, particularly around
the teacher data tables that were included in this year's SARC. We're very excited to see them
included. However, we would, I do have a few modifications that I would recommend including
displaying teacher data and assignment in percentages in order to allow for more
easy comparability as well as percentage information for district and statewide data
so that comparisons can be made and more useful, followed by teasing out the data by student
subgroup in order to facilitate and identify and correct any disparities that may exist.
Relative to tables 14, 17, and 18, I would ask that table 14 actually include data from the 2018-19
administration of the CASP as well as the state. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Hello, my name is Micah Studer. I am the chair
elect for the Student Programs and Services Steering Committee for the California County
Superintendent's Educational Association. I'm calling to express concern about local assignment
option deeming our alternative education teachers as out of field. Specifically, Ed Code 4045
provides for our teachers to be assigned to teach multiple subjects so that we can appropriately
staff and provide education for our most out-of-promise youth. We would appreciate CDEs and
the board's reconsideration of this classification for our students, especially as publishing this
information publicly may lead to some unfortunate ramifications in terms of staffing and our ability
to recruit and retain highly qualified educators for our most out-of-promise youth. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello, this is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates. I join my colleague Jessica Salka from Children
Now on her comments around the hard work that went into the Sark revision, thanking the department
and staff for that, as well as the hard work on the teacher data tables, the teacher info tables,
yes. We come from the perspective of civil rights advocates, so we're concerned about
equities for high-need students and transparency to parents and the public, and that's in service
of sound policy and practice decisions so that every student has a fully prepared and properly
assigned teacher. And because of that, we want to underscore the suggestions that Jessica made
around displaying the teacher authorization and assignment data and percentages so that this
information can be comparable. We also had suggestions about adding more information
through a couple more columns for district-wide and statewide data and collection and display of
this data by student subgroup. Thank you, caller. Your time's up.
All right. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record. Your time starts now. Hello, Madam President. This is Brian Revis calling on behalf of
the Education Trust West. I wanted to say that we agree with our equity partners, Ms. Salko and
Ms. Guillen, from Children Now and public advocates around modifications to the tables
regarding teacher data and transparency and assessment results. Please take a look at our
letter of July 9th, our coalition letter, and I want to say on table 14, if I understand correctly,
because of problems with comparability, most LEAs will fill in the table with
NA and provide no results, and I think we would much rather see data presented
that may be imperfect, and we think that there's a way to do it to provide adequate explanation
around why they may not be comparable, but we're concerned about flying blind here during the
pandemic, and we'd like to see the public have as much information or at least some information.
Your time's up. Thank you. Thank you.
Last caller, last call for speakers for this item.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. This is Bill Lucille with Ed Voice. Ed Voice supports the addition of tables
six to nine in the SARK as a first step for including more transparent teacher quality
at the site level. We also recommend further disaggregation of teacher assignment data by
subgroup and percentages whenever possible and appropriate. Ed Voice would also like to see
improvements in the assessment reporting, specifically table 14 of the proposed template
compares CAS results from the last two years. However, the proposed example incorrectly suggests
data is not available, thereby providing no information on potential learning loss to parents,
community members, and other stakeholders. Districts administered the CASB and other
standards aligned assessments this spring, and they have data for several years on how students
and subgroups were formed. We urge the board to direct available standards aligned assessments
data from 18 to 19 through 2021 to be included to better understand learning loss experienced
at a school. Thank you. Thank you, caller. This concludes public comment for item five.
Thank you very much. At this point, if we have comments or questions as part of board discussion,
we can launch that process. I see member Rucker. Anyone else? Please raise your hand. Member
Rucker, get us going. Thank you very much. I want to begin, Cindy, by thanking you for this work.
This is an example of the really important role that stakeholder engagement has taken. We have
been working on writing this definition and figuring out how to present the data about this
definition in a comprehensible way ever since ESSA was signed into law by President Obama and that
federal mandate came into existence. So I'm actually very proud that we've gotten to this
point, even if it's taken multiple years, because it's very important not only to refine this
definition, but to understand that once we start posting this data, which is simply a number,
not an interpretation, and not a narrative explanation about ineffective or effective teaching,
that it's going to be subject to a lot of interpretation. So with that, I want to thank
all of the stakeholders who called in to add their suggestions about ways to continue to refine
and add granularity to what is being reported in the school accountability report card.
My favorite one line about the accountability report card is there's thousands of pieces of
information we would like to see, but at the same time, we'd like it to fit on one page and be
easy to read. So it's important for us to look at what it is we actually use the school accountability
report card for, but also what is the exact state and legislative mandate that requires the work
for what is reported in the school accountability report card. While it would be nice to create
ways to compare statewide or school-wide data about teachers from school to school or from
district to district, that's not something required in the mandate. And so if this is something we
want to explore, the human capital, both at the district level and the state level, should be
considered. It doesn't mean the ideas or the suggestions are not worthwhile, and I appreciate
the stakeholders for making that suggestion, but that's going to take more time, and I think it's
a worthwhile pursuit to consider as well as the time worth looking into. I also think it's important
for us to start thinking about with this new level of granularity and this new definition,
what are we getting from these reports that are going to inform decisions districts make.
Let me be clear, especially as it relates to the local option
comment that came from one stakeholder, and he really did make an important point.
There's a lot of terms of art that swirl around about teacher credentialing, and one of them
is multiple subject credentials. Multiple subject credentials have nothing to do with a grade or
age span, but the way a particular teaching assignment looks, and so it might be worthwhile
for the department to take a look at exactly what's being reported concerning alternative
education teachers. If their alternative education program is a single group of students in a
self-contained but alternative setting, there's nothing wrong with a multiple subject credential
holder teaching that program, and they would meet the requirement of being an effective teacher based
on the way that assignment looks. So I think we have to take another look, a more granular look,
at some of those certifications, not just the name of the certification, but what the authorization
actually means, so that we can make sure in examples like what we're given concerning the
alternative education programs, we're actually representing what that teacher's assignment
looks like, and not just the certification. But I'm so proud, Cindy, to see this work done,
to see this work progress, and thank you so very much.
I don't see other hands raised, so I'm going to take the prerogative of the chair to dive in on
my favorite table. Cindy, you'll probably guess what it is. Table six, followed by seven and eight.
I'm so excited to see those, and I want to go into my document here to ask a question.
So my understanding of table six is that when you add up the lines there,
fully credentialed intern without credentials and misassignments assigned out of field,
and unknown, you would end up with 100%. Is that correct?
I'm not able to hear you. Are you on mute? I'm not on mute. Can you hear me now?
Yeah, I can hear you now. That is correct. It should equal 100%.
And what will happen if, it sounds like what you're thinking to do is to divide the local
assignment option folks into those that may continue to be called ineffective, and those that,
you know, cannot have a credential because there isn't one for AVID or a leadership course or
whatever. And where would you think to put them? Would they just be under properly assigned?
Or is that still a question? We are working on through those conversations.
Okay. We're still looking at the data, and I, you know, the data is in its first year
of collection, and we know from first year of collection of data, that's a little messy.
So we need to be sure that the credentials and the local assignment options follow the criteria
that set forth an education code. And I don't know that we're quite there yet. So that's why
I'm not, I'm not being very specific. I just want to say. It's okay. We're coming back to it. I just
was curious. And so maybe we would even add a line that says local assignment option or something,
but I'm ahead of you. So we'll talk about it in September. The other question I have,
I thought that the comments from some of the stakeholders about just adding a column that
allows for percentages as well as numbers and the sort of comparison to the state or district average
might be an easy thing to do. Is that your view that that could be readily added?
We can always convert numbers to percentages. I understand the interest there. We've talked
about it with our team. I think, you know, the table could get very large. So the suggestion
that we would make is for the rows, with the exception of the total, be simply in percentages
and then have the total be the numbers. And so people can go back and figure out,
you know, what the conversion of the percentage to a real number. But adding district and state
level data, you know, once we're into the data set, we can definitely put those comparisons
in place. We do have a little bit of time. Of course, you're adopting the template now.
We will not release the data in the template until after Thanksgiving. So we do have quite
a bit of time to work through this, at least for SARC purposes. Our intention is, of course,
to get a public data set out much sooner on DataQuest. So I just want to put that out there.
We've got some competing reporting things going on. But in terms of what you've asked for,
yes, that is doable. And again, that would be our suggestion on how to make that addition.
That'd be great. I think they'll make it usable for the folks who want to use it.
The other suggestion that was made was to do reporting by student group. And I don't know
what viability of that suggestion is. I would just mention, I think that that's
really outside of what the statute is calling for. I think there are other places to include
information such as student group and to member Rucker's point about, you know, this is simply a
data point. I think there probably needs to be more support without the rollout of that.
So here for me, I do have a hesitation in including that in the SARC, but it is definitely
something we are eager to get out, especially on DataQuest. You really change the narrative when
you add the student group information in there. But I think as far as meeting the needs and
alignment with the criteria under ESSA, that is at this point, I mean, it would go above and beyond
the statute. Okay. So noting that it would be more straightforward to provide percentages,
as well as a number that you could also cross-hatch with, and district and state data,
I'd like to suggest that that be part of what we propose for the template in response to the
stakeholders and hold off on things that take us into more uncharted territory. And we'll look
forward to hearing more about the local assignment options when we see you in September. Are there
other questions or comments? Hearing none, I will just add one more comment, which is hooray. This
is really terrific. And I'd like to see if there's a motion. I'll move approval.
Thank you. Is there a second? I will second. Patricia Rocker will second.
Thank you. Any further discussion? All right. We'll call the roll for votes. Member Son.
Aye. Vice President Strauss. Aye. Member Rocker. Yes. Member Rodriguez. Yes. Member
Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member McQuillin. Member Glover-Woods. Yes. Member Fatah. Yes.
President Darling-Hammond. Yes. Motion carries. Wonderful. We are making good time towards the
goal of getting out by five. So that was both well presented and efficiently voted on.
And what a great contribution to the data that will be available to people in our state.
We're going to move on to item six, which is the proposed revisions of the local control funding
formula, local indicator self-reflection tool for priority three. That's quite a mouthful.
It has to do with family and parent and family engagement. That's our priority three.
And the CDE recommends that we adopt the revisions to the local indicator self-reflection tool for
priority three, proposed in attachment one. And I'll allow the State Department representatives
to explain all of the aspects of what that means in terms of revising the instructions,
the narrative prompt, requiring LEAs to provide an appropriate response within each field,
and then updating the dashboard functionality. And this item will be presented by Lindsay
Tornatore and Lisa Borrego of the California Department of Education. Lindsay, please begin.
We can't hear you. I can't hear you.
Sorry. Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Strauss,
Chief Deputy Gregson, and members of the board. My name is Lindsay Tornatore,
and I am the Director of the Student Achievement and Support Division. And I am joined here today
with my colleague, Lisa Borrego, the Director of the Family Engagement Division. You will be
hearing from Lisa a little later on in this presentation, as she is here today to share
an overview of the newly established Statewide Family Engagement Network and how they are
partnering with the CDE to respond to the strengths, progress, and the focus areas for
improvement identified in this item. As President Darling-Hammond stated, this item is an action
item. The action that the CDE is requesting the State Board take is to adopt four key revisions.
Two, the current version of the LCFF local indicator LEA self-reflection tool for priority
three, parent and family engagement. There are four primary revisions that we are bringing to
all of you for consideration today. All of these can be found on page two of this item. A summary
of the recommended revisions is provided on this slide, which are to revise the instructions to
clarify that the ratings and narrative responses must be based on an analysis of stakeholder input
and local data, separate the current single narrative prompt into three separate narrative
prompts, require LEAs to provide an appropriate response within each field in the dashboard,
and update the dashboard business rules to avoid LEAs from inputting null signs or zeros,
and to include the revisions to the self-reflection tool that are potentially adopted by the State
Board today. I want to take a moment and highlight the fact that these proposed revisions do not
create any new requirements for LEAs. Rather, the proposed revisions are intended to provide
additional clarity for LEAs as to the process they are to use in reporting progress towards
priority three and to ensure that LEAs address each aspect of the narrative prompts.
The recommended revisions to the priority three LEA self-reflection tool were informed from the
findings of a study that was conducted in partnership between the CDE, the Region 15
Comprehensive Center, and the Regional Educational Laboratory West, both at West Ed. This study was
conducted at the request of the State Board, made during its March 2019 meeting, when the current
version of the LEA self-reflection tool for priority three was adopted. The request from
the State Board was that the first year of implementation of the priority three local
indicator self-reflection tool be conducted based on the data LEAs reported in the 2019 dashboard.
The findings from the analysis of rating and narrative data, along with the full report,
was shared as a June 2021 information memorandum.
While the focus of this item is on the recommended revisions to the priority three self-reflection
tool and based on data that was reported pre-pandemic, I would like for all of us to
acknowledge the work that our LEAs are currently doing and have been doing related to continuous
improvement and continuous capacity building of meaningful family engagement. It is because of
our LEAs commitment to family engagement and continuous improvement work that we even have
local indicator data to study and discuss. The priority three local indicator data reported by
our LEAs already has and will continue to stimulate conversations around how to support
and improve family engagement practices throughout the state for the benefit of our students and
families. The content of this report was developed by the CDE under the leadership of our small but
ever-mighty local agency system support office, or as we know them as LASSO. Special thanks to
Lydia Venturia, Radine Girola, Joshua Strong, and our former LASSO leader Jeff Brashears
for publishing such a thorough report. Also, this report would not have been possible without the
support from the Region 15 Comprehensive Center and the Regional Educational Laboratory West.
We would like to extend our sincere gratitude to our colleagues Margit Berg and Minchen Gidini for
their guidance and commitment they offered to this report. Appreciations and shout outs to all of
our colleagues at the Region 15 Comp Center and Rail West at Westud. So in the next three slides
highlight some of the trends and themes that emerged out of this study and showcase that the
vast majority of California's LEAs are engaging in high quality research-based practices that
promote accessible, inclusive, and data-driven parent and family engagement. This study used
a mixed methods approach. The quantitative analysis examined how 2,361 LEAs rated themselves
on the implementation of the 12 research-based practices in family engagement on a five-point
Likert scale. The qualitative analysis examined the narrative responses from a stratified sample
of 198 LEAs to gain some insight into how they describe their strengths, focus areas for improvement,
and how they referred to evidence and engaged stakeholders. The quantitative analysis yielded
the finding that the most commonly reported rating across the 12 research-based practices
identified in the tool was a rating of four full implementation out of possible five points of full
implementation and sustainability. Similarly to the ratings, the majority of the LEAs from the
stratified sample reflected on their strengths and progress when responding to the narrative prompts.
The table on this slide provides some specific examples as reported by LEAs in the 2019
dashboard related to their strengths and focus areas of improvement. This table is an abridged
version of the data shared in the 2019 report which can be found in Appendix D of Attachment 2
of the June 2021 memo. LEAs reported that engaging underrepresented families as an area of strength
and progress noted that some of their efforts included cultural recognition and cultural
celebrations, providing interpretation services and materials in multiple languages,
removing barriers and providing transportation and child care during meetings,
and supporting students experiencing homelessness, foster youth, students with disabilities,
and other underrepresented students. And LEAs who reported that providing system-level support
as an area of focus for improvement noted that some of their efforts and aspirations include
to create a supportive collaborative system, structure, and environment for both educators
and families, to use various communication methods to communicate with families and or
to make information accessible and understandable to all families, and to provide training and
support to administrators and staff to better engage families. Other themes that were identified
among the LEA's narrative responses for how they reflected on their strengths, focus areas
for improvement, and how LEAs referred to evidence and engaging their stakeholders include but are
not limited to building trusting relationships, two-way communication with families. I will not
read the whole slide but I will just summarize. And some focus areas for improvement themes
provide professional development on cultural proficiency and best practices for working
effectively with our underrepresented families. And as far as how LEAs refer to evidence and
engage stakeholders themes, survey data or other forms of evidence to inform their responses to
the narratives and or ratings, feedback loops, focus groups, interviews, surveys, et cetera,
were most commonly seen throughout our analysis. And again, this table is only a small sampling of
the data shared in the full analysis from this study, which can be found in attachment to
Appendix D of the June 2021 information memo. And it is a good transition from discussing the
themes of strengths, progress, and areas of focus for improvement that I now introduce my colleague
Lisa Borrego, who will share the role that the newly established statewide family engagement
network is playing in the continuous development of LEA's capacity to improve and expand their use
of evidence and creative ways to engage their parents and families in their continuous improvement
journeys. Thank you, Lindsay. Good afternoon. It is my pleasure to be here with you today to
provide some information related to the statewide family engagement network. We first want to
acknowledge and extend a heartfelt thank you to all of the families throughout California who work
with their schools and their students every day. You make a difference in the lives of your children
and in your school communities. We are eternally grateful. I'm excited to share a little
information related to the family engagement network. The statewide family engagement network
was established in January 2021 and is a partnership between the California Department of Education
and the Parent Organization Network. We want to acknowledge the project director Adeseli Simeon
for her leadership and contributions to this work. Participants currently represent a diverse
group of stakeholders including advocacy groups, county offices of education,
institutes of higher education, charter schools, LEA's and state agency partners. The meetings
provide an opportunity for cross-agency collaboration along with opportunities to
discuss capacity building and identification of best practices in family engagement.
The following two slides provide some background on the three meetings that have been held since
January 2021 along with items discussed at each meeting. Our first meeting was focused on providing
input and feedback to the 2019 priority three data analysis that was mentioned by my colleague Ms.
Tonotore related to the R15 CC and REL West report. In addition, we heard from the parent
organization network who shared their findings of their report, family engagement in California,
strengths, needs and trends from the 2019 priority three self-reflection tool
which were based on a sample of LEA narratives. Input and feedback from the meeting helped to
inform the recommendations proposed in this board item. The second meeting in March focused on the
idea of developing a cross-agency network to support capacity building of family engagement
in California. The parent organization network shared a landscape analysis of family engagement
resources and supports organized by the three domains identified in the priority three
self-reflection tool. Input was also gathered related to family engagement supports needed
in preparation for reopening of schools. And the third meeting in June was about sharing best
practices related to the three self-reflection tool domains, building relationships, partnership
for student outcomes and engaging families in decision making. There were partnership
presentations and resources shared. A topic area for the group continues to be how to engage with
the field to increase broader support for family engagement and building capacity as we return to
in-person learning. As demonstrated by the work that is going on with the family engagement
network, the analysis of the 2019 priority three local indicator data has stimulated multiple
conversations around how to support and improve family engagement throughout the state in today's
current environment. Lindsay, I'll turn it back to you.
Thank you, Lisa. So as you can see, the work of the FEN is a bright spot for our state,
and we are excited for it to continue to grow and contribute to the capacity building of
our LEAs as a shared responsibility and partnership among all of us. The current
priority three LEA self-reflection tool, which was adopted in 2019, is included in this item
as attachment two, and the proposed tool is included in this item as attachment three.
The actual revisions that are being proposed to be made to the tool are to update the visual
format to emphasize the practices and ensure that all LEAs rate themselves on a scale of one to five,
break up the single narrative prompt box into three separate narrative boxes as opposed to
one narrative box to address all three components of the current prompt, add the phrase based on
the analysis of stakeholder input and local data to the beginning of each narrative prompt,
and create dashboard business rules that will remove the ability for LEAs to enter a zero or
null sign or leave narrative prompt boxes blank. Again, it is important to note that these four
recommendations do not bring any substantial content changes to the tool. Rather, the
recommended revisions provide additional clarity for LEAs related to the process they are to use
in reporting their progress towards priority three. As shared in attachment three of this item,
you can see that the recommended revisions are incorporated by way of formatting changes to the
tool, and the other revisions will be addressed through dashboard functionality updates.
If the board takes action to adopt the proposed revisions to the tool today,
then this revised tool will be used in tandem with the development of the 22-23 LCAP,
and will be reported in the dashboard in fall of 2022. The 2021 dashboard will open for 2021
local indicator data reporting on August 13, 2021. The proposed revisions to the priority three
self-reflection tool will not be applied to the 2021 local indicator reporting period.
Back to the CDE recommendation, which is the CDE recommends the State Board of Education take action
to revise the LCFF local indicator self-reflection tool for priority three,
parent and family engagement, to include the four recommendations gleaned from the 2019 study.
And with that, I will turn it back to President Darling-Hammond.
Thank you for that very both well presented and engaging item. We want to put up the public
comment slide, if you don't mind, so that we can get people queued up. Members of the public wishing
to provide comment on this item can do so by calling the phone number and using the access
code provided on this slide. And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in,
I do want to ask Vice President Strauss as the accountability liaison if she has any initial
comments. President Darling-Hammond, so let me just say I appreciate Lindsay and the presentation,
discussion of the study. I think sometimes it's always good to go back and look at what we've
done and hear voices from stakeholders help us get better. And what I believe is this is a true
illustration of continuous improvement and progress. Again, as I look at districts and how
they work with their stakeholders and engagement from 2013 when we first started this process
to now, I think people have really developed and engaged in a far more sophisticated and
inclusive way than we did overall at the beginning of LCFF. And so I think that this is a reflection
of continuous improvement and the priority of family and parent engagement and how we measure
that. I'm excited about the statewide family engagement network as a structured way to make
sure we get a balance of voices. Araceli Simeon was a member of CPAC and really helpful in our
process there. And I believe that this will help us to do a better job to make sure we're getting
both hard and soft data to make sure we're informing the best practices. So thank you
again for the presentation and I support the recommended changes. Thank you. Terrific. And
Member Record, do you have a clarifying question? Your hand is up on my...
Okay, very good. Then seeing no other clarifying questions, we'll go to public comment if we have
any. Yes, we currently have three callers in the queue. Reminder, if you would like to speak to
this item, please call in at this time. Caller number one, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. Yes, I'm hoping to speak to agenda item number seven.
Am I at the wrong place in line here? Okay, you'll need to call back for item number seven.
Thank you. Okay, thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Aracely Zinion and I'm the Director of the Parent Organization Network.
Last Friday, we submitted a letter in support of CDE's proposed revisions to the LCFS Priority 3
self-reflection tool and to offer additional recommendations. When considering these
recommendations, I urge you to refer to Dr. Mike Hurst-Fremar, pondering about the impact of
LCFS in the classroom and the transformation of teaching and supporting professional development.
Research on the self-reflection tool shows that the LCFS and Priority 3 are having an impact on
family and community engagement, but the gains are greater in community engagement and felt
more strongly at the district level. However, if we invest in strengthening family school
and family teacher partnerships, we can get to improve outcomes for students and for schools.
So I urge you to adopt the three recommendations in our letter, seeking to increase transparency
on the engagement process for the self-reflection tool and to strengthen guidance and professional
development to implement Priority 3. Thank you. Thank you, caller. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, President Hammond-Darling and State Board. I'm Dr. Marlene Batiste,
Director of State and Legislative Affairs for CABE. We support the points raised in the LCFS
equity coalition letter to strengthen the tool as follows. Add a prompt similar to that in the
LCAP template and instructions for stakeholder engagement that requires LEAs to describe who
participated in completing the Priority 3 self-reflection tool and how. Direct CD to engage
stakeholders such as county offices of education, CCE, et cetera, develop guidance, for example,
rubric, facilitation guides, and modified survey questions to support LEAs in carrying out Priority
3 self-reflection tool to standardize the scale rating and to identify best approaches and develop
initiatives to build staff capacity regarding family engagement and then integrate the component
into the system of support. We finally include family engagement in the list of the professional
development topics funded through the Educator Excellent Block Grant and other related funding
sources or programs for educator professional development. Thank you so much. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. Lucero Chavez on behalf of the Parent Institute for Quality Education
or PRINQUE, the National Family Engagement Organization by Eastern California and part
of the LCFS equity coalition. Speaking of coalition support, CDU's recommended changes
to the local indicator self-reflection tool for Priority 3. We recommend further strengthening
the tool to ensure that districts have what they need to improve their family engagement practices,
such as adding a prompt similar to the LCAP template, directing CDE to engage stakeholders
to develop guidance to support LEAs in carrying out the tool to standardize the scale ratings
and build capacity regarding family engagement and include family engagement in the list of
professional development topics funded through the Educator Excellent Block Grant and other
related funding sources. In short, we urge the board to direct the CDE to dedicate more time
and resources to develop guidance and coordinate efforts across CDU divisions and education
agencies to develop research-based practices for family engagement. Thank you for your time
and consideration. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now. Hello, this is Elizabeth Guillen with Public Advocates. I would like to
echo the comments of my colleagues in the equity coalition about strengthening the self-reflection
tool. In short, we agree with our partners in the family engagement network, particularly
in the parent organization network. LEAs that have greater knowledge of family engagement research
tend to rate themselves lower on the scale because they recognize their weaknesses,
while many LEAs rating themselves higher describe overly basic practices that are unlikely to result
in truly effective family school partnerships that improve outcomes for students in schools.
We think LEAs need more guidance to understand the tool and its utility for self-improvement.
We urge the board to direct staff to make these small improvements to the self-reflection tool.
Thank you. Thank you. This is last call for item number six. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Strout,
Deputy Superintendent Stephanie Gregson, Jessica Sacco calling on behalf of Children Now.
I want to thank the CDE for bringing forward this item and simply align my comments with
the previous four callers from the equity coalition and keep my comments brief. Thank you.
Thank you. This concludes public comment for item number six. Thank you.
All right. With that, let's see if there's any discussion from the board.
Are there comments or questions from board members? Member Sun.
Yes. Hi. Thank you for the excellent presentation. My internet dropped off,
so I had to re-log in. I apologize. I missed a part of it. I wanted to just make a general
observation around some of the specifics of this reflection tool, which I'm also seeing in the LCAP
as well, is that I think in our efforts to try to guide and nudge LEAs to be more specific
in their narratives, that we are actually doing something where we're making the
responses much more choppy. There's these narratives that are in boxes now, and the questions
tend to repeat themselves. They'll start with, for example, based on the analysis of stakeholder
input and local data, briefly describe blah, blah, blah. Then the next question will start
with the same one again. You have to really read to get at what each different question is. Then
in the end, the LEA is providing very short-term answers or short answers to something that I
think should be more comprehensive. I understand the reasons for it. I'll support the
recommendation, but I just wanted to bring up that I feel like we're now getting to a point where we're
sacrificing the larger storytelling of what's happening in these LEAs, which was the original
intent of the LCAP and of these analysis tools for the sake of trying to get at details, and now
we're actually getting really choppy. I just wanted to raise that concern. Any other questions or
comments? Thank you. Very quickly, I want to echo what Member Sun just said and add that
I would like to see a reflection that ends with how did this lead to student achievement? How did
this lead to reducing dropouts? How did these particular actions, instead of just come to a
meeting, sign in, you participated in decision-making, but was there a, and I didn't see that and perhaps
maybe it's in here, but I would like to see a little bit more of that, more thought add to the story.
Not thought, that was the wrong choice of words. There's a lot of thought in this.
The more outcome from the meetings or the parent engagement.
Any other comments or questions?
Number Glover Woods. Thank you. I just wanted to say I appreciate the comments that were previously
made. I thought the breakout of the narrative into three separate prompts actually was very helpful
to be able to ensure that, again, we're able to hear the story from the LEAs, but that each of those
areas of the narrative are very critical, and having them divided in the way that they were
allows for a response to be given to each. I definitely see how it could be felt to be choppy
as well, but from my perspective, I think really getting the information for each of those narrative
prompts in each of the areas is most helpful to all stakeholders and anyone who might be looking
at this reflection tool. Any other comments or questions?
Seeing none, oh, is there somebody? No, well, I just wanted to add on that.
Understanding that we want to try to get to some of these details, and it may help guide
the thinking for LEAs. I would rather see us put effort more into the professional development,
into the training of the responses rather than kind of changing the check boxes. I'm just afraid
we're growing into a trend where these analysis tools are becoming more of a compliance checklist
and rather than a broader reflection and a narrative that really cohesively
discusses their thoughts and their plans.
Okay, any other comments or questions?
I'm sure the staff will reflect on these ideas, and we are in a moment where we need to
move forward and approve where we are with this tool, so I need a motion if there is one.
Oh, Member Strauss, I see that your hand went up. Did you want to make a motion or did you want to
make a comment? Yeah, I'm glad to make a motion, but I just want to make a motion.
Did you want to make a comment? Yeah, I'm glad to make a motion, but I just want to clarify what
Member Sung said. So, Member Sung, are you saying that the part that's divided out into three
separate pieces you would say is doing that choppiness? Is that what you're concerned about?
Well, yeah, I'm just seeing that the same kind of strategy is in our current LCAP,
and we're starting to go down the road of separating out these questions into blocks,
and it just, again, I think just blocks the flow of the overall thought. So again,
I will support the recommendation. I just wanted to raise this as an issue and for us as we are
continuously looking at our templates to think about that. So, a global general comment,
and I would just say I would support the thinking going forward that we don't end up with so many
separate little boxes that it becomes just a bureaucratic rather than getting the result
that we really want, which is a deeper thoughtful reflection connected to the data and the input.
Yeah, that's exactly my point. Thank you. And I think it's related to the point that
Member Rodriguez was making about to the extent that the narrative can also say,
these are the things we did and here's how we think it supported some of our goals for students.
That's also part of that desired narrative, and then the kind of thinking we want.
Then my question is to Lindsay Tornatore. Is that something that going forward your division will
take in consideration for additional modifications going forward? I know we need a recommendation on
this today, but I don't want to lose the message that it's going to become so choppy and so many
little different pieces that it won't get the result that we really hope for in the end.
Yes, Member Strauss, absolutely. And thank you all members for your comments on this feedback
and observations noted. Definitely we will take this into consideration both in how we message
out to the field during our professional development, our collaborations with CESA and
CISC LCAP collaboration calls, and also as we continue to get ready to bring some new revisions
to the LCAP template to you at upcoming board meetings. Thank you, much appreciated. So with
understanding that CDE will be continuing to look at this and in further recommendations will take
our comments into consideration, I move approval of CDE's recommendation of the four actions
to the revisions of the self-reflection tool for priority tree.
I think I'll second that. I second. Oh, there's already a second. We have several seconds, but I
heard Member Glover Woods first, I think. Thank you. Any other discussion of the item?
All right, Brooks, let's do our roll call vote.
President Darling-Hammond. Yes. Member Patel. Yes. Member Glover Woods. Yes. Member McQuillan.
Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member Rodriguez. Yes. Member Rucker. Yes. Vice President Strauss.
Yes. Member Son. Yes. Motion carries now. Terrific. Thank you, Lindsay and Lisa. We have earned
ourselves another 10-minute break. I'm going to ask that you put the public comment slide back up
now because we can allow people to queue up for item number for the waiver items, which is
coming next. And there's not a lot of time after we introduce this item for people to get in the
queue. We don't want to lose anybody who may want to make a comment. So that slide is up there.
People who want to comment on waiver items one through 12 can get themselves ready.
In about 53, let's come back at by 3.05. Give you a couple of extra minutes and get that
coffee for that mid-afternoon jolt. And we'll see you at 3.05. Don't leave the meeting. Just
turn off your video and your microphone. All right. Welcome back. Board members, we need
to reestablish a quorum. So Brooks is going to call the roll. President Darling-Hammond.
Here. Member Patel. Here. Member Glover Woods. Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Petillo-Brownson. Here. Member Rodriguez. Here. Member Rucker. Here. Vice
President Strauss. Here. Member Son. Here. Have a quorum. All right. We're going to take up our
waiver consent calendar, which includes waiver items one through 12. We'll now open the phone
line for the public comment queue, and members of the public wishing to provide comment can call
the phone number and use the access code provided on the slide. And since we've had that up for a
little while, we can find out if there is any public comment on those waiver items.
Yes. We have three callers in the queue. Once again, please make sure that you are only calling
in for waivers one through 12. If you're calling for another item, please call back
for that particular item. First caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now. SBE members, my name is Sheila Fletley, and I'm a classroom teacher
representing the California Teachers Association. CTA would like to express our continued concern
with the funding determination process for non-classroom-based charters that have been
outlined in past letters to the SBE, especially given past statements made at the ACCS that the
NCB funding determination process is pro forma. CTA believes that there must be heightened oversight
and transparency regarding these charters. With the extended moratorium, we believe that CDE and
SBE should be investigating whether NCBs are using funds appropriately
and how the funding determination process can be overhauled. Specific to the NCB in this item,
MAAC community charter, we're glad to see a rare funding request that complies with the existing
rules around funding levels and does not ask for a waiver for 100% funding that is not warranted.
Thank you. Thank you, caller. The last two callers dropped out, so there are no more callers in the
queue. Public comment for waivers items 1 through 12 is now over. Okay, given that there's no other
public comment, I'll ask for a motion on waivers 1 through 12. I will move approval of the 12 waiver
items on consent. Thank you. A second? Seconded. Thank you. We'll now call a roll call vote.
Brooks, please call the roll. Member Son. Aye. Vice President Strauss. Aye. Member Rucker. Aye.
Member Rodriguez. Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member McQuillan. Aye. Member Glover Woods.
Yes. Member Fatah. Yes. President Darling-Hammond. Yes. Motion carries unanimously. Okay,
now we're going to take up regular consent items 7 through 10 and we want to open the phone line
again for queue for public comment on the consent items. If you can put the slide back up,
members wishing to provide comment on regular consent items 7 through 10,
they do so by calling the telephone number using the access code provided on the slide
that is shown now. I want to remind callers that item 7 is only about the schedule
for the development of the math frameworks, not about the content of the draft framework.
Accordingly, comments on this item should be limited to those that directly address
post schedule. If anyone wishes to provide comments on the content of the draft framework,
there will be an opportunity to provide written comment during the public comment period this
fall so the board can review and consider all feedback in detail. So with that, I will ask if
we have any public comment on regular consent items 7 through 10. We do have one caller in the
queue. Again, this is only for consent items 7 through 10. If you have general public comment,
that will be taken up after these items. Callers, now 2, please state your name and affiliation for
the record. Your time starts now. Caller, you're live. Caller ending in 9099, you're live.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Oh, hi. This is Susan Koloik. I'm a parent of a rising 8th grader in Palo Alto Unified.
I made a public comment on the current mathematics framework and the revised framework needs to have
the opportunity for public comment. Thank you for your effort on this. Thanks. Thank you, caller.
And just a reminder, we are only taking public comment about the timeline itself. There will be
an opportunity for written public comment during the public comment period, the 60-day period,
which will follow the adjustment to the timeline. If you're on this call for waiver call or item 7
through 10, please stay in the line. If you're calling in for public comment, please call back
after this item. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts
now. My name is Lori Myers with Educators for Quality and Equality, and I'm calling on behalf of
over 1,000 educators, parents, and voters. We appreciate that the CDE is taking time to implement
the extensive new additions and revisions to the framework approved by the AQC at the last meeting.
However, because of the scope of this new material and the controversy already surrounding
the framework and its recommendations, we are deeply concerned that there is no opportunity
for the IQC to review these substantive changes before the SBE votes to approve the framework
in spring 2022. Over 500 public comments have been submitted asking the SBE to comply with Title 5
California Code of Regulations section 9515 by approving a new timeline that includes the public
IQC meeting so the IQC can review the significantly revised draft and public comments and make its
recommendations to the SBE and to give the public a full 60-day review and comment period prior to
this IQC meeting in fall 2021 or winter 22. The extensive changes to the framework that need an
additional bunch to make and do the full IQC review and public comments. Thank you.
Thank you. Your time is up. And just to remind everyone of President Darling-Hammond's comments,
there will be a 60-day comment period for the math framework. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi. Good afternoon. This is Manuel Bonrostro with Californians Together. And Californians Together,
along with many other partner organizations, including Education Trust West, have really
appreciated the opportunity to work as a partner with the CFTC and IQC committees all along the way
in the development of the mathematics framework. And we definitely appreciate the responses by
members of the commission to include language from our different suggestions that address issues
from our different suggestions that address issues of equity and language access.
We support the extended time for development of the next draft of the framework and will continue
to work to improve the chapter on instructional materials and also continue to provide comments
along the way. Thank you again for your work on this important piece of guidance for educators
and have a great rest of your meeting. Thank you, caller. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
My name is Bill Lucia from EdVoice. EdVoice is in support of delaying the formal public comment
period on the revised framework. And we recommend that the board direct the superintendent and the
executive director of the IQC to ensure all applicable provisions of Title V and the Ed
Code are followed with respect to both academic grade level standards, content, and the process
of adoption. In addition, as highlighted in our letter, students don't rise to low expectations.
EdVoice is concerned about proposals that recommend all students remain in the same minimum
competency math sequence through the 10th grade and mandating non-mathematic content be added to
the content of pedagogy of math instruction. As we noted in our letter, frameworks become mandatory
criteria for evaluation of state adopted materials and these proposals are not consistent with
adopted grade level academic mathematics standards or consistent with current and confirmed research
as required. Thank you. Thank you, callers. Just a quick reminder, this is only for
our consent item seven through 10. The math framework item consists only of the timeline,
not the content of the framework. Please limit your comments to the timeline only.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Kari Lofeng and I'm a board member with California Association for the
Gifted and a district coordinator for gifted education services in a Northern California
school district. California Association for the Gifted has been heartened and is grateful that
the authors of the math framework have promised to make these significant revisions to the draft
that was presented to the IQC in May and that they have asked for the additional time
to get California to better support California's gifted students. Because these revisions are
indeed promised to be so extensive, we respectfully ask that the document be viewed as a draft
and not yet finalized for review by this esteemed body. Rather respectfully, we ask that the draft
document be returned to the IQC for robust discussion, review, and public comment before
being returned to the State Board of Education. Thank you caller. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Yes, my name is Michael Malione and I'm a parent in Piedmont, California and I've been following
this adoption timeline or the timeline for reviewing and given the delay five months
and the amount of rewriting that was requested, it seems to me that this really falls into the
category of another draft and so it should be handled as such. It should go to a 60-day public
review before going to the IQC and then coming back for a final review and that would seem to
be the appropriate timeline that should be followed in this case given the circumstances
and given all the public comments that there were the last time around. Thank you.
Thank you caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time
starts now. David Margulies, parent in California and I am also calling,
I'm calling to request that the SBE add an IQC meeting and a public comment period to the
mass framework schedule. I personally do not understand for something as important as our
kids' education why it is even being considered acceptable to deny this. The first draft sparked
significant controversy as shown by all the newspaper publicity. There is even an open
letter to the SBE and IQC signed by almost 500 California scientists and technology fields
objecting to it. Therefore, shouldn't the IQC be at least allowed to have a meeting on this?
For a large amount of parents, we did not even hear about what was happening in the framework
until the newspaper started publicizing it and by then it was too late to public comment on the
draft. So a large amount of parents were not able to. It is only fair that we get a chance to comment
on the education of our kids. It seems devious to not allow the IQC to review and not allow public
comment. In the introductory presentations for this meeting, there was quite a bit of mention
about the California way. Well, hopefully the California way is not to bypass commissions
and deny public comment. Thank you, caller. Your time is up. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. My name is Dr. Julie Nyberg and I serve as
Executive Director for the California Association for the Gifted. Thank you to the State Board of
Education for supporting advanced learners in California. We would like to recommend the public
have a 60-day review of the document in draft form followed by a review by the IQC to review
the draft version of the math framework. The California Association for the Gifted would like
to recommend that universal access to talent development and gifted services are provided at
every school site and explicitly encouraged in the math framework to nurture great minds in a
golden state. Failure of the California public education system provide access to an advanced
mathematics curriculum that is reinforced by gifted and talented services, systemically enhances
the excellence gap and reinforces disparities with students who are underrepresented, underserved,
and are from varying cultural, racial, ethnic, linguistic, and socioeconomic backgrounds. Data
from the Office of Civil Rights has revealed that American Indian, Alaska Natives, Black, Latinx,
Native Hawaiian, and Pacific Islander students are under identified in California and therefore
not receiving gifted and talented services which constitute intellectual needs in mathematics.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Yes, hi. My name is Kathy Jordan. I'm a parent of a student in public school
and given that we may be denied an opportunity to give public comment later, although I also
echo that we should have another opportunity of public comment. I wanted to ask that the
California math framework be modified to accommodate students taking Algebra 1 in 8th grade and to aim
for completion of calculus in 12th grade in that math sequence and progression. This math framework
and its attempt to lower math standards conflicts with the goal and purpose of the California Math
Placement Act. In attempting, its purpose and goal was attempting to help students of color
and other students to reach and complete calculus by grade 12. This California math framework
instead attempts to ensure that students of color and other students do not reach and complete
calculus by the end of 12th grade. This seems as though it's seeking to treat everyone the same.
Thank you caller. Your time is up. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. Good afternoon, Jessica Sacco on behalf of Children
Now and the California STEM Network. I'm just calling in support of the extended revised timeline
in order to allow the writers sufficient time to incorporate the edits requested by the IQC while
continuing to maintain the document's fidelity to equitable math instruction for all students.
Thank you. Thank you caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Yes, my name is Krista Landgraf and I'm a teacher in the Chino Valley Unified School District.
I'm calling to thank the writers for one for their continued commitment to a thorough rewrite of the
California math framework and public comment and specifically I would like to see a public
full 60-day draft review and comment period either this fall or the winter of 2022 and also
an opportunity to schedule a public IQC meeting with members to review the revised draft and allow
for public comment. Thank you. Thank you caller. This concludes the public comment period for
consent item seven through ten. Thank you. Thank you very much. At this point we can take any
further conversation from the board if there is any.
All right, do I have a motion then? Linda, I did raise my hand. Oh sorry,
it's not popping up. Thank you. No problem. I just wanted to thank everyone who has been involved
both with the IQC on the board and has sent in comments today as well as emails concerning
the revision on the mathematics framework and timeline. Today's item is only about the timeline
not approving the content of the math framework itself. The revision of the mathematics framework
as you all will recall was the first framework that this board approved after the adoption of
the common core and the revision of that framework has been a multi-step process throughout that
revision process. There were multiple opportunities for public input at educator focus groups,
at the framework curriculum committee meetings, the instructional quality commission as well
as state board meetings and during two different 60-day public review periods. So I did hear that
there were concerns about following the opportunities for public comment. The revised timeline
outlines some major steps in the framework revision process and it's important to note
that during the IQC's last meeting in May, the panel made some very specific recommendations
to revise the document based on the field review comments and that revision work is continuing now.
Given that there will likely be enough time for another public check-in between now and next May
when the board is expected to take action to approve the framework, I think it is appropriate
to add a placeholder on the calendar for another opportunity for public comment and review and
further discussion at an IQC meeting should it be needed and I would suggest putting that placeholder
for an IQC meeting in early 2022 that can follow the next planned 60-day public comment period
that's in the timeline that we will be approving with this item today and I would also suggest
giving our executive director as part of the approval of this item the authority to call the
meeting. So your proposal is first of all you've clarified that as we know there still will be
another 60-day response to the draft so that is clear in any event and you're suggesting that
we simply give the executive director the authority if there is a if it appears warranted to convene
the IQC yes in the time period yes okay that sounds reasonable to me is there any objection
to that approach that makes a lot of sense I am seeing no distension so with that I would like
to see if we have a motion to approve the consent items does consent item seven through ten I will
move to approve consent item seven through ten okay and do I have a second I'll second it
all right we'll hold the roll call vote Brooks please call the roll number son
yes vice president Strauss yes member Rucker yes member Rodriguez yes member Petillo-Brownson
yes member McQuillen yes member Glover Woods yes member Fatah yes president Darling-Hammond
yes motion carries unanimously terrific we are reopening item one to approve the revised March
2020 meeting minutes and the preliminary report of actions draft May 2021 meeting minutes and to
report on our liaison assignments and so we need the public slide public comment slide to go up
again for comment on the revised SBE minutes for March 11 12 2020 and SBE draft preliminary
report of actions minutes for the May 12 13 2021 meeting if we're if there's any public comment
please use the phone number on this slide and include the participant access code
and while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in do I have a member motion from
the board member to approve the revised March 11 12 2020 state board of education report action
meeting minutes and the draft preliminary report of action minutes for the May 12 13 2021 meeting
I move that we approve both sets of minutes as read okay thank you do I have a second
a second thank you very much are there any public comments
we do not have any public comment at this time all right is there any further discussion
seeing none
none board members please raise your hand in the participant panel of zoom
and brooks will keep track of the raised hands
oh I know that's that's that's if we have discussion sorry I was looking at this I was
like why are we doing a roll call vote that way brooks please hold the roll call vote of course
thank you uh president Darling Hammond yes member Patah yes member Glover Woods yes member McQuillin
yes member Patilla Brownson
yes sorry member Rodriguez yes member Rucker yes vice president Strauss yes member Sun
okay so we're now going to go to the board member liaison reports and I want to invite members to
report on liaison activities that are not related to any items on our March agenda please uh uh
offer your comments um and we're going to go and reverse alphabetical word and begin with the
one president Darling Hammond we lost audio there for just a second oh okay let me say it again we're
going to do our liaison reports uh and we ask that you report on our liaison activities that are not
related to items on our March agenda and we're going to do our liaison reports uh and we ask that
you report on our liaison activities that are not related to items on our March agenda
and begin by calling our members okay very good yeah I will be very short because a number of my
liaisons were covered in items two three and four today the only quick report I have is that the
California workforce pathways joint advisory committee is continues to work on its California
plan for um career technical education and we meet in August and I'm sorry I didn't quite
expect that August 6th will be our next meeting date and that's all I have perfect uh vice president
Strauss um yes um I'm going to skip the IQC report because member Rucker did share an update
member Rucker did share an update and I believe our materials review will be shared by liaisons
I did want to share President Darling Hammond and I are both members of the quantitative reasoning
steering committee as part of CSU looking at a fourth year of math requirement that would be
quantitative reasoning and it has a lot to do with us thinking about students being prepared
for mathematics and success after high school and so there is a research study being going going on
based on data from lab from fall of 2020 and there'll be a report presented to the CSU
trustees in March of 22 um expecting the proposed timeline would be 2026 and the entering class of
fall of 27 I know that sounds really far away but things do progress and it takes you a while to
take a look at coursework and teacher preparation meanwhile the chancellor's office at CSU are
supporting course and teacher capacity to help students get the best first instruction in
algebra and to reduce failure rates so there's a whole project that are dealing with math and
science teacher initiatives there's an increase in in teacher preparation enrollment which looks
exciting and so I just wanted to share that because we are talking about mathematics and
I think thinking about K through higher ed is an important pathway to consider
the concurrence commission met on june 5th that's the subject matter projects and they're talking
about responding to the call for racial justice and looking at the role of leadership development
and what the role of the california subject matter project is so a couple of updates that I
think are really interesting based on the discussion with dr cursed earlier about teacher capacity
there's a lot of summer institutes going on on new frameworks building capacity and looking at
teacher pipeline there's also because it's online it actually has increased the access for rural
educators to have access to statewide professional development which I think is really exciting going
forward and they're building a community of teacher leaders both locally and statewide and
looking at the teacher shortage issue so just understand that our subject matter projects
are working hard and do support our work the advisory commission on special ed met on june
16th looking at a study on governance and accountability and the budget impact one of
the highlights if you're interested in looking back at the video there was an item after lunch
on voices from the field where administrators and special ed
sopas talked about strategies for reopening schools for all students and they shared some
really nice lessons and looking at how assessment and professional development so right after lunch
on the axi agenda um really helpful and um lastly the last week on june 24th and 5th the
california collaborative but district reform talked about the issues of returning to school
and I think important to think about is what the promising practices are like we talked about on
the sr item earlier we heard voices of students and from teachers and how important it is to
include teacher well-being as well as student well-being and how hard and exhausting the last
year has been there was also a good discussion which expands what we've been talking about
what is the evidence for equity and improvement and what are date what are data sources we can
use so I think it's important that we think about that as we return to school
and there's a lot of work with our our partners in really trying to collaborate and help
making sure that funding is strategically used in a way that supports sustainability and growth
that ends my report thank you terrific thank you member rucker thank you as board member
sprout said we've already covered the iqc on multiple items today and board member son has
briefly spoken about the joint advisory committee on june 25th of this year the department of
education in comp in in collaboration with a number of really important sponsors put on the
early math symposium the conference itself was an amazing success and I think a model of effective
online engagement among the participants and among the stakeholders who work to put this plant
this program together I'm always amazed at how both the participants and the presenters
can use technology to stay connected and how people continue to adapt to work in an online
environment and make the presentations interactive the presenters are presented in fact from so many
different places from california tennessee chicago illinois new jersey and even italy
the conference was telecast around the world and there were participants in the conference from
every continent as I said in my opening remarks for the conference I've always had a professional
fantasy of bringing the world into my classroom for the first time in my life and probably the
only time I actually had the opportunity to speak to the world the recorded sessions for
the 2021 early math symposium are available to anyone who wants to look at them on youtube
I also want to report on my work with the military compact there is a new program being
launched called the purple star school program it's a new project to recognize schools that
show a major commitment to students and families connected to our nation's military military
connected students move a lot the purple star program is designed to help students respond
to educational and social emotional challenges that military connected children face during
their transition to a new school and also to encourage schools to pay attention to what it
means to help keep those students on track to matriculate through school schools that earn a
reward will receive a special purple star recognition to display on site and schools
that qualify this school year will be announced in april the month of the military child
and and then finally i am continuing my work with the significant disproportionality work group
each year california submits a compliance report to the federal office of special education
programs osep we get straight a's on that report except in one area the over identification of
students of color for participation in special education programs for quite some time department
staff have been engaged through this work group with stakeholders from pro program cohorts around
the state to develop and implement a state performance plan to address the disproportionate
representation by race and ethnicity of students receiving special education services the arc of
this work has resulted in a refined procedure to identify schools with significant
disproportionality the state has more accurately reviewed lea work on delivering special education
services and has now been able to identify with statistical confidence the lea's that must address
over identifying students particularly african-american boys this highly technical work
to identify schools with significant disproportionality now needs to shift to
focus on how to address the problem so i'm looking forward to the july 28 2021 work group meeting
where the discussion will turn to planning supervising supporting and developing technical
assistance that's the end of my report okay member rodriguez yes thank you so i have three
reports one related to the summer school for the arts ctc and then the adoption of the world
languages and arts materials so the california summer school for the arts is currently in session
i attended the welcoming ceremony on sunday and it was so exciting to see over
500 people in a zoom all of them with their cameras open and the enthusiasm of the students
411 students i believe was the last count who attended the online school for the arts
and it's a it's a state program although there is a tuition that is
you know that goes along with the application process but there's also a foundation that
supports students who can't afford the four weeks you know in working with
master teachers incredibly impressive teachers heard from some of the alumni
and and i learned a new word poggers i didn't know that word i know a lot of slang from
teaching high school and i kept seeing poggers poggers when they would get excited in the
in the chat box so it was fun and one of the so you know the disciplines are animation dance film
music theater visual arts and writing and the applications by discipline were higher in
animation visual arts and then writing we also had applicants who were from
and participants actually from other countries because this is a very attractive program because
it prepares students who actually who want to work in these fields but this time around
and maybe because it was it was uh you know done online we had um 787 applicants from california
11 from texas seven from new york five from new jersey five from china seven from canada
and five from the uk so one of the under the direction of matthew gallagher who's the new
executive director and he's been he's fairly new he's really pushing for more diversity and more
statewide representation and the opening ceremony really reflected that because we do have students
who are underrepresented um black students uh american indian and hispanic latino are
definitely misrepresent are underrepresented um you know if you look at the statewide demographics
so that is uh a an objective of his to increase the participation statewide and also only about
five or six counties are represented los angeles county being the um the largest one and i'm going
to share a website uh with the public and with the board members and it's www css for three s's
ava exhibitions.com and you can see some of the work that the current students are producing
and some of the art professors it's again incredibly exciting i left the welcome ceremony
just so inspired um to see the enthusiasm i've never seen a chat box that busy with like yeah
you know and the students just being you know just uh so excited and happy to be there and we know
how powerful the arts are for growth for other type of learning and and especially i think for
processing a lot of the um what you know at least in in the opening ceremony processing a lot of
what we've been through in the last year and a half so um i'll move on to ctc and uh the
california classified school employee teacher credentialing program which is a state grant
program that helped classified school employees earn a teaching credential has added about 800
new teachers to the california classrooms over the last five years um according to the report
given at the june um the june 16th and 17th ctc meeting uh in 2006 the state budget allotted 20
million and 25 million dollars for the second round in 2017 for this program the 2021-22 state
budget that the legislator approved this week includes 125 million for the program so it's one
of the responses that california took to address the teacher shortage that has left many classrooms
without fully credentialed educators the report that was shared at june ctc meeting
was prepared for the ctc by shasta college and while it found that the program has met
the objectives of the legislature legislators i'm sorry um there are a list of recommendations
giving guidance as the program continues um there were some disparities when it came to
school districts that uh the way they manage you know different school district manage different
programs so it's recommended that there uh be a limit on the management costs to ensure that
the teacher candidates across the state are given similar amounts um and then with the passage uh
president darling hammon mentioned the uh 2021 state budget agreement and there's a lot in there
for um teacher preparation so um some of the there's some testing flexibility
and um this extends the previously adopted windows of time when candidates for a teaching
or admin credential can defer certain required tests because access to the test was limited by
19 um school site or testing center closures
suspends the requirement to complete the california
administrator performance assessment um the candidates must complete the requirement
prior to earning a clear credential though so it doesn't it doesn't um you know cancel it it just
gives extra time there's more flexibility suspends the requirement to complete the rica the reading
instruction competence assessment prior to early earning a preliminary credential if the candidate
is unable to meet it between march 19 2020 and december 31st 2021 the commission may extend the
deadline to june 30th 2020 due to testing center closures or capacity um and that will be revisited
suspends the requirement to complete the c best prior to enrollment in the teacher preparation
program again the commission um may extend the deadline suspends the requirement to complete
the c set right which are the california subject examination for teachers
also within the same time frame there's a credential fee waiver 20 million in a one-time
general fund to provide a credential fee waiver in 21 22 for individuals earning entering the k
through 12 workforce um applies only to initial applications for the following documents
preliminary multiple subjects single subject education specialist
preliminary administrative services special language pathology pathologist services credential
pupil personnel preliminary school nurse preliminary teacher librarian clinical rehabilitative
services child development permits substitute permits and teaching permit for statutory leave
uh fee waivers are not valid for renewal costs with currently licensed credential holders
um dyslexia grants to preparation programs um two million dollars in a one-time general fund
to update program curriculum and course offerings to align the common trunk teacher performance
expectations the update education specialist teacher performance expectations and include
pedagogy on dyslexia computer science supplementary authorization incentive grant
establishes 15 million grant program available over a five-year period to increase the number
of teachers authorized to teach computer science teacher residency grant program 300 million
increased from 250 million i'm sorry 350 million increased from 250 million
um residencies pair a new teacher with an experienced mentor for one year
and um grantees may receive up to 250 uh 25 000 dollars uh per participating teacher
and let's see um president darlene hammon talked about the national board certification incentive
and i will um move on to the arts education instructional materials adoption
and the world languages instructional materials adoption which are underway currently underway
on monday the training was held um for both and it was incredibly well organized participants
commented as much and it was you know to sum it up the day included uh the why right why are we here
how how are we going to go through this process and it was just so well articulated in charts
with like you know this is how we're going to do this with sample charts um and you know based on
the discussions that are had and then uh and then the what if which was actually a lot of fun
it was scenarios with like well what if this happens right you know and how are we going
to handle that so um the arts team will meet july 19th so next week through the 23rd for eight to
five uh 8 a.m to 5 p.m and world language will meet the following week uh july 26 through july
30th uh from eight to five thank you that was a lot it was i have to ask what is poggers what
does poggers actually mean so poggers is like yay very excited and it comes from pog and i had to
look it up and i wanted to make sure it was something appropriate because i kept seeing in
the chat what poggers poggers all right well now now we have a new word that we can use in our
state board meetings yes uh member patio brownson
um and i have to say as you said pog all i could think of was pineapple orange guava juice is that
related but yes cheer okay um so i um i'm going to uh give a a brief recap of the july excuse me
june 9th early childhood policy council meeting this was prior to the adoption of the state
budget though the state budget certainly was a large topic of discussion um and our board chair
our madam president has already described the biggest headline of the proposal for and now
adopted law um around universal transitional kindergarten which is very exciting and expected
to serve around 400 000 students across the state at full implementation also very exciting to see
the teacher professional development and pipeline expansion investments alongside what i think
is is really part of an ongoing emphasis on addressing equity in the early years really
to prevent the achievement gap before it happens by expanding universal tk but also maintaining
all of the seats for three-year-old california state preschool to ensure that low-income children
in california have two years of preparation and come into kindergarten ready to go
um at that same meeting there was also a presentation of polling data
for parents of children across the state inclusive of five-year-olds in the k-12 system
and what was striking really was that among single parents in particular more than a
quarter of those parents were actually feeding the children less or skipping meals during the
pandemic as they were dealing with economics uncertainty three quarters of parents in the same
category were expressing worries about their children's social emotional cognitive educational
development and again connecting back to the state budget process i think what our our board president
outlined was a host of educational investments but also there were a number of wraparound investments
that i think are equally exciting to think about in terms of child tax credit to actually enable
more economic security and part of parents and families there was the inclusion of 0 to 5 for
the first time called out explicitly mental health services act for mental health service provision
all of which i think to this whole child vision that madam president had described earlier so all
around still excited and just flagging and maybe what is obvious that so many of these investments
really are first for not just california but for the nation and there is so much excitement and
attention i think that california is getting from leading the way and explicitly leading the way
for thinking about early learning as a tool to actually promote more equitable and fair outcomes
for kids have always been
poggers
member navo oh he he is no longer here member mcquillin all right thank you
i'm looking forward to the joint task force on the career technical education also on august 6th
his next meeting a lot more to report
the superintendent mentioned that over at the department of education the
american indian oversight committee is being reestablished restarted again i'm excited to
hear that and i've heard some of the appointees to that committee and
really good people to sit on that committee i'm so glad it's starting back up again
and i too am a very excited about all the new resources available to california students to
support our students out of the pandemic and and to help with the learning loss i'm just excited
about all the new resources it's a new day in education in california and looking forward to
to that as long as we don't have this variant or the delta variant getting in our way and
and i'm really concerned about that also
that's all i have thank you all right thank you very much and it is exciting that the
task force is being reestablished in the department i think that's another sign of progress
another occasion for a member glover woods thank you member rodriguez did touch a bit on the world
languages instructional materials deliberation that's coming up so i'm just going to add a
little bit to that again just a reminder it is going to take place the week of july 26
through the 30th and the team has been doing their individual review of materials over the
last couple of months and on that week of deliberations we will be looking at a total of
11 programs that have been submitted by four different publishers and there will be nine
programs that will be looked at for spanish and two for french so we're quite excited and looking
forward to the robust conversation that will take place at the end of the month and that
concludes my report thank you thank you and member fatah yeah definitely so um this past month uh
actually from i believe it was june 23rd to the 25th um don't quote me on that though i hosted the
ed 100 academy for student leaders and so that had uh brought in 400 students who joined in for
almost all three days and they got to hear from amazing speakers such as sal khan our very own
brooks allen uh who who spoke um and and just a plethora of other speakers who talked about kind
of different facets of um ways in which students can impact education so that was a lot of fun
um i've also begun training our upcoming student board member rana i know that she's watching
right now because i got a text just uh recently saying poggers so um it's great to see her already
kind of taking initiative and getting ready for for her term and i look forward to working with
her um and and yeah i i in other news i graduated so um always always nice uh but um yeah this has
just been such an awesome opportunity uh and uh i look forward to training rana
and that concludes my liaison report awesome awesome uh and i am last in the queue and i sort
of gave my report at the beginning of the meeting um but i will simply uh just add in the context of
the assessment liaisoning that um member sun and i did there are these very robust conversations
going on about assessment innovations including in the smarter balanced consortium uh where the
the set of states are looking together at a number of ways to continue to improve what is our core
assessment in cask for english language arts and math and talking about ways to make it more
supportive of the teaching learning process during the year uh and among the things that
the smarter balanced consortium is uh is a whole considering is the movement of some of the
performance task activity into the classroom during the school year so there will be
ongoing conversations between and among the 15 states of territories that comprise smarter
balanced california will be part of those conversations and will be coming to echo record
information as that unfolds it's exciting to think about that as a part of the new normal that may
emerge and with that we have concluded our liaison reports we'll take up item
11 which is general public comment we're going to put that public comment slide back up there again
the public comment is invited on any matter that is not included in the printed agenda and we will
open up the phone line for public comment if you want to make a comment use the numbers shown on
public comment slide in the access code that is there i'm going to wait about 60 seconds because
it takes there's a lag in the process of viewers getting the recording of our meeting so we don't
want to cause anyone to miss the opportunity for public comment so with that in mind we're going to
take a few more seconds to allow people to call in and queue up before we call for public comment
and i'll ask i think it might be pam who's on duty with the comments to let us know
uh in the next minute or so if you do have anyone who has called it at this time we have no public
speakers uh for uh or no no callers for public comment we'll give it another 30 seconds just
because we don't want to cause anyone who really wants to speak to be able to do so given that leg
so we'll do our wait time we do have one person uh caller please speak your name
and affiliation for the record your time starts now
uh sorry to throw in a public comment so late in the day and keep you from concluding your
your work uh on this difficult long day i wanted to put one issue on as a possibility for a future
agenda item and that's something called the lcap portal this is a this is a data collection tool
that was funded the development of which was funded in last year's budget in june 2020
unfortunately the entire 2021 school year was spent simply doing the contracting around this
tool we really want to see this tool move forward there's 450 000 from last year's budget to do that
and we think that really starting to figure out what this tool could be would be of benefit and
aligned with a lot of other board priorities in particular the continuous improvement process
of having just supporting districts learning from each other and lcff fiscal transparency we
think it will be really helpful in both of those fronts and and merits and attention from the board
to figure out what this thank you caller your time's your time's up
that was the last public comment
all right well uh with that i will hereby adjourn our july 2020 state board of education meeting
at 403 pm and i look forward to seeing you all at our september 2021 meeting
and we'll let you know if it's going to be on zoom or in person
take care zade best of luck zade going forward we're gonna miss you yeah